Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Jetzt Milito. Milito macht es alleine. 70.
Minute.
0 zu 2. Bastian Schweinsteiger.
Schweinsteiger an den Pfosten. Ribéry. Ribéry.
Und das ausgerechnet haben Sie gesagt. Herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, zum Tribünengespräch Männer, die ins Mikrofon brüllen. Nein, nicht ganz, auch wenn es dieses Intro suggeriert. Wir wollen sprechen über das, was passiert ist. Nicht nur in diesem Sommer mit dem zweiten Trippel für den FC Bayern in der Saison 2019, 2020, sondern wir wollen den größeren Bogen aufmachen im gesamten Jahrzehnt. Deshalb habt ihr alle vier Finalteilnahmen der Bayern aus den letzten, je nachdem, wie man zählt, zehn oder elf Jahren gehört, je nachdem, ob man nach Saisons geht oder nach Kalenderjahr. Und ich begrüße euch recht herzlich zu diesem ersten Tribünengespräch nach unserer Sommerpause. Mal gucken, wie verrostet, eingerostet ich noch bin. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich freue mich, dass ihr zuhört und ich freue mich, auch eine illustre Runde hier begrüßen zu dürfen. Grüße gehen raus an eine bekannte Stimme des Rasenflungs... Rasenfunks, da fängt es schon an. Flo Jan Bogner von Eurosport, Ed Flo, Pumuk auf Twitter. Servus, Flo.
Die Zugänge, also Gündogan kam dann eben zur Saison 2011, 2012 vom 1. FC Nürnberg, war eigentlich so mit Ivan Perisic der wichtigste Zugang zu dieser Saison, wo dann eben der Titel verteidigt wurde. In der Saison vorher war es eben nur, um nochmal kurz das für alle zurück in die Erinnerung zu rufen. Ab dem 6. Spieltag stand man auf Tabellenplatz 1, also vorher schon einmal, aber ab dann, ab dem 10. Spieltag, Entschuldigung, und Dortmund hat diese Tabellenführung einfach nicht mehr hergegeben. Und das ist gar nicht so häufig passiert in der Bundesliga-Historie, dass eine Mannschaft, die sich schon früh vor die Bayern an die Spitze setzt, sich dann auch von egal, was die Bayern tun, nicht aus der Ruhe bringen lässt und dann die Bayern auch nochmal locker in deren eigenen Stadion besiegt. Das kommt natürlich auch noch mit dazu. Zu Hause hatte man auch gewonnen gegen Bayern München mit einer taktisch überlegen geführten Mannschaft und aber auch einem Trainer, der dem standhalten konnte, was so eine Tabellenführung mit dir über lange Phasen macht. Also das war auch, glaube ich, wichtig damals für zumindest die Wahrnehmung von Borussia Dortmund, dass Jürgen Klopp im Grunde bis zur 89. Minute am 34. Spieltag, ich übertreibe jetzt ein bisschen der Wahnsinn, schon Meister, aber bis dann hat er gesagt, na wir sind ja der Underdog. Also, Entschuldigung, aber das ist ja völlig lächerlich. Meisterschaft? Nee, wenn die Bayern erstmal aufwachen, hui, dann ziehen die an uns vorbei und wir, wir müssen richtig dagegenhalten und wir werden jetzt, aber wir haben uns jetzt was erarbeitet, darum kämpfen wir. Wir werden sein wie die Piranhas. Das hat er ja angeblich vor dem Spiel in München gesagt, jagt sie wie die Piranhas. Das war auch noch ganz wichtig für die Wahrnehmung von Borussia Dortmund, dass Jürgen Klopp es, meiner Meinung nach, auch in der Retrospektive gesehen, sehr gut geschafft hat, das Erwartungsmanagement so zu halten, dass die Mannschaft auch überhaupt so performen konnte, wie sie es dann auf den Platz bekommen hat. Da waren ganz einzelne Wachsler, waren da immer mal wieder drin in einzelnen Spielen, aber Dortmund hat in dieser Saison auch wirklich viele Spiele einfach gewonnen über die Überlegenheit der Summe seiner Teile, weil man ein sehr, sehr gutes System hatte mit sehr vielen guten Einzelspielern und hat sich dann auch von Bayern einfach nicht mehr einholen lassen. Und am Ende waren es ja zehn Punkte Vorsprung vor den Bayern und sieben Punkte Vorsprung vor Leverkusen. Leverkusen war der größte Konkurrent von Dortmund im Endspurt dieser Saison.
Sie haben hinten raus in der Saison aber drei von den letzten neun Spielen verloren.
Ja, das stimmt, genau. Das war schon sehr überlegen. Und dann eben die Saison danach, wo alles noch besser wird. Und wir sprechen jetzt hier schon vom Bayern-Trainer Jupp Heynckes. Der kam zur Saison 2011, 2012, am 1.7.2011. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, Flo, dass man in den Aufeinandertreffen, die es früh in der Saison gab und auch in den Spielen sonst von Bayern, früh schon vermeintlich Elemente vom Kloppfußball entdeckt haben wollte. Eben Ansätze eines Pressings, aber das hat in der Saison 2011, 2012, meiner Meinung nach, noch nicht so richtig gegriffen bei den Bayern. Und vor allem in den direkten Duellen hatte man immer noch Probleme, einfach irgendwie ein Spiel aufzuziehen, wie man es sonst gewohnt war. Also Bayern hat sich da immer quasi außerhalb der Komfortzone bewegen müssen gegen Dortmund. Was hat denn da letztlich dann bei den Bayern in der Saison 2011, 2012, noch gefehlt, deiner Meinung nach?
Der ein oder andere individuell starke Spieler mit Sicherheit noch. Wenn man dann das ja draufnimmt, wo Bayern Champions League-Siegler wird, dieser Javi Martinez, der war einfach unfassbar wichtig für diese Mannschaft. Und diesen Spielertyp hatten sie halt das Jahr vorher eben nicht. Einfach diese Verbindungsspiele, die sind auf der einen Seite Abräumer vor der Abwehr, aber auch einer, der zu dem Zeitpunkt zumindest noch einen guten Verbindungsspieler im Aufbau geben kann, der hat einfach gefehlt in der Saison 2011, 2012. Und wenn man sich da die Aufeinandertreffen gegen Dortmund anschaut, ich glaube, Bayern verliert zweimal 0-1. Zu Hause glaube ich Götze 0-1, im Moment der zweite Halbzeit und Bayern findet einfach keine Lösung, keinen Weg. Die individuelle Klasse, auf die sie ja schon immer sehr angewiesen waren, von Ribéry und von Robben irgendwie zum Tragen zu bringen, weil die werden auch die ganze Zeit gedoppelt. Dortmund scheint irgendwie einen mehr im Mittelfeld zu haben. Und das steht denen die ganze Zeit auf den Füßen. Der Großkreuz doppelt die ganze Zeit. Und das passt denen alles gar nicht. Und im Rückspiel, da war es, glaube ich, dann schon eher auf Augenhöhe. Weil da Bayern dann auch in einen Rhythmus und in ein Fahrwasser gekommen ist in der zweiten Jahreshälfte 2012, der richtig gut war. Und da macht, glaube ich, Robben verschießt einen Elfmeter und Lewandowski macht das Tor.
Genau, also in der 77. Lewandowski 1 zu 0 und dann Robben Elfmeter 86. Minute wäre das 1 zu 1 gewesen. Er verschießt in Devin Subotic, diskutiert mit ihm noch freundlich über die Auswirkungen dieses Fehlschusses für die Saison.
Ja, genau, so diplomatisch ausgedrückt. Also bei Bayern fehlte, glaube ich, noch so ein bisschen, man muss ja auch mal sagen, dass Jupp Heynckes zu dieser Mannschaft noch mal kam. Also Jupp Heynckes war so ein Relikt der 90er gefühlt. Oder eigentlich sogar schon der 80er. Klar, er hat dann mit Real 98 nochmal die Champions League gewonnen, aber der tingelte dann so über Benfica und Teneriffa. Und irgendwie, er bei Schalke landete, glaube ich, 2003, 2004, was fürchterlich schief ging. Und dann war der eigentlich irgendwie so weg vom Fenster. Und nur weil Uli Hoeneß mit ihm gut befreundet war und Uli Hoeneß auf die Idee kam, ich brauche jetzt den Jupp, um diese Klinsmann-Havarie irgendwie noch zu einem versöhnlichen Ende zu bringen und ihn einfach für die letzten vier Spieltage dieser Saison 2008, 2009 zu verpflichten, kam, glaube ich, Jupp Heynckes überhaupt erst wieder so an die Oberfläche des Bundesligageschäfts und hat dann relativ, also was gut war für ihn, dass Leverkusen eben auf die Idee kam, ihn dann eigentlich vom Standtrack, vom Interimstrainer der Bayern so zu verpflichten. Und bei Leverkusen hat er dann zwei Jahre einen guten Job gemacht. Und dann kam Bayern eben nochmal auf ihn zu und hat gesagt, komm, lass uns doch nochmal probieren.
Wo der Franz Beckenbauer damals gesagt hat, Mensch, wenn der Jupp uns geachtet, er möchte nochmal, dann hätten wir ihn doch gleich genommen. Um das kurz zu unterstreichen, das war nämlich noch so eine Sache, an die konnte ich mich noch vage erinnern und ich hab's jetzt schnell gecheckt. In der Auftaktsaison von Heinkes als Trainer von Leverkusen 2009-2010 ist Leverkusen 24 Spieltage lang ungeschlagen geblieben. Also das war quasi der Einstand von Jupp Heinkes bei Leverkusen.
Exakt, also der hat da wirklich eine sehr überraschende Entwicklung genommen, wo jeder dachte, der Jupp ist so ein alter Typ, der eigentlich mit Kando spazierend, ich weiß nicht Kando, müsste da schon gelebt haben, mit Kando spazierend, also der Hund von Jupp Heinkes, der Hund, der Schäferhund, irgendwo durch Gladbach laufen und ansonsten mit Fußball hat er aber nicht mehr so viel am Hut. Und das hat er widerlegt. Und er hat das halt sehr klug widerlegt. Also er hatte, anders als früher, als er als sehr streng galt, glaube ich, einen sehr guten Zugang zur Mannschaft gefunden, einen fast väterlichen Zugang auch zu den Spielern gefunden, weil einfach auch die Altersmäßige Distanz gegeben war, die ihm vielleicht in den 90ern, Anfang 2009, nicht geschenkt war per se. Aber er hat eben auch ganz klug verstanden, eben schon Elemente von Pressing, von Gegenpressing auch zu adaptieren für Dortmund, ganz klar. Aber eben auch neue Ideen einzubringen, die jetzt vielleicht nicht so alltäglich für einen Trainer in den 60ern seines Lebens sind. Die hat er aber auch in Leverkusen schon gezeigt. Bayern war dann nochmal so diese Komplementierung dessen, was er in Leverkusen dann schon vorgestellt hatte. War es für mich zumindest so ein bisschen.
Und gleichzeitig war das eine emotional komplett überdrehte Saison beim FC Bayern. Und das hing eben auch mit dem berühmten Finale zuhause im eigenen Stadion in der Champions League zusammen. Also zum einen hing damit zusammen, dass man vielleicht in der Rückrunde auch manchen Punktverlust auch daran festmachen kann. Bayern war noch Herbstmeister geworden, ist eine der wenigen Spielzeiten der Bundesliga-Geschichte, in der nicht der Herbstmeister meister werden konnte. Dortmund hat mit einer überragenden Rückrunde diese Meisterschaft fix gemacht. Und es führte unter anderem zu einem denkwürdigen DFB-Pokalfinale, was ja zeitlich gesehen vor dem Champions League-Finale stattgefunden hat. Und genau eine Woche davor, ein Ergebnis, an das sich alle BVB-Fans und vielleicht auch viele Fußballfans in Deutschland sehr gerne erinnern, ein legendäres 5 zu 2, mit dem Borussia Dortmund den FC Bayern im DFB-Pokal besiegt, der eben eine Woche später versuchen will, im eigenen Stadion die Champions League zu gewinnen und der ja schon in der Liga von Dortmund die ganze Zeit besiegt wurde. Steffen, war dieses Pokalfinale vielleicht in der Rückschau betrachtet der Tiefpunkt dieses ganzen Jahrzehnts in der Bayern-Geschichte?
Ich verrate jetzt mal ein Geheimnis. Ich habe ja bis heute, habe ich öffentlich zumindest oder auch in Gesprächen mit Freunden und so weiter immer gesagt, dass mir das 2 zu 5 eigentlich total egal war, weil das wichtige Spiel war ja ein paar Tage später.
Verrate ich dir ein Geheimnis, das habe keiner geglaubt.
Das war gelogen. Nein, absolut ein ganz, ganz bitterer Moment. Vielleicht ein bisschen so wie für Barcelona jetzt dieses 2 zu 8 vor ein paar Wochen. Interessanterweise auch von der Spielweise ein bisschen ähnlich, weil Bayern bis zum 2 zu 1 sogar leicht besser ist. Macht das 1 zu 1 durch einen Elfmeter, dann fällt das 2 zu 1 und bricht dann aber völlig auseinander. Und man sieht, wenn man sich dieses Spiel anschaut, das ist wirklich interessant, weil es viele Dinge offenlegt, die bis heute Teile der Probleme von Bayerns Spiel ausmachen, vor allen Dingen im Bereich der Restverteidigung. Du siehst immer wieder diese Szene, wo der FC Bayern kollektiv nach hinten sprintet und es eben nicht gelingt, da eine Formation zu finden, dann so einen Konter zu verteidigen. Das gelingt ihm immer mal wieder, aber wenn wir in den letzten Jahren über Schwachpunkte im Bayernspiel geredet haben, war es das. Und das hat Dortmund eben mit Götze, mit Lewandowski, mit Kagawa, eben auch kleine, flinke Spieler da im Zehnerraum, die diese Lücken einfach bestmöglich genutzt haben. Ja, und Bayern fällt wirklich auseinander in diesem Pokalfinale. Und wie gesagt, man konnte sich das schönreden, weil man gesagt hat, okay, da kommt das Finale noch hinten drauf. Gab es aber nicht. Ich will vielleicht noch einen Satz zu Dortmunds Rückrunde sagen, weil die, glaube ich, wichtig ist. Dortmund scheidet aus in der Champions League Vorrunde und hat deshalb in der gesamten Rückrunde den vollen Fokus auf die Liga und den Pokal, was, glaube ich, auch ganz, ganz wichtig ist, insbesondere bei so einem intensiven Spiel, wie Jürgen Klopp es spielen lässt. Und bei einer doch vergleichsweise unerfahrenen Mannschaft. Das kam Dortmund schon, glaube ich, sehr stark zugute. Und wenn wir später vielleicht auch noch mal darüber reden, woran es eigentlich liegt, dass es in der Bundesliga so schwerfällt, den FC Bayern da auch vom Thron zu stoßen, glaube ich, ist das schon ein Faktor. 2010, 2011 hat Dortmund, glaube ich, gar keinen internationalen Wettbewerb gehabt. Oder Europa League, aber eben nicht mit dieser Taktung wie in der Champions League und 2011, 2012 eben früh raus gewesen. Das ist ein wichtiger Faktor in diesen zwei Jahren für Dortmund. Als ich mir das Pokalfinale dann nochmal anschaute, konnte ich mir nicht verkneifen, mir noch mal die eine oder andere Stimme danach anzuschauen, die es gab. Weil es ganz schön ist, was aus heutiger Sicht draufblickt, oder zumindest aus Münchner Perspektive draufblickt. Aki Watzke sagte nach diesem 5 zu 2, ich habe gelesen, die Münchner wollten zeigen, wo der Hammer hängt. Ich kann nur sagen, der Hammer hängt in Dortmund. Lars Walroth und Julian Wolf haben für die Welt einen großen Kommentar geschrieben. Dortmund ist der neue Maßstab im deutschen Fußball. Es war übrigens auch der Sommer, wo sich Marco Reus dagegen entschied, nach München zu wechseln, sondern zu Borussia Dortmund ging. Das haben viele auch als Signal genommen, dass das mehr ist als nur Dortmund ärgert Bayern, sondern dass da eine wirkliche Wachablösung stattfindet. Ich zitiere noch mal aus diesem Weltkommentar, weil ich es wirklich ganz passend finde. Als sich die Gerüchte verdichteten, dass Mario Götze ein lukratives Angebot aus Süddeutschland vorliegen soll, verlängerte Dortmund dessen Vertrag zu deutlich erhöhten Bezügen. Auch das unterscheidet den neuen Pokalsieger von früheren Bayern-Konkurrenten. Mittlerweile kann der BVB auch finanziell den Angriffen standhalten. Ein Blick auf die Ersatzbänke zeigt, dass die Münchner auch in Sachen Kader-Tiefe längst die Hoheit verloren haben. Bayern ist nicht mehr das Maß aller Dinge in Deutschland. Gegen den BVB wirkt der Rekordmeister retro.
Es ist insofern interessant, wenn da jetzt kurz die Zahlen mit reinkommen, dass Dortmund in der Tat, was Personalkosten angeht, in dieser Saison einen Sprung gemacht hat. Also von der Saison 2010, 2011 zur Saison 2011, 2012 hin. Ein deutlicher Sprung. Man liegt da knapp unter 200 Millionen Euro, die eben für das Personal aufgewandt werden. Der Sprung bei den Bayern ist wesentlich kleiner, allerdings auf anderem Niveau. Da liegt man fast bei 300 Millionen Euro. Also sprich, es gibt noch eine Lücke zwischen den beiden. Aber enger wurde es selten zwischen diesen beiden. Also dass diese Lücke nicht ganz so groß war zwischen ihnen. Und bei Bayern tut sich tatsächlich auch finanziell in dieser Phase relativ wenig. Die großen Einnahmesteilungen, die ja dann auch mit TV-Geldern zu tun haben, um mit dem Abschneiden international, da kommt ja dann nochmal extra Geld her, die werden erst noch kommen. Also tatsächlich von den Zahlen her deckt sich das so ein bisschen. Aber wir sehen ja dann, dass es dann irgendwie anders kommt. Und die Dimensionen sind halt schon auch noch andere. Also ich verstehe das, dass du eine Genugtuung empfindest, wenn du im Nachhinein als Bayern-Fan diese Zitate liest. Aber finanziell sind ja die Verhältnisse immer noch völlig klar. Und die Bayern spielen ja auch keine schlechte Saison. Also sie zerbrechen ein bisschen vielleicht an den Emotionen im DFB-Pokalfinale. Sie zerbrechen definitiv an ihren Emotionen dann im Finale der Horm. Und sie haben Probleme in den Spielen, in den direkten Spielen gegen Dortmund. Alles andere läuft aber schon relativ geschmeidig beim FC Bayern. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass da eine große Lücke zwischen diesen Vereinen wäre. Und deswegen kann es dann auch nicht so komplett verwundern, dass, also ich finde, da muss man jetzt keinen Helden-Epos draus machen, auch wenn die Geschichte in der Saison so schön ist, dass dann nach dieser Saison dann ein Triple folgen wird mit eben einer wichtigen Verpflichtung mit von Javi Martinez. Sondern ein bisschen ist das auch einfach der Lauf der Dinge, wenn du dir die wirtschaftlichen Kräfteverhältnisse in der Liga anguckst.
Ja, das sehe ich schon ein bisschen anders. Also, was die wirtschaftlichen Kräfteverhältnisse angeht, okay. Aber ich empfinde sicherlich, wenn man im Nachhinein draufschaut, kann ich nicht verhehren, dass ich auch ein bisschen Genugtuung empfinde. Aber das war ja auch mein Gedanke in dem Moment damals. Also, du verlierst das Finale 5-2 gegen Dortmund. Du bist seit zwei Jahren chancenlos gegen Dortmund. Du verlierst dann dieses Champions-League-Finale in München, was sich so anfühlt, wie, okay, das kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich fünf, sechs, sieben Jahre nicht mehr wieder. Weil das ist normalerweise, dass man zwei Mal innerhalb von drei Jahren überhaupt im Finale steht. Das ist ja schon auch für die Bayern-Historie sehr außergewöhnlich gewesen. Und dann kommt am Ende noch eine Europameisterschaft hinten drauf, wo insbesondere die Bayern-Spieler ja auch als die Gedemütigten, als die Loser, als die Verlierer sozusagen vom Platz gehen. Und natürlich kann man jetzt im Nachhinein sagen, naja, ist doch logisch, weil die finanzielle Basis ist ja da. Aber ich würde schon sagen, das ist... Du hast dann zwei Möglichkeiten, was du als Mannschaft und als Club in so einer Situation machen kannst. Entweder zerbrichst du wirklich daran und sozusagen verfilzt dann die eigene Prophecy und machst genau so weiter. Oder du ziehst dich halt wirklich da raus und schreibst daraus eine große Geschichte. Und wenn du mich gefragt hättest, was die wahrscheinlichere Geschichte gewesen wäre, in dem Moment hätte ich gesagt, ich glaube eher, diese Generation geht eher unvollendet zu Ende. Und es geht jetzt darum, mit Heinckes irgendwie einen Übergang zu organisieren, dass das daraus gefolgt ist. Und dann auch in so kurzer Zeit, im nächsten Jahr, finde ich jetzt schon schwierig, das klein zu reden im Nachhinein.
Nee, also ich tendiere ein bisschen mehr zum, also ich verstehe den Aspekt, den der Steffen bringt, aber ich tendiere auch ein bisschen mehr zu dir, Max. Der Lauf der Dinge war einfach in Richtung Bayern. Das ist ganz klar mit der größten Wirtschaftlichkeit, mit dem doch auch in der Breite besser aufgestellten Kader, war es klar, dass Dortmund nicht noch einen dritten Meistertitel irgendwie dahin zaubern kann. Vor allem, weil du bei Dortmund dann auch gemerkt hast, dass eben dann auch der Fokus auf die Champions League gelegt wurde, die dann eben gesagt haben, okay, auf zu neuen Zielen. Wir versuchen jetzt natürlich auch in der Champions League eine bessere Rolle zu spielen, als wir das das Jahr vorher gemacht haben, wo es ja gar nicht aufging. Und dieser Tanz auf drei Hochzeiten hat Dortmund dann natürlich auch ein bisschen Power in der Bundesliga genommen. Und bei Bayern hast du eben gemerkt, diese Anstrengung, wir müssen jetzt auf jeden Fall mal wieder Meister werden und alles andere. Schauen wir dann mal, wie das funktioniert. An den Champions League-Sieg hat ja im Stillen nach diesem dramatischen Finale Dahoam haben natürlich alle gesagt, das kann es jetzt nicht gewesen sein. Das müssen wir irgendwie noch mal packen. Aber jetzt den Champions League-Sieg nach dem Finale Dahoam hat glaube ich keiner sofort als Ziel ausgegeben, weil auch alle das erste Mal mit sich selber beschäftigt waren und erstmal mit diesem Trauma auch ein bisschen beschäftigt waren. Aber ich habe schon auch gesehen, dass relativ schnell dann ja auch so Parallelen gezogen wurden dann zum Trauma von 99, dass die Mannschaft damals dann in einem 2-Jahres-Schritt 2001 zur Bewältigung genutzt hat und gefühlt war das aber eben 2012 auch so, dass man eher dachte so, okay diese Mannschaft hat noch was im Tank, diese Mannschaft kommt vielleicht auch noch mal ins Champions League-Finale, aber bestimmt nicht in Back-to-Back-Seasons, also auch gerade nach der EM mit den Voraussetzungen Bayern hatte in den Jahren, in den letzten 2000er und Anfang 2010er Jahren, ja auch immer dieses nach einem großen Turnier war eigentlich eher erst mal die Luft raus, weil die Mannschaft einfach durch ist, weil Verletzungen dann zum Tragen kamen und also Bundesliga-Titel war schon so ein bisschen eingeloggt, natürlich immer mit einem Fragezeichen, aber dass dann das Treppel rausspringt, das war Das war dann wirklich die große Leistung dieser Mannschaft und des Jupp Heynckes vor allem.
Wir haben dann die EM damit auch schon ein bisschen abgeharrt. Ich finde, die ist jetzt mit dem Kontext des deutschen Fußballs da auch wichtig zu betrachten. Das ist die EM, in der man gegen Italien mit 1 zu 2 rausgeht, vorher schon gegen Griechenland mit 4 zu 2 gewinnt. Und wo man jetzt im Nachhinein sagen kann, diese atmosphärischen Störungen zwischen dem Bayern-Block in der Nationalmannschaft und dem Dortmund-Block, die scheinen tatsächlich eine große Rolle beim Abschneiden bei diesem Turnier gespielt zu haben. Dazu gibt es jetzt genügend Aussagen von beteiligten Spielern aus dieser Zeit. Mal kurz die Aufstellung aus dem Spiel gegen Italien. Ich will jetzt nicht über taktische Formationen reden. Das wurde damals genug gemacht. Er sollte Andreas Pirlo in Mandeckung nehmen. War das nicht der Plan? Hab ich Andreas gesagt? Freunde wie ich dürfen ihn ja Andi nennen. Also die Ausstellung, wir haben neue im Tor, Lahm, Badstuber, Hummels, Boateng, Badstuber, Hummels. Gerade in dieser Kombination spannend. Auch was eben da Abstimmungsprobleme angeht, auch die Frage, wie da Tore gefallen sind. Zum Beispiel das erste von Balutelli, da rückt Hummels aus der Kette raus. Das zweite da ist Philipp Lahm, ein bisschen zu langsam in eine Umschaltbewegung. Nach eben einem Pass von Andy Pirlo. Kedira Schweinsteiger, die Doppel-Sechs, ist geblieben. Podolski Ösi, groß eben auf dem rechten Flügel, beziehungsweise so hat er eigentlich dann im Finale nicht so ganz gespielt und Mario Gomez vorne im Sturm. Also wir haben im Grunde schon eine Blockbildung, die sich ja auch schon 2010 wieder so angedeutet hat. Das war ja nicht immer so in der Nationalmannschaft. Aber diese beiden Blöcke greifen noch nicht so wirklich gut ineinander. So ist quasi die kurze Geschichte der EM 2012 zu erzählen. Und um noch kurz das Bild der Bundesliga aufzumachen. Hinter Dortmund und Bayern landet Schalke auf Platz 3, hat in der Vor-Saison auch den Pokal gewonnen. Gladbach wird eben mit Marco Reus, der aber eben dann zu Dortmund wechselt. Vierter qualifiziert sich für die Champions-League-Qualifikation. Leverkusen fünfter und Stuttgart und Hannover sind noch in die Qualifikation zur Europa League gekommen. Das war damals das Bild. Die großen Vereine, was so Transferströme und Umsätze angeht, unter anderem zum Beispiel Werder und auch den HSV kann man da nennen. Ich habe euch ja vorhin die Top-Transfers des HSV genannt. Die spielen keine Rolle. Der HSV rutscht bis auf Tabellenplatz 15 ab. Und Werder habe ich ja vorhin schon mal angekündigt. Da geht nicht mehr viel in diesem Jahrzehnt, was internationalen Fußball angeht, bei Werder Bremen. Das ist auch nochmal eine wichtige Entwicklung. Dass auch gerade die Europa League-Teilnehmer, die changieren jetzt immer wieder durch. Also da haben wir mal Mainz, mal Freiburg, mal Hannover, mal Stuttgart, mal Hertha und so weiter und so fort. Das ist immer schön für die beteiligten Vereine. Die können aber selten das dann wiederholen in der kommenden Saison. Das schaffen eigentlich nur Vereine mit anderen Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten, wie zum Beispiel Wolfsburg, wie dann später auch Hoffenheim. Und so ist es eigentlich schwer für alle Bundesliga-Vereine, die nicht Dortmund und Bayern sind, auf etwas aufzubauen. Schalke 04 versucht das die ganze Zeit, baut aber auf Schulden auf, um es mal ein bisschen zu überspitzen. Und das ist ein Problem.
Und Leverkusen ist Leverkusen.
Und Leverkusen ist Leverkusen. Ja, genau, Leverkusen hat natürlich auch ganz gute Möglichkeiten finanziell, verabschiedet sich ja aber auch in dieser Phase von den großen Transfers. Also wir sprechen ja auch über, also da kamen ja dann auch andere Faktoren der weltweiten Wirtschaft mit dazu bei Leverkusen. Ja, aber das ist so ein bisschen die Situation in der Liga. Also heute ist es ganz normal für einen. Aber meiner Meinung nach ist eben genau dieses Jahrzehnt, über das wir sprechen, da schon wichtig für gewesen, warum Dortmund und Bayern dieser Liga immer weiter entwachsen. Also Dortmund holt in der Saison 2011, 2012 noch ein Punkterekord. Und Jürgen Klopp sagt, also der wird jetzt erstmal für die Ewigkeit bestehen. 81 Punkte hat Dortmund da geholt. Eine Saison weiter. Und damit sind wir jetzt dann in der Trippesaison angekommen, holen die Bayern 91 Punkte und verlieren nur einmal in der kompletten Saison. Und das ist dann eben die Saison von von Heinkiss, über die wir schon etwas gestritten haben jetzt, was da die Faktoren waren. Aber ich glaube, bei einem sind wir uns einig, Flo. Entscheidend war der Neuzugang von Javi Martínez, der damals ja auch minütlich mit Flight Trackern und allem Möglichen begleitet wurde, für den die Bayern auch in eine neue Dimension geprascht sind, was eben Ablösesummen angeht.
Also diese 40 Millionen, die waren damals wirklich empfunden. Und das für einen Spieler, der jetzt keinen Weltruhm hatte, bis dahin angehäuft. Also man hatte so die Ahnung, dass das ein guter Spieler sein könnte, so im Gro der deutschen Fußballlandschaft. Aber so richtig definieren oder festmachen, dass das jetzt wirklich der heiße Scheiß ist, konnte man das, glaube ich, nicht. Ich glaube, man hatte schon so ein Zutrauen, dass Bayern damit was richtig macht. Aber dass es auch wirklich richtig ist und dass dieser Spieler dann auch wirklich so funktioniert. Und wirklich dieser Missing Link ist in dieser Mannschaft, das war schon so ein bisschen ein Fragezeichen dahinter. Aber es hat einfach extrem viel Sinn gemacht, mit Martinas und Schweinsteiger auf dieser 6er-Position zu spielen. Schweinsteiger, der halt einfach dieses Spiel so gut eröffnen kann, der den Rhythmus vorgeben kann im Mittelfeld, der natürlich auch arbeitet, aber eher der 8er ist und halt einfach einen 6er braucht, der hinter ihm da klar Schiff macht, der aber auch eine Kopfballstärke noch mitgebracht hat. Das war Henkes auch immer unglaublich wichtig, dass er genügend Kopfballspieler auf dem Platz hatte, gerade für die Defensive, gerade auch für die Standardverteidigung. Und alles andere, also ich glaube, Ribéry war schon auch häufiger mal verletzt in der Saison, oder war zumindest auch mal verletzt in der Saison. Robben war tatsächlich so ein Thema mit Henkes. Also ich kann mich da erinnern in der Saison, dass Robben ein paar Mal auf der Bank saß und da auch richtig stinkig war. Aber ja, also dieser Martinez-Transfer, der hat einfach unglaublich viel Sinn gemacht. Und was man auch nicht vergessen darf, es kam auch noch ein, war das vor der Saison, der Verteidiger aus Gladbach, der da kam? Also Danci kam rein, der, ja, wo auch jeder gesagt hat, Verteidiger von Gladbach, Gladbach hat irgendwie da auch mal Relegation gespielt mit dem und so. Was wollen die jetzt mit dem? Der ist ja auch schon irgendwie, der war schon fast 30 zu dem Zeitpunkt oder 29. Aber der hat einfach einen Arbeitsethos an den Tag gelegt als Brasilianer auch. Der hat auch Karl-Heinz Rummenigge im Vorgespräch in der Anwarnung des Transfers auch unglaublich beeindruckt, mit welcher Einstellung der Danche an diese Aufgabe der FC Bayern rangegangen ist. Und auch der hat sich einfach unglaublich gut eingefügt in dieser Abwehr und hat dann auch letztlich den Platz eingenommen, den Holger Badstuber durch seine schwere Verletzung in der Partie gegen Dortmund im Dezember 2012 durch seine Kreuzmann-Verletzung irgendwie freigegeben hat. Also da rückte dann plötzlich gleich einer nach und einer rein, der dann da einfach einen super Job gemacht hat. Also Dante, was hatten wir noch, Boateng, die haben sich dann da quasi als Duo gefunden. Und van Beuthen war dann nur noch so der Backup in der Innenverteidigung. Und diese Stabilität durch die Innenverteidigung und den Sechser, Martinez davor, die hat diese Mannschaft stark gemacht.
Eigentlich heute kaum mehr vorstellbar, dass Dante, wie auch immer man ihn korrekt ausspricht, über zwei Drittel der Saison eigentlich der deutlich stärkere Innenverteidiger war als Boateng. Also man merkte richtig, wie Boateng, der immer noch in dieser Phase so ein paar Wackler drin hatte. Ich erinnere mich auch an das Spiel in Borisau, wo er da, ich glaube, vom Platz fliegt und Bayern da verliert oder der Olympischen spielt, weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr. Boateng richtet sich eigentlich diese ganze Saison so an Dante so ein bisschen auf. Du merkst halt, Dante kommt mit diesem Selbstvertrauen und diesen auch positiven Eindrücken aus Mönchengladbach. Der hat diese ganze Scheiße in Anführungsstrichen ja nicht mitgemacht und hat deshalb auch so ein bisschen diese Unbekümmerteid und dieses Selbstvertrauen auch irgendwie wieder reingebracht. Fast bis zum allerletzten Spiel der Saison, dann gegen Dortmund im Champions-League-Finale, wo man dann auf einmal merkt, okay Boateng, der ist viel mehr. Also der wird jetzt nicht einfach nur mitgeschleppt und wird ständig darüber diskutiert, ob er irgendwie zu viele individuelle Fehler macht. Sondern der kann richtig Weltklasse werden. Und der hat sich richtig an seinem Partner, an der Innenverteidigung, wirklich aufgerichtet. Der hat ihn lange mitgezogen und irgendwann war Boateng dann eben auch voll da. Manzukic kommt auch dazu. Wie gesagt, ein Transfer, der ein bisschen interessant zustande kam, aber der unheimlich wichtig ist, gerade wenn es um die Duelle gegen Dortmund geht. Weil, obwohl Bayern auch in den Spielen gegen Dortmund sich insgesamt verbessert hat, auch im Spielaufbau, haben sie gegen Dortmund immer noch deutlich mehr lange Bälle gespielt als gegen jede andere Mannschaft, weil eben dieses Pressing so stark war. Und Gomez, der ja ein bisschen eine tragische Figur ist, weil er seine zwei besten Saisons, 2.10., 2.11., 2.11., 2.12. hatte, wo er wirklich getroffen hat wie am Fließband. Aber eben diese Saisons, die sind nicht so richtig halt positiv in Erinnerung bleiben. Aber der vor allen Dingen eine Schwäche hatte, und das war das Kopfballspiel gegen die Dortmunder Innenverteidigung, egal ob der Hummels oder Santana oder Subotic oder wer auch immer gespielt hat. Und Mansukic hat es halt eben geschafft, aus diesen langen Bällen durch seine Kopfballstärke, aber auch dadurch, dass er einfach so unangenehm ist und im Zweifel zumindest den Dortmunder Innenverteidiger irgendwie mit einem Ellbogen bearbeitet hat, so dass er nicht den Kopfball kontrolliert in Richtung Shaheen Gündohan spielen konnte, hat es dadurch ermöglicht, dass Bayern auf einmal frühere und höhere Ballgewinner hatte, auch gegen Dortmund. Und das war sowas von enorm wichtig, weil es Dortmund eben nicht gelungen ist, nach jedem langen Ball wieder sofort umzuschalten und dann in die andere Richtung zu marschieren. Insofern auch der Mansukic-Transfer, auch wenn, wie gesagt, dann jetzt nicht die wahnsinnige Strategie, glaube ich, hinter war, entpuppte sich wirklich als sehr gut. Einen habt ihr jetzt noch gar nicht erwähnt, das ist Matthias Sammer. Der kommt auch dazu vor der Saison und seine Legacy gehört ja mit zu den umstrittensten Dingen, glaube ich, aus dem letzten Jahrzehnt in München, aber muss schon eine Sache sagen, auch wenn ich gerade noch mal gesagt habe, zerbricht die Mannschaft jetzt an dieser Saison 2.11, 2.12 oder richtet sich daran auf. Er war schon derjenige, der von der ersten Minute an, damals im Trainingslager im Trentino, gesagt hat, es gibt hier überhaupt keine Ausreden, es gibt keiner, braucht hier Mitleid, das sind alles gestandene Profis und der damit irgendwie so den Ton rund um die Mannschaft ein Stück weit verändert hat nach seiner Ankunft und unabhängig davon, wie man seine Arbeit danach bewerten kann, ob die jetzt positiv war, ob die egal war, weil er irgendwie keinen Einfluss hatte. Ich glaube, dass er so dazu kam und dann einfach auch diesen Ton und die Atmosphäre und den Fokus rund um die Mannschaft von der ersten Sekunde an verändert hat, auch das war glaube ich wichtig, wenn es darum geht, da wieder in die Saison stark zu starten.
Genau, dazu gehört dann eben auch noch mal das Finale Dahoam im Rückgriff, da also wie das Spiel verlaufen ist, also als du vorhin zum Beispiel, Flo hat gesagt, dass ja Jupp Heynckes immer wichtig war bei Standards, kopfballstark zu sein. Da hat Didier Drogba kurz auflaufen müssen, als er diesen Podcast gehört hat und dann eben aber die Art und Weise, wie Christian Nehlinger unter anderem, dem wurde dafür die Verantwortung ein bisschen zugeschoben von der Führungsriege, es nicht geschafft hat, Schützen fürs Elfmeterschießen aufzutreiben. Also eben bis hin zu dem, dass Manuel Neuer als dritter Schütze der Bayern selbst antritt, weil andere Spieler sich nicht in der Lage dazu sahen, ein Elfmeter in dieser Hochhochhochdruckphase zu schießen. Und das scheint immer so nach allem, was man so hört, einer der Gründe gewesen zu sein, warum es eben dann auch diesen Wechsel weg von Christian Nehlinger, der ja eine Idee von Uli Hoeneß war, hin zu Matthias Sammer gab. Und der hat eben diesen Ton so anders gesetzt. Und das war ja eine Saison der Bayern, die von den Ergebnissen her eine totale Fabelsaison ist. Also das wurde jetzt später noch mal getoppt, aber damals war das schier unglaublich. Ich habe schon angesprochen, die eine Niederlage, die man in 34 Saisonspielen erlitten hat. Allein in der Rückrunde hat man kein einziges Mal verloren. 98 Tore haben die Bayern gemacht. Also man war schon damals an diesem 101-Tore-Rekord dran, den man jetzt ja einstellen konnte. Man hat nur 18 Gegentreffer kassiert, also die defensive Stabilität ein Riesenthema. Und man ist tatsächlich einfach mit Fabelergebnissen durch die Liga gerollt. Also da waren dann schon eben 9 zu 2 gegen den HSV dabei, in 6 zu 1 gegen Werder, in 6 zu 1 in Hannover. Also da hat das angefangen, da hatte man sich so langsam dran gewöhnt oder begann sich dran zu gewöhnen, dass es jetzt solche Ergebnisse in der Bundesliga gibt. Und das gab es ja sehr lange nicht mehr. Also in den 70ern gab es noch häufiger Spielzeiten mit so hohen Ergebnissen. Später hat sich das aber relativ normalisiert, würde ich jetzt sagen, ohne jetzt hier genau eine Statistik dazu rausgesucht zu haben. Da ging das jetzt aber richtig los und auch im Halbfinale im DFB-Pokal gewinnt man einfach 6 zu 1 gegen Wolfsburg und zieht so ins DFB-Pokalfinale ein. Und auch in der Champions League, da sind die beiden einzigen Niederlagen dieser Champions-League-Saison, eben von dir vorhin angesprochen, in Borussia, nach dem Platzverweis von Boateng und das Achtelfinal-Rückspiel gegen Arsenal, wo es noch mal kurz kritisch wurde, da hatte man das Hinspiel aber mit 3 zu 1 gewonnen und Arsenal hat dann mit 2 zu 0 gewonnen. Also das hätte noch mal kritisch werden können, wurde auch so kommentiert, aber das Hinspiel war sehr deutlich gewonnen. Danach hat man Juventus Turin zweimal mit 2 zu 0 besiegt, einmal zu Hause, einmal auswärts. Dann Barcelona zu Hause mit 4 zu 0 und auswärts mit 3 zu 0. Und im Grunde das wackeligste Spiel dann jenseits der Niederlagen war ja dann Steffen das Finale gegen Borussia Dortmund, wo gerade in der ersten Halbzeit im Grunde Manuel Neuer dafür gesorgt hat, dass man nicht in Rückstand geraten ist.
Ja genau wie jetzt beim letzten Finale in der Tat. Dortmund hat sich ein bisschen schwerer getan in der Liga. Hat glaube ich auch so ein bisschen dann den Fokus jetzt nach zwei Meisterschaften und Champions League diese Reise sozusagen haben sie ja noch nicht mitgemacht. Da hat Klopp es glaube ich auch geschafft, wahnsinnig viel Motivation eben draus zu ziehen. Ja und dieses Finale war in der Tat, ich glaube, am Ende verdient mit 2 zu 1, das kann man schon so sagen, aber stand natürlich zwischendurch absolut auch auf der Kippe und man konnte der Mannschaft in den ersten 20-25 Minuten wirklich anmerken, wie der ganze Film aus den letzten Jahren irgendwo wieder da war. Weil es ging wieder so los, dass die Münchner irgendwie keinen richtigen Weg fanden, sich daraus zu befreien, dass Dortmund sich Torschancen erspielte, teilweise mit zwei drei Mann dann vor Neujahr war oder man gegen drei Situationen plötzlich landete. Bayern ist es aber gelungen, in diesem Finale dann eben ruhig zu bleiben und ich glaube dafür war wichtig, dass man im Vorfeld eben auch schon diese Erfahrung gemacht hatte, diesen Fluch gegen die Dortmunder, der ja über zweieinhalb Jahre anhielt, dass man den schon mal gebrochen hatte. Ich habe mich sowohl mit Peter Herrmann als auch mit Spielern aus der Mannschaft im Nachhinein mal länger unterhalten und unabhängig voneinander haben beide dieses Supercup-Spiel am Anfang der Saison genannt, als Schlüsselmoment für die gesamte Saison und am Ende auch für das Finale, weil so unwichtig wir den Supercup empfinden, dass der FC Bayern, dass es ihm da gelangen, vor der Saison Borussia Dortmund zum ersten Mal zu schlagen, da haben die wahnsinnig Kraft draus gezogen. Das war denen unheimlich wichtig. Das war irgendwie wohl auch in der Saison dann immer mal wieder Thema. Es gelang dann ja auch in der Liga zwar nicht, aber dann im DFB-Pokal ein 1 zu 0 Erfolg durch ein herrlichen Treffer von Arjen Robben, der dann nach innen zieht und den Ball in den Winkel schlägt, wie so häufig. Und ich glaube, diese Gewissheit hat dann dafür auch gesorgt, dass man sich trotz dieser schwierigen 15- bis 20-minütigen Anfangsphase sich besann, ruhig blieb und dann sukzessive sich dieses Spiel wirklich zurückgearbeitet hat. Und Schweinsteiger und Martinez spielen auch da eine ganz wichtige Rolle. Schweinsteiger ist dann etwas tiefer eingekippt im Verlauf des Finales, hat den Ball von etwas tiefer dann dann geholt. Übrigens auch ein Motiv, dass die ganze Saison über anhielt, dass Schweinsteiger ganz viele Extra-Schichten gemacht hat, um immer wieder sich zu überlegen, wie kommen wir, gerade wenn es gegen Dortmund und gegen starke Pressing-Teams geht, wie kommen wir hier raus? Was sind die richtigen Winkel? Wo muss ich mich positionieren, um der Mannschaft zu helfen, um nicht so alibi-mäßig in die Viererkette einzukippen, sondern mich eben so zu positionieren, dass es konstruktiv wird, dass es was bringt. Und so hat sich Bayern sukzessive in dieses Finale wirklich reingearbeitet und war dann glaube ich über 19 Minuten dann auch die die leicht bessere Mannschaft.
Also ich fand das extrem offen, das Spiel. Und wir erinnern uns, es steht hier auch bis zur 90. 1-1.
Und Dante hätte auch mit Gelb-Rot fliegen können zum Beispiel.
Und Dante hätte auch vom Platz fliegen können. Und aber es gibt ja auch immer so, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, das übernatürliche des Fußballs, aber dass es dann am Ende so läuft, dass Bayern dieses Tor macht, dass Robben dieses Tor macht. Robben, der ja, wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe, eigentlich erst im Laufe der Rückrunde wieder seinen Platz findet in dieser Mannschaft, weil sich groß verletzt im Spiel gegen Juventus. Vorher favorisiert tatsächlich Heinkes Ribéry links, Große in der Mitte, Müller rechts, so verkappt. Und erst weil Großverletztes Müller dann auf die falsche Zehn rückt, findet Robben wieder Platz rechts in der Mannschaft. Ja, diese ganze Dramaturgie, das passte. Da fielen dann so diese kosmischen Puzzlestücke so ineinander. Und jeder Bayern-Fan wird ja wohl gedacht haben, es gibt einen Fußballgott. Ja, es gibt ihn. So. Aber es war ein ausgeglichenes Spiel. Und Bayern schafft es halt eben ja im Pokal Dortmund zu schlagen, ja im Supercup Dortmund zu schlagen. So als Aha-Erlebnis, auch nach dem 2-5, das ja dann auch erst ein paar Monate zurückliegt. Aber in der Liga spielen sie auch zweimal nur 1-1. Gut, das zweite Spiel war dann so ein Nicht-Angriffspakt. Aber Dortmund ist wirklich noch so der böse Geist, der über dieser Mannschaft schwebt. Und die Dortmunder beißen sich glaube ich bis heute in den Hintern und zwar kräftig in den Hintern und von Jahr zu Jahr mehr in den Hintern, dass sie dieses Spiel nicht gewonnen haben, weil es lag da. Sie hätten es nehmen können. Klar, es gibt immer noch jemanden, der sagt, ja Dante muss vom Platz. Aber da war schon auch ein bisschen eigene Schulden oder fehlende eigene, ja, die letzten Prozente da ein bisschen Schuld daran, dass Dortmund da nicht Champions League-Sieger geworden ist im Jahr 2013. Und man merkt mit Bayern hinten raus halt auch wieder so eine Latenz. Du hast gegen Barcelona den absoluten Peak. Du marschierst die Wochen vorher auch irgendwie 6-1-Pokal- Halbfinale gegen Wolfsburg, 6-1 in Hannover. Und dann nach dem Barcelona-Spiel geht alles auf dieses Champions League-Finale zu. Du machst nicht Angriffspakt gegen Dortmund, spielst da irgendwie 1-1. Und hast dann am letzten Spieltag ein 3-4 in Mönchengladbach.
Also 4-3 Sieg.
4-3 Sieg, wo du aber irgendwie, wie war das, relativ schnell irgendwie hinten liegst.
Genau, mit 3-1 nach 10 Minuten für Glatbach. Stranzl, Hanke, Nordfeit haben die Tore gemacht.
Das ist eine geile Ohrfeige. Richtig schön hergestranstelt worden. In einer Saison, wo Bayern gefühlt bis zu dem Zeitpunkt 8 Gegentore hatte, kassieren die halt mal eben 3 in Glatbach.
3 der 18 Gegentore rund um sich am 34.
Und du hast dann eben auch diese Schwere im Spiel gegen Dortmund am Anfang im Finale. Und du hast dann danach auch noch ein DFB-Pokalfinale gegen Stuttgart, wo eigentlich alles sagt, ja, also die, das geht halt auch nur gerade so mit 3-2 über die Bühne. Also da merkt man dann schon auch die Anstrengungen und die Strapazen da hinten raus. Und dass halt so ein Trippel dann doch nicht ganz so leicht von der Hand geht in den letzten Wochen einer Saison. Gerade wenn du halt versuchst, dann noch mal so ein 7 zu 0 in der Addition gegen Barcelona, das ja eigentlich schon der Peak ist, dann noch mal irgendwie zu abzubecken, hätte ich jetzt gesagt.
Aber damals ist halt der zu bestätigen. Der Ball auch immer auf der richtigen Seite des Netzes, um eine Tennis-Analogie zu verwenden, runtergefallen für die Bayern. Also da ist ja zum Beispiel das Barca-Spiel ein sehr gutes Beispiel. Zwei Tore aus Abseits und beim 1 zu 0 stützt sich, glaube ich, Dante auf. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen unverdient, Champions League exklusiv, Rasenfunk 2 für Triple an. Nee, Quatsch. Aber so wie eben in diesem Spiel in Gladbach, wo dann Ribery und Robben drehen dann das Spiel. Also Ribery verkürzt eine 18. Minute und dann macht er in der 53. ins 3-3. In der 59. macht Robben das 4-3. Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war es dann auch so, dass ich dann auch Gladbach gesagt habe, wißt ihr was?
Man muss ja auch nicht irgendwie die Bedeutung von so einem 34. Spieltagsspiel, wo schon alles vorbei ist, überhöhen. Aber es ist halt das letzte Spiel vor dem Champions-League-Finale. Und wenn du da halt irgendwie 4-1 in Gladbach verlierst, dann macht das schon was mit dir. Also deswegen hat es schon so seine Bedeutung und seine Daseinsberechtigung. Jetzt darfst du wieder weitermachen.
Genau, aber man hat eben diese Spiele gewonnen. So wie man eben auch dieses Champions-League- Finale irgendwie gewonnen hat. Da kann man ganz, ganz wunderbar darüber streiten, auch über die Entstehung des 2 zu 1 von Robben. Aber es ist eben, es ist ein Finale, es zählt dann, ob du quasi die einzelnen Dinge, ob die zu deinen Gunsten ausgehen oder nicht. Und das ist passiert. Und ein anderer Aspekt ist da aber auch noch ganz wichtig mit reinzunehmen. Also zum einen wird wenige Wochen vor dem Finale bekannt, dass Uli Hoeneß sich wegen Steuerhinterziehung selbst angezeigt hat. Die große Storyline dazu wird sich aber erst in der kommenden Saison entfalten und ja auch in der Abwesenheit seinerseits münden. Aber die wichtige, wichtige Geschichte, die auch damit dann nämlich indirekt zusammenhängt, weil es einen zeitlichen Zusammenhang gibt, einen anderen Zusammenhang kann man vermuten, aber nicht beweisen, ist, dass kurz vor dem Finale bekannt wird, dass Mario Götze zu Bayern wechseln wird in der kommenden Saison. Und dass eben dieser böse Geist, Borussia Dortmund, dann doch auch wieder mit den Mitteln bekämpft wird, die man von den Bayern kennt im Grunde seit den 80er-Jahren hatten sich die Finanzen so stabilisiert, dass auch der Schuldenberg abgetragen war. Nämlich, dass man im Zweifel dann doch auch immer die finanziellen Möglichkeiten hat und auch die Aussicht darauf, Titel zu gewinnen beim FC Bayern, um halt die besten Spieler oder mit die besten Spieler des Gegners wegzukaufen. Und das spielt, glaube ich, eben nicht nur für dieses Finale eine Rolle, auch wenn Götze da ja nicht spielen konnte. Ich glaube, er war leicht verletzt. Das war, wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere. Aber für die kommende Saison ist das dann eben einfach wichtig und zeigt eben auch, so wichtig ein Finalsieg für Dortmund natürlich gewesen wäre, auch als Zeichen. Meiner Meinung nach hatte es sich auf dem wirtschaftlichen Spielfeld schon vorher entschieden. Dortmund ist total ins West gegangen für die Saison 2012, 2013. Also laut fußballwirtschaft.de, aber die haben die Seiten, die Zahlen von Dortmund kennt man ja sehr gut dadurch, dass sie eine AG sind, war da die Personalkostenquote, also sprich der Anteil der Personalkosten an den Gesamtkosten erstmals über 50 Prozent bei Dortmund und hat einen deutlichen Sprung hingenommen von unter 200 Millionen in der Saison davor zu über 250 Millionen in dieser Saison, in der man dann das Champions League Finale gegen Bayern verliert. Also da hat Dortmund nochmal richtig investiert und man wird sich jetzt zwar in der Folge für die Champions League regelmäßig qualifizieren und deshalb sich einen monetären Vorteil vor dem Rest der Liga holen. Man wird aber nie einen monetären Vorteil gegenüber dem FC Bayern haben. Bei der FC Bayern schon immer in Themen wie Merchandising vor Dortmund lag, in Themen wie Champions League Einnahmen auch schon, weil man aus der Saison 2011, 2012 sehr, sehr viel TV-Geld für die Champions League erhalten hat. Das heißt, die Lücke von Dortmund zum Rest der Liga, die wird jetzt wachsen ab jetzt und ist auch hier auch schon im Wachsen. Aber die Lücke zu Bayern, die wird man nie schließen können. Und dann merkt man das eben auch indirekt sportlich, weil eben Bayern die Mittel hat, zu sagen, Mario, möchtest du nicht bei uns zeigen, dass du besser bist als Neymar? Da müssen wir auch gleich noch über eine Trainerankündigung sprechen, die ja auch noch in diese Saison reinfällt zur neuen Saison hin. Und Mario Goetze dann sagt, ja, da habe ich Lust drauf, ich gehe weg von Jürgen Klopp, ich gehe weg von Borussia Dortmund und spiele jetzt dann bei Bayern.
Kleine Korrektur, eine Wechselverkündung war kurz vor dem Spiel gegen Real.
Ach ja, so war es, stimmt.
Also kurz vor dem Halbfinale. Und ich habe zwei Dinge an diesem Goetze-Wechsel nie verstanden, vielleicht könnt ihr mir sie beantworten. Erstens, warum hatte Goetze eine festgeschriebene Ablösesumme? Das wehne ich in meinen Kopf so richtig. Dortmund ist ja ein paar Mal zum Verhängnis geworden in der Zeit. Und die zweite Frage ist, warum macht Mario Goetze das? Also ich muss wirklich sagen, ich konnte es natürlich aus Bayerns Sicht, war das irgendwie der logischste Transfer aller Zeiten, irgendwie klar. Du holst einen der besten deutschen Spieler von einem der wichtigsten Konkurrenten von dir. Warum macht Goetze das? Also wenn du, jetzt kann man natürlich immer sagen, ja, verdient er eine Million mehr oder nicht, aber ich kann mir, so wie ich ihn einschätze, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt der alleinige Grund dafür ist und ich glaube, die Millionen mehr hätte auch irgendwo anders sicherlich verdienen können. Ich habe es nicht verstanden, wie man diese Geschichte, diese Dortmunder Geschichte, die man da aufgebaut hat über drei Jahre, dann einfach so herschenkt und damit ja auch seine eigene Legacy einfach kaputt macht. Ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Na ja, also er war auf jeden Fall, es gab so ja so ein paar große Säulen, Lewandowski gehört ja auch mit dazu und da werden wir ja auch noch drüber sprechen, der ist ja dann auch noch irgendwann.
Lewandowski, ganz kurz, ist für mich ein anderes, also Lewandowski, für den war ja selbst Bayern am Anfang ein Sprungbrett. Also da kann ich mir sozusagen dieses Karriere-Ding, das folgt irgendwie bei Dortmund schafft er einen Durchbruch, dann geht er zum Branchen-Primus und dann geht er irgendwann zu Real. Das glaube ich war an seinem Kopf. Aber Götze hat ja auch für den Verein einfach eine ganz andere Bedeutung gehabt. Götze für mich eine andere Geschichte als Lewandowski.
Ja, also es ist natürlich nicht genau zu sagen. Also den Punkt, den ich machen wollte, war vor allem, er war der erste aus diesem Bündnis Borussia Dortmund, was sich da auf ein gemeinsames Ziel eingeschworen hat und auch eigentlich darauf eingeschworen hat, der Antagonist zu Bayern zu sein, der die Seiten gewechselt hat und der so ein bisschen dann auch, also überspitzt gesagt, die Familie verlassen hat. Zumindest so wurde es ja damals auch aufgefasst. Man kann es natürlich schwer beurteilen. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, aber das ist jetzt auch einfach nur eine Hypothese meinerseits. Vielleicht hat seine Rolle in der Nationalmannschaft da mit reingespielt. Bei der EM 2012 spielt er gegen Griechenland zehn Minuten, ansonsten spielt er nicht bei der kompletten EM 2012. Und das war schon jetzt nicht so der schlechteste Mario-Götze, den wir erlebt haben. Danach spielt er zwar immer mal wieder, hat auch mit Verletzungen zu kämpfen, aber seine einzigen Einsätze im Jahr 2013, wie gesagt, da kommen aber auch Verletzungen mit rein. Aus dem März eben von vor dem Champions League-Finale sind gegen Kasachstan in der WM-Qualifikation. Und es steht die WM in Brasilien vor der Tür. Und wie gesagt, es ist nur eine Arbeitshypothese, aber vielleicht hat das damit reingespielt. Wenn du beim FC Bayern spielst, dann hast du nach allem, was man aus der Historie der Nationalmannschaft herauslesen kann, oft auch eine andere Rolle in der Nationalmannschaft. Das liegt an ganz vielen Dingen. Das liegt auch daran, dass du oft mit einem Bayern-Block im Verein zusammenspielst, der sich dann auch in ähnlicher Konstellation oft in der Nationalmannschaft wiederfindet. Das hat aber vielleicht auch einfach mit der Art und Weise, wie die Bayern auch manchmal gegenüber der Nationalmannschaft und dem Bundestrainer kommunizieren, zu tun. Da hat man ja auch mal eine interessante Gegenbewegung gesehen, jetzt mit der Demontage von Homis Boateng und Müller vor einiger Zeit. Und vielleicht war, also ich kann mir nämlich auch wenig Reim drauf machen, aber das könnte ein Argument gewesen sein. Es geht um die WM in Brasilien. Da will er als feste Säule dabei sein.
Ja, und ich denke auch einfach dieses Dortmunder, auch diese Beziehung mit Klopp und dieser aufwändiges Spielstil, der hat sich ja auch ein bisschen einfach irgendwann abgenutzt. Und ich glaube, die ersten Abnutzungserscheinungen sind dann eben auch schon 2013 zu erkennen. Und wenn du weitsichtig denken willst als Spieler, hast du glaube ich auch zu dem Zeitpunkt auch als Dortmunder gesehen. Wir schaffen es vielleicht, an Bayern ranzukommen. Wir schaffen es vielleicht, die auch zu ärgern. Wir haben sie geschafft, zwei Jahre in Schach zu halten, aber auf Dauer haben wir nicht die Voraussetzungen, um hier wirklich ein Gleichgewicht der Kräfte und der Mächte herzustellen und dann noch Pep Guardiola die Aussicht mit dem Mann zusammenzuarbeiten, der mich vielleicht als Spieler wirklich auch nochmal auf ein neues Niveau heben kann. Kann das Klopp mit mir in Dortmund machen? Ich weiß es nicht. Also wahrscheinlich nicht noch weiter. Das sind für mich alles sehr, sehr valide Gründe und wenn es um die festgeschriebene Ablöse geht. Vorhin hast du ja gesagt, Götze hat das Jahr vorher erst nochmal seinen Vertrag verlängert. Und das ist ja meistens so, wenn jemand sehr begehrt ist und dann nochmal irgendwie seinen Vertrag verlängert, macht man das damit einhergehend, dass man sozusagen einen Vertrag auf Zeit schließt. Und man einfach sagt, okay, der Verein sagt, du kriegst jetzt nochmal mehr Geld, damit du bei uns bleibst. Aber der Spieler sagt, irgendwann würde ich schon gerne weggehen. Dann sagt der Verein, okay, pass auf, dann fahren wir einfach eine Ablösesumme, eine festgeschriebene, wo wir dann einfach wissen, was wir haben, weil dann kriegen wir die Summe, wenn sie geboten wird und wir kommen da irgendwie sauber raus aus der ganzen Geschichte. Da haben sie natürlich dann den Plan, ohne den FC Bayern gemacht, und seinen indiskreten Quellen, die dann sowas dann gerne am Tag eines Champions-League-Halffinals dann einfach mal so rausgeben und danach dann sagen, nein, nein, nein, von uns kam das nicht.
Aber Guardiola ist dann vielleicht noch ein wichtiges Argument, das da noch mit reinspielt. Denn das wird ja im Januar bekannt, dass im Dezember Uli Hoeneß höchstpersönlich nach New York gereist ist, um den sich in einem sabbatical befindlichen Pep Guardiola für die kommende Saison als neuen Trainer zu verpflichten. Und diese Meldung, die schlägt ein, wie eine Bombe, den Pep Guardiola. Inzwischen hat sich so ein bisschen seine Wahrnehmung auch gedreht. Aber damals ist er einfach derjenige, der mit Barcelona nicht nur einen Stil geprägt hat, der den kompletten Weltfußball beeinflusst hat, sondern der auch einfach irre erfolgreich war. Er hat mit Barca 2009 und 2011 die Champions League gewonnen und ist im Grunde der Trainer. Und hat ja aus freien Stücken aufgehört, hat selbst bekannt gegeben, nein, ihm braucht jetzt eine Pause. Und dass dieser Trainer, wo man wirklich sagen kann, von Weltrang, vielleicht zu dieser Phase auch der beste Trainer, zumindest was die Erfolge angeht, die aktuellen Erfolge angeht, dass der zum FC Bayern kommt, das hat, meiner Meinung nach, Steffen, den Club nicht nur national, sondern auch international in der Wahrnehmung auf ein neues Level gehoben. Und das könnte ja auch mit reingespielt haben bei so einer Wechselentscheidung.
Ja, also Guardiola, das fand ich jetzt von den Argumenten, die ihr vorgetragen habt, das einzige, wo ich sagen würde, okay, das kann ich nachvollziehen an Götzes Stelle. Ich muss auch sagen, als damals dieser Wechsel bekannt gegeben wurde, der hatte sich ja zumindest ein bisschen angedeutet, es gab Gerüchte im Vorfeld. Ich habe die in der Zeit eigentlich abgetan. Ich konnte mir das nicht vorstellen. Also das ist so ein bisschen so in diesem Moment, also heute wickt das alles, klar, Guardiola, Bayern, einer der Top-5-Vereine in Europa und so weiter, aber es fühlte sich damals irgendwie noch nicht so an. Das war so ein bisschen so, als wenn Ronaldinho 2004 zu Bayern gewechselt wäre. So unwirklich fand ich das eigentlich in dem Moment und es unterstriche auch noch mal, dass Heinkes eher so, oder diese Saison, zwar natürlich, Bayern war auch schon im Winter relativ erfolgreich und auch schon gut unterwegs, aber trotzdem hatte es so ein bisschen so ein Gefühl, okay, jetzt der Übergang geht jetzt zu Ende und jetzt kommt Guardiola und dann kann man sich dann vergolden. So war ja so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass man dann tatsächlich den ganzen Weg geht zum Trippel. Das war da sicherlich noch nicht abzusehen. Ich weiß auch, dass Heinkes das, glaube ich, insgesamt nicht so gut gefallen hat, wie das alles abgelaufen ist. Der hatte, glaube ich, ein bisschen dran zu knabbern. Ich weiß nicht, ob er gerne in München auch weitergemacht hätte. Was er auf jeden Fall nicht gut fand, ist, dass, glaube ich, dann verkündet wurde, dass er seine Karriere beenden wird und dass er jetzt Vorstandsberater wird und so was. Das hat ihm überhaupt nicht geschmeckt. Aber ich glaube, er hätte auch so gerne weitergemacht. Ja, aber das war natürlich ein krasser Moment, finde ich. Weil es in der Tat, wie du richtig gesagt hast, den FC Bayern, glaube ich, jetzt auch für jeden sichtbar. Und eigentlich auch ab dem Moment war der FC Bayern auch auf Spielerebene irgendwie auf allerhöchstem Niveau für jeden irgendwie ansprechbar. Das ist immer die Frage, kriegt man es finanziell am Ende gewuppt oder sind noch Vereine drin, die vielleicht noch mehr versprechen, auch so im Marketingumfeld und so weiter. Aber auf einmal war der FC Bayern damit unter den Top 3, Top 4 Ansprechpartnern, die es so gab in Europa.
Und neben dem Trainer und Mario Götze, der ja nach allem, was man heute so weiß, als Alternative angeboten wurde zu einem gewissen Nehmer, den Pep Guardiola ganz gerne gehabt hätte, wo ihm dann typisch, das ist FC Bayern typisch, dass da ja dann die Vereinsoberen auch durchaus mal Veto einlegen und sagen, ach du, wir haben mit Südamerikanern schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht. Winter und so mögen die oft nicht. Aber Mario Götze, das ist doch ein Deutscher, und der ist ja fast wie Nehmer, magst du nicht den haben? Zusätzlich zu dem kam ja auch noch Thiago, das berühmte Thiago-oder-nix-Zitat, der ja, und das wissen wir ja inzwischen, dann eine ganz feste Säule wurde nicht nur unter Pep Guardiola beim FC Bayern. Für was steht denn dieser Wechsel sportlich gesehen? Eben jenseits von der Bedeutung, auch von der Art und Weise, wie Guardiola damals diesen Transfer angekündigt hat. Das war relativ deutlich und nicht so in der Art und Weise, wie er vorher aufgetreten ist. Von einem Van Gaal hätte man das erwartet, dass der sich in der Pressekonferenz hinsetzt und sagt, naja, also entweder den oder gar keinen. Ich weiß noch, bei Pep Guardiola hat das damals für einige hochgezogene Augenbrauen gesorgt, dass sich jemand so klar positioniert und damit ja auch den Verein in eine schlechtere Verhandlungsposition für den Wechsel bekommt.
Nee, nee, Ablösesumme festgeschrieben.
Ach, stimmt, stimmt, ab. Und warum hat sich das so lange gezogen?
Weiß ich nicht, hat sich's gar nicht. Ich glaube, das Schöne war ja, dass der Bruder von Pep, Pere, Pere Guardiola, war der Berater von Thiago zu dem Zeitpunkt. Und so war natürlich Pep Guardiola hervorragend darüber informiert, dass die Ausstiegsklausel von Thiago nur dadurch aktiv war, dass Thiago in der Vorsaison zu wenige Einsätze für Barcelona hatte. Also es gab eine Ausstiegsklausel auf der Grundlage, wenn ich nicht genug spiele, dann darf ich gehen für diese Summe. Und das war eben Pep Guardiola bewusst. Und das hat er eben den Bayern gesagt und gesagt, ich brauch diesen Spieler, nicht nur, weil ich diesen Spieler haben will, sondern weil der jetzt auch einfach echt günstig hergeht mit 25 Millionen. Und die Bayern haben gesagt, wem willst du das? Thiago, aber der ist ja nicht mal Stammspieler bei Barcelona. Wieso willst du den jetzt haben? Mit 25 Millionen sind die jetzt auch kein Pappenstiel. Also ich meine, für den Javi da, diesen anderen Spanner, da haben wir 40 gezahlt. Also das ist jetzt auch nicht so wenig. Und dann hat aber Pep gesagt, eben der oder keinen. Weil den will ich jetzt wirklich. Diesen Götze, den habt ihr mir irgendwie untergejubelt. Da finde ich schon noch irgendwie eine Lösung. Aber den hätte ich schon gerne. Und ich glaube, dass Pep Guardiola damals eben auch schon im Sinn hatte, einen Nachfolger oder einen anderen Spielertypus als Bastian Schweinsteiger zu implementieren in dieser Mannschaft. Und einfach einen noch spielwitzigeren und einen noch besseren Lösungen in engen Räumen finden, einen Spieler im Mittelfeld zu implementieren. Als das jetzt mit der Besetzung, weil du hattest ja irgendwie so, wenn du das angeschaut hast, du hattest Javi Martinez, du hattest Bastian Schweinsteiger und du hattest Thomas Müller im Zentrum, jetzt so diese Triple-Mannschaft und Toni Kroos. Wer von denen verkörpert jetzt so ein bisschen dieses Iniesta-haftige oder dieses Javi-haftige? Keiner von denen. Da war ihm glaube ich wichtig, so einen Thiago zu haben, einen Spieler, den du in jeder Situation, in jeder Höhe seines Körpers anspielen kannst. Und der kann den Ball in wirklich technisch herausragender Manier verarbeiten, weiterleiten und vor allem nach vorne gerichtet agieren auf dem Platz. Deswegen war glaube ich dieser Thiago, dem Pep Guardiola so wichtig. Also eine Mischung aus der Klasse des Spielers, dem Spielertyp, den er sich vorgestellt hat und aber auch der Möglichkeit der festgeschriebenen Ablöse.
Was ja auch spielerisch damit einherging, dass man jetzt so wirklich beim Ballbesitzfußball angekommen ist. Also den Zahlen nach spielt Bayern den immer in der Bundesliga, weil eben auch viele Gegner gegen Bayern sagen, nehmt ihr mal den Ball. Wir warten dann hier an der Mittellinie auf euch und ihr müsst jetzt erstmal unsere kompakte Abwehr auseinanderspielen. Und mit Pep Guardiola ist der Ballbesitz aber noch mal krass nach oben gegangen. Also in der Bundesligasaison in der letzten unter Heinkes hatte Bayern mit 60 Prozent des Spiels den Ball, unter Guardiola jetzt zu 66 Prozent. Aber es war auch ein anderer Ballbesitz. Also ein tieferer Ballbesitz, ein zirkulierender Ballbesitz. Es war wichtig, mit Verlagerungen zu spielen. Es war aber auch wichtig, im Spielaufbau ihn kontrolliert von hinten heraus zu spielen. Nicht immer gleich den langen Ball, sondern eben die berühmten, ich glaube, was waren es, 13 Kontakte in der eigenen Hälfte und erst dann in die Mittellinie und bis zur Mittellinie gibt es einen klaren Plan im Spielaufbau und ab der Mittellinie hat er dann auch den Spielern mehr ihren freien Lauf gelassen, eben in natürlich einem taktischen Grundkonstrukt, aber hat da auch auf die individuellen Klassen setzen können. Und das hat, glaube ich, den FC Bayern auch nochmal spielerisch weiterentwickelt und dafür steht für mich auch dieser Spielertyp Thiago, der da eben Dinge mitbringt, die eben, wie du gerade schon herausgearbeitet hast, die vorhandenen Spieler, Martinez und Schweinsteiger, so nicht erfüllt haben. Auch eine taktische Flexibilität. Also wenn wir uns erinnern, das ist die Zeit, wo die Bayern dann anfangen, also wo einzelne Spieler, wie zum Beispiel Philipp Lahm, drei verschiedene Positionen spielen in einem Spiel gegen Mainz 05. Man sich denkt, warum? Also das kannte man von den Bayern so noch nicht, aber Pep Guardiola ist eben ein Trainer, der das so angeht. Und dafür war Thiago wichtig und steht damit auch simpel für die Art und Weise, wie sich dann das Spiel des FC Bayern verändert hat, meine Meinung nach.
Erinnert ihr euch an das allererste Pflichtspiel von Pep Guardiola als Bayern-Trainer? Ja, Super Cup gegen Dortmund. Ergebnis?
2 zu 4 oder so was?
Richtig. Also Bayern kommt aus diesem Triple Wahn, aus diesem Trippelsommer, aus diesem Trippeltrubel. Pep Guardiola fängt an und sie spielen natürlich als Erstes in Dortmund den Haya Popaya Super Cup, aber immerhin Super Cup. Pep Guardiola stellt Thiago auf die Sechs, stellt Kroos und Müller davor, stellt Shaqiri und Robben auf die Flügel und Manzukic vorne rein. Das ist so eine in-your-face-Anarchie-Aufstellung und meint, jetzt schauen wir mal. Und kriegt halt vier Stück eingeschenkt. Das war so ein bisschen so, da haben dann alle so ein bisschen mit der Augenbraue gezockt und haben gesagt, ja okay, es ist Super Cup, aber muss man das so aufstellen? Muss man die so spielen lassen? Die waren noch nicht so richtig fit, alle okay. Aber das war so ein kurzer Schock und Rüttler. Und dann aber läuft es bei Bayern. Und also ich muss heute sagen, ich finde, der FC Bayern hat nie einen besseren Fußball gespielt oder einen schöneren Fußball gespielt als über weite Strecken der 2013er, 2014er Saison. Das war spielerisch noch mal eine Schippe besser als in der Trippelsaison. Und es ist auch relativ früh schon zu erkennen, dass das alles ineinander fließt. Also dieses Heureka-Archimedes-Erlebnis haben so viele Bayern-Spieler unter diesem Pep Guardiola. Und das kumuliert für mich alles in diesem Spiel, das sie bei Manchester City spielen, in der Champions League Vorrunde. Ich habe das mir damals auf DVD festgebannt und alle paar Jubeljahre ziehe ich es mal wieder raus und schaue mir das an. Weil das wirklich, also, viel besser kannst du nicht Fußball spielen als über weite Strecken dieses Spiels. Mit einer Dominanz, mit einer ballbesitzorientierten Spielweise, die aber trotzdem schnell nach vorne geht. Die Kompaktheit, die Positionstreue auf dem Platz. Ein Philipp Lahm, wie er weckt.
Auf der sechsten Position. Das war ja die Erkenntnis aus dem Champions League, aus dem Supercup gegen Chelsea, wo man aus der Not heraus Lahm auf die Sechs gestellt hat. Und auf einmal war er da. Wichtig.
Ja, und also, das ist... Für mich ist non plus ultra dieses Spiel. Dieses, wie es im Spiel aussieht.
1 zu 1 ist das gleiche. 1 zu 1 ist das gleiche aufgeschrieben. Also, absolute Zustimmung. Nie besseren Fußball, glaube ich, gespielt als unter Guardiola. Ich würde neben dem 3 zu 1 gegen Manchester City vielleicht noch das 7-1 gegen AS Rom mit reinnehmen. Das war ähnlich brillant. Die Ironie ist ja in der Tat, dass Thiago erstmal ja kaum eine Rolle spielt, weil er sich relativ schnell verletzt. Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum Lahm sich Guardiola umschaut und sich fragt, wen kann ich eigentlich noch als kleinräumigen, spielstarken, pressigen, resistenten Spieler hier ins Zentrum stellen? Dann kommt auf diese Idee, Lahm dahin zu stellen, der zusammen mit Groß und Schweinsteiger in diesem Spiel gegen City in der Tat, da gibt es Ballstaffetten, das ist wirklich irre. Nicht nur Ballstaffetten, die einfach im Nichts verlaufen, sondern die am Ende zu Toren führen. Thomas Müller vorne zentrale Spitze, Robben und Ribéry auf den Flügeln. Stimme ich absolut zu. Definitiv eine Sternstunde. Interessanterweise aber auch ein bisschen ein Muster der Guardiola-Zeit, dass man immer irgendwie im Herbst so richtig in Top-Form ist und dann in der zweiten Jahreshälfte das immer so ein bisschen schwieriger wurde.
Ja, also man merkt halt einfach, die Mannschaft piekt einfach viel zu früh in jeder Saison. Sie kommen zu schnell durch die Lösungen, die die Guardiola ihnen aufzeigt und die sie einstudieren und die sie im Training erarbeiten. Zu schnell, nahe an die Perfektion und haben dann nicht mehr diesen Atem, das über die Saison einfach auch durchzuhalten. Und du merkst natürlich auch, andere Mannschaften stellen sich besser darauf ein. Also, die haben dann Anschauungsmaterial. Die können sich das anschauen, die können scouten und die können sich dann gezielt die Dinge raussuchen, die Bayern weh tun. Das ist so ein bisschen die Tragik der Pep Guardiola-Zeit. Gepaart mit Verletzungen, du sprichst Thiago an, aber auch in seinem zweiten Jahr, da fällt ja dann auch die komplette Abwehr auseinander. Alaba ist verletzt. Also, das wird dann irgendwann richtig wild. Was dann alles, mit diesem Nottransfer von Medi-Benazja wird dann da so ein bisschen gepflegt. Irgendwann ist da nicht auch noch die Serdar-Taski-Episode.
Also, gepflegt wurde eigentlich erst später, aber ich lasse es dir durchgehen. Und Serdar Tasche, wie wir damals gelernt haben, kam, glaube ich, im Winter, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Ja, ja, irgendwann in einem Winter dann. Irgendwann kam der dann noch mal dubioserweise nach München. Anyway, jetzt habe ich den Faden verloren. Irgendeinen Punkt wollte ich noch anschauen. Javi Martinez, Javi Martinez. Ja, also, Piken zu früh, aber ein anderer Aspekt, noch eben losgelöst von dem, wir reden über Javi Martinez und haben ihn vorhin zum Schlüssel der Trippelsaison ernannt. Pep Guardiola kommt an und sagt als erstes, ja, auch Javi Martinez, super Innenverteidiger. Also sagt er halt von Anfang an, durch die Blume, den kann ich im Mittelfeld nicht gebrauchen. Warum kann er den im Mittelfeld nicht gebrauchen? Weil er ihm eben nicht spielt, stark genug ist. Weil er eben in der Spieleröffnung zu eindimensioniert ist. Weil er eben in der Spieleröffnung nicht zu pressingresistent ist oder erscheint. Und deswegen sagt er eigentlich von Anfang an, das ist für mich ein Innenverteidiger. Und das lässt man ihm aber durchgehen. Also da ist jetzt keiner, der, gehen wir nochmal zurück zu van Gaal, dann plötzlich sagt so, was will der denn jetzt? Also unseren Königstransfer, 40 Millionen, der uns hier das Triple beschert hat, unsere Maschines, unser Held, der dann ja auch noch gegen, im Supercup, im europäischen Supercup dann im Spätsommer, Frühherbst der ersten Gardiola-Saison, dann ja diesen Ausgleich zählt gegen Chelsea in Prag zum 2-2, der dann zum Elfmeterschießen und dann da auch zur Revanche gegen Chelsea führt, zur Ultimativen. Das lässt man ihm durchgehen. Anders als van Gaal, wo der dann vielleicht auch einfach zu viel gemacht hat und zu viel verändert hat, lässt man Pep das machen. Und der Erfolg gibt ihm ja dann aber auch recht. Also über weite Strecken dieser Saison. Bayern wird, glaube ich, im Ende März Meister in Berlin.
War die früheste Meisterschaft.
Ich war da vor Ort, habe damals für die Abendzeitung gearbeitet und hatte eben das Glück, für die Abendzeitung sowohl die Trippelsaison als auch dann die erste Gardiola-Saison als Bayern-Reporter zu begleiten und war bei sehr vielen Spielen vor Ort, auch auswärts. Ich weiß, wie ich mir in Berlin den Hintern abgefroren habe. Bayern wurde da Meister. Aber da war dann auch irgendwie die Saison zu Ende gefühlt. Sie spielen dann gegen Real das Halbfinale, wo du im Hinspiel in Madrid 1-0 verlierst, wo du es eigentlich gewinnen kannst. Also Bayern war da auch schon auf Augenhöhe, muss eigentlich ein Tor machen, verliert unglücklich 1-0 in Madrid. Und du hast vor dem Rückspiel schon das Gefühl, ja, jetzt geht was. Also 0-1 aufholen ist schwer. Bayern haben jetzt auch immer mal wieder Gegentore bekommen. Aber das kann was werden. Und ich bereite euch jetzt die Overtüre, dass ihr über dieses Real Madrid-Spiel reden dürft. Dieses Dann-Spoiler, etwas in die Hose gegangenes 0-4.
Also nachdem Steffen sich schon das 2-5 nochmal angeguckt hat in Vorbereitung auf dieses Spiel, also er ist dahin gegangen, wo es ihm wehtut, bin ich mir fast sicher, dass er sich zum 0-4 auch Notizen gemacht hat, Steffen.
Ja, definitiv. Also die Geschichte dieses Spiels gibt ja, also es gibt eine Geschichte, die Guardiola über seinen Leib und Magen-Biographen, oder wie man ihn bezeichnen soll, Marti Peranau, dann hat verbreiten lassen, und die auch später von Dominik Thoren, glaube ich, noch mal bestätigt wurde, die ist ja, dass er eigentlich anders spielen wollte gegen Real. Die Geschichte war, dass er eigentlich abwartend spielen wollte, weil er sehr viel Respekt hatte vor der Konterstärke von Real Madrid und die Mannschaft, dann weil sie so euphorisch war, auch durch die guten Ergebnisse in der Liga davor, und generell man jetzt zeigen wolle, dass man, wer hierher im Haus ist in München, ihn dann überredet habe, eine offensivere Ausrichtung zu wählen. Er spielt also gegen Real ein 4-2-4 mit Schweinsteiger und Kroos in der Zentrale. Und genau, es geht dann fürchterlich schief mit dem 4 zu 0, 0 zu 4. Aus meiner Sicht ist das aber überhaupt kein Faktor und das wird so ein bisschen vergessen, auch weil ja natürlich sehr viel in dieses Spiel hineinappretiert wird. Es steht nach wenigen Minuten 2 zu 0 für Real Madrid. Das hat nichts mit Kontern oder mit Taktik oder mit sonst irgendwas zu tun, sondern hängt damit zusammen, dass Sergio Ramos zwei Standardsituationen reinköpft. Dann steht es 2 zu 0 und damit ist das Spiel einfach vorbei. Also natürlich gibt es Spielverläufe, wo man es dann noch mal dreht, aber zwei Auswärtstore von Real im eigenen Strafraum, da brauchst du schon dann Wunder danach. Danach kommen in der Tat dann noch mal so ein paar Kontersituationen, wo Bayern wechselt dann auch zur Halbzeit Martinez ein, um dann darauf zu reagieren und so weiter. Insofern wurde da sehr viel reininterpretiert in dieses Spiel. Einerseits aufgrund dieser Story. Guardiola hat sich so viel überlegt und hat sich dann überstimmen lassen von der Mannschaft. Andererseits aber auch in Richtung in großen Spielen ist er zu verkopft und so weiter. Aber es waren am Ende, wie gesagt, zwei Kopfballtore von Ramos. Einmal nach einem Freistoß, einmal nach einer Ecke. Und dann siehst du einfach auch scheiße aus.
Und gleichzeitig ist das ja aber jetzt dann so der rote Faden der Guardiola-Ära. Also wenn wir eben, wir haben national Rekorde und in dieser Saison auch einen schönen Fußball. Wir haben aber auch immer nach überlegenen Hinrunden merkwürdige Rückrunden. Also in seinen beiden ersten Spielzeiten für Bayern bleibt Bayern in der Hinrunde ungeschlagen. Man geht ohne Niederlage als Herbstmeister in die Winterpause. Und in der Rückrunde, meistens wenn man die Meisterschaft gewonnen hat, zu einem absurd frühen Zeitpunkt, fehlt dann irgendetwas. Und das zeigt sich dann auch in den Halbfinalen-Niederlagen in der Champions League. Und gleichzeitig habe ich aber auch das Gefühl, da würde mich deine Meinung interessieren, Steffen, dass sich aber auch im Spiel der Bayern etwas totgelaufen hat. Also ich würde euch zustimmen, wenn ihr sagt, dass 2013, 2014 das ein sehr schöner Fußball war, also erfolgreich war der Fußball ja dann sowieso, in weiten Teilen unter Guardiola. Ich finde aber, dass sich das dann in den späteren Spielzeiten von Guardiola durchaus ein bisschen geändert hat. Und dass oft ein, zwar immer noch eine hohe Ballzirkulation war und ein hoher Ballbesitz, aber wenig Torschancen, wenig was daraus kreiert wurde und auch oft Umstellungen, die zwar auf den Matchplan des Gegners eingehen, aber das Spiel auch so ein bisschen tot machen. Also in der ersten Halbzeit lässt du den Gegner ganz lange den Ball hinterherlaufen und in der zweiten Halbzeit machst du dann irgendwann die Tore. Ich hatte so das Gefühl, das Begeisternde hat das Spiel der Bayern dann in den Folgejahren unter Guardiola verloren.
Ich glaube einerseits, dass Guardiola einfach als Trainer von der Ausrichtung ein anderer Typ ist als viele andere. Ich glaube, dass er seinen Fokus, seine ganze Energie da reinsteckt, ein Spiel zu kreieren, das seinen Vorstellungen entspricht. Und ich glaube, dass Titel am Ende dieser Entwicklung stehen, aber für ihn nicht das alles Entscheidende sind. Und das ist für mich so ein bisschen eine Erklärung dafür, warum es häufig in so Saisons dann am Ende irgendwie so einen Energieabfall gab. Weil häufig, es ist dann schwer, wenn du im Herbst oder auch im Winter oder auch dann im Frühjahr richtig überragenden Fußball spielst und du merkst richtig, wie zufrieden er ist und wie er quasi am Ziel ist, das dann wirklich zu strecken bis in den Mai, Juni. Und ich glaube, er war dann nie der Typ, der dann den Schalter umgelegt hat und gesagt hat, so und jetzt geht es halt darum, irgendwie diesen Pot oder so zu bekommen. Er hat das manchmal, finde ich, auffällig war das zum Beispiel in Pokalfinalen, sowohl 2014 als 2016. Da war das total da. Obwohl auch da in den Wochen davor der Fußball teilweise grauenhaft war, hat es irgendwie geschafft, auf dieses Pokalfinale das dann komplett zu orientieren. Das war dann mega emotional. Aber so in diesem Alltagsgeschäft, ich glaube, da fehlte ihm so ein bisschen, nachdem er schon mal bewiesen hat, wie gut es läuft, diese Geilheit darauf, da jetzt auch jedes Spiel zu gewinnen und jeden Titel mitzunehmen und so weiter. Das ist der eine Aspekt. Der zweite Aspekt ist, mir wird insgesamt die Guardiola-Zeit so ein bisschen zu sehr über einen Kamm geschert. Ich glaube, wir sollten gleich schon nochmal auch in die anderen beiden Halbfinals in der Champions League genau reinschauen, weil die erzählen halt alle ganz unterschiedliche Geschichten, sowohl dieses Halbfinal da gegen Barcelona als auch dann im Jahr drauf gegen Atletico. Aber so habe ich mir zumindest immer erklärt, warum es nach Höhen am Anfang danach immer so ein bisschen wegfüsselte und der Fußball dann eben auch nicht mehr so zielgerichtet war. Und vielleicht ein Aspekt noch. Guardiola kam, um diese Mannschaft zu vergolden. Er hat dann eine Mannschaft übernommen, die war schon quasi vergoldet. Die hatte das Triple gewonnen. Das heißt, sein Ziel hat sich ein bisschen verändert. Es ging irgendwie darum, diese goldene Generation noch weiter zu stretchen, so weit, wie es irgendwie geht. Und ich glaube schon, dass es auch einer Mannschaft irgendwann schwerfällt, wenn du das Triple gewonnen hast, wenn du zum vierten Mal Meister in Folge bist, dann dich auch immer noch in der zweiten Jahreshälfte, wenn du vielleicht schon Meister im März bist, dich dann noch zu fokussieren gegen Augsburg und gegen andere, dann irgendwie wieder 100 Prozent hinzulegen. Das kann ich zumindest irgendwo nachvollziehen. Und ich glaube, das gehört ein Stück weit auch zu dieser Guardiola-Ära dazu, dass so eine gewisse Sättigung auf jeden Fall eingesetzt hat.
Er hat aber auch irgendwann die Mannschaft auch noch mal weiterentwickelt. Er hat schon auch immer nach Lösungen gesucht, wie er den Spielstil der Bayern immer noch dominant, immer noch ballbesitzorientiert, aber auch noch mal wieder weniger ausrechnbar machen kann. Und unter anderem halt dann auch, ich glaube, dann zu seiner, es ist zur zweiten oder zur dritten Saison, wo er dann die Außenverteidiger plötzlich nach innen zieht. Wo er dann einfach sagt, jetzt habe ich es. Wir müssen mit den Außenverteidigern nicht hoch an der Außenlinie stehen, sondern wir ziehen die quasi so im Spielaufbau nach innen. Und ziehen die quasi so als zusätzliche Optionen. Also A, wenn der Gegner mit Außenstürmern versucht, Deckungsschatten eben beim Spielaufbau zu kreieren, der erwartet den Außenverteidiger halt außen. Und der linke Angreifer erwartet den halt in der linken Schulter. Aber was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich den Lahm jetzt nach innen laufen lasse? Dann habe ich doch schon wieder einen Vorteil, oder? Und gerade Lahm und Rafinha sind dann Spieler, die es dann halt irgendwie schaffen, aus dem Zentrum heraus dann auch als Außenverteidiger zu agieren. Und das war auch noch mal so ein Erlebnis, wo man sagt, da hat er sich echt gute Gedanken gemacht. Das hat er gut gemacht. Und er hat es dann schon auch geschafft, die Bayern dann noch mal weiter zu kitzeln. Und egal, mit welchem Spieler man spricht, im Nachhinein über die, oder viele, sagen einfach, das war ein super Trainer. Der hat mir echt noch mal viel Neues beigebracht. Gerade ein Jerome Boateng, der schwärmt heute noch in den höchsten Tönen von Pep Guardiola.
Er hat auch die Dreierkette phasenweise eingeführt. Das, was ich mir ja schon seit Jahren, auch jetzt immer mal wieder gewünscht hätte, weil ich das glaube, das ist bei so einem hohen Wahlbesitz, den Bayern hat, dass das einfach wahnsinnige Vorteile hat, auch in der Konterverteidigung Vorteile hätte. Das hat er gemacht. Er hat dann in dem DFB-Pokalfinale 2014 gegen Dortmund dann auf einmal mit einer Fünferkette gespielt. Ich glaube, mit Heuberg als Rechtsverteidiger. Er hat dann später, ich habe sie mal Line-up auf Death genannt, so eine Offensivformation eingeführt, wo er quasi mit fünf Stürmern gleichzeitig gespielt hat. Damals dann mit Douglas Costa, mit Müller, mit Lewandowski, mit Robben, mit Coman. Alle einfach gleichzeitig auf den Platz gestellt. Wohl wissend, dass das natürlich defensiv für Anfälligkeiten sorgt, aber immer mit dem Wissen, im Zweifel schießen wir vier bis sechs Tore selbst. Die Statistiken in dieser Zeit waren auch wirklich wahnsinn. Immer wenn die fünf zusammen auf dem Platz gespielt haben, gab es, glaube ich, alle 25 Minuten einen Tor. Oder alle 20 Minuten. Das stimmt absolut, dass er da immer wieder was rausgekitzelt hat. Aber es muss ja irgendwie einen Grund geben, warum es sozusagen am Ende dieser letzte Schritt ein Stück weit gefehlt hat. Es war ja schon so, dass gerade diese Halbfinals, der Rhythmus war irgendwie immer rundherum weg. Das ist nicht der einzige Grund, warum man am Ende verloren hat. Aber es war schon so, dass rund um diese Spiele, man musste sich dann wieder so hochziehen auf einmal. Man hat dann irgendwie gegen Augsburg mal unentschieden gespielt oder was auch immer im Vorfeld. Und musste dann wieder voll da sein. Bevor wir auf die Halbfinals noch mal eingehen, vielleicht einen Aspekt noch. Flo hat gerade gesagt, ihm wurde viel durchgehen gelassen. Das würde ich absolut unterstreichen, was die Bayern-Führung angeht. Was die öffentliche Meinung angeht, sah das aus meiner Sicht ein bisschen anders aus. Da stand er schon eigentlich von Anfang an, sowohl aus journalistischer Perspektive als auch in Teilen, Fans, Unterstützer-Szene, schon in der Kritik. Und zwar wegen allen möglichen Dingen. Am Anfang wegen zu viele Spanier und zu viel Tiki-Taka. Medial auch. Genau, medial. Dann, weil er zu viel rum experimentiert hat, da könne sich eine Mannschaft gar nicht einspielen usw. Schon irre eigentlich dieser Gap zwischen Unterstützung aus der Mannschaft, auch im Verein, auch Unterstützung, glaube ich, von großen Teilen der Fanszene. Aber auf der anderen Seite teilweise auch richtig harte Kritik, auch so aus dieser ganzen Experten-Community. Also diese ganzen ehemaligen Fußballer, die ja nach wie vor immer noch eine große Rolle spielen in der öffentlichen Meinungsbildung zumindest. Dann war er von Anfang an, wurde er da sehr skeptisch gesehen.
Ja, ich wollte jetzt erst heftig widersprechen, weil ich mich erinnert habe an die Begeisterung, fast schon Liebe für Pep Guardiola, als er in seiner ersten Pressekonferenz auf Deutsch sein Eingangsstatement abgehalten hat. Aber je länger du gesprochen hast, desto mehr Dinge sind mir wieder eingefallen. Er war schon ein Fremdkörper in dieser Liga. Er hat eben Dinge anders gemacht als viele Trainer in der Liga vor ihm und zu seiner Zeit. Und auch anders, ehrlich gesagt, als der deutsche Fußball funktioniert. Ich finde, da hat man tatsächlich immer eine Skepsis gemerkt, dass da jemand von außen kommt, der dreimal pro Spiel die Formation ändert. Und das auch im Spiel gegen den HSV macht. Oder auch im Spiel gegen den FC Augsburg, wo eigentlich so das klassische Mantra des deutschen Fußballs ist, wir wollen unsere Stärken auf den Platz bringen. Und dann hat der Gegner erstmal gar keine Chance. Hat sich ja Pep Guardiola tatsächlich für jeden Gegner etwas ausgedacht. Die Geschichte ist so ein bisschen legendär hier bei Bayern, wobei sie jetzt auch schon so oft erzählt wurde, dass sie vielleicht doch gar nicht stimmt. Aber angeblich soll es ihn wahnsinnig gemacht haben, dass er nicht wusste, wer der zweite Sechser bei Paderborn war, vor dem Spiel gegen Paderborn. Und er musste wohl irgendwie jeden Scout, Busfahrer und auch Uli Hoeneß und Karl-Heinz Rummenigge nach ihrer Meinung gefragt haben. Und das hat halt dafür so eine verwunderte Belustigung gesorgt. Aber er ist anders als viele andere Trainer rangegangen. Und interessanterweise gibt es ja aber zu dieser Zeit im deutschen Fußball dann auch erste Trainerfiguren, die jetzt auch nachweislich mit Erfolg ähnlich taktisch, also versuchen, über eine taktische Überlegenheit Spiele zu gewinnen. Also Jürgen Klopp hat sich definitiv etabliert, aber der hat eine ganz andere Außendarstellung. Mit Thomas Tuchel hat man jemanden, der mit Mainz 05 am Ende der Saison 2013, 2014 in die Europa League kommt. Da kommt jetzt auch etwas in Bewegung, finde ich.
Wisst ihr, wer Pep Guardiola damals auch sehr beeindruckt hat als Trainer in der Bundesliga?
Sag's.
Ralf Hasenhüttl bei Ingolstadt.
Stimmt, genau.
Pep Guardiola sitzt irgendwann auf einer Pressekonferenz und sagt so völlig unvermittelt Ingolstadt. Ja, Ingolstadt, die waren voll gut. Die fand ich super. Die haben total gut gegen uns gespielt. Da hatten wir totale Probleme. Und da spricht Ralf Hasenhüttl einfach ein unglaubliches Kompliment aus. Wo alle so da saßen, okay, das Spiel müssen wir uns, glaube ich, nochmal angucken. Aber, ja. Und Hasenhüttl geht dann zu Leipzig und macht mit Leipzig gute Dinge und ist jetzt ein Premier League-Trainer. Das stimmte dann schon auch irgendwie.
Stimmt, sehr guter Punkt. Und auch seine absolute Respekt vor den Kontern. Also fast schon seine Angst vor den Kontern. Das hat er ja immer wieder gesagt. Die Bundesliga ist die stärkste Umschalt-Liga der Welt. Und wir müssen das verhindern. Da hat er sich ja den Kopf drüber zerbrochen, was vielleicht andere in seiner Position jetzt auch nicht getan hätten.
Es gab noch ein zweites Spiel, was ihn, glaube ich, nachhaltig gepredigt hat. Und das war ein Freundschaftsspiel gegen Red Bull Salzburg im Jahr 2014, was damals mit Null zu bereitet wurde. Ich glaube, danach wollte er die halbe Mannschaft kaufen von Salzburg, weil er einfach besessen war davon, wie die gespielt haben. Also Kampel, Manet, die hat ja alle intern dann vorgeschlagen, wollte die unbedingt nach München holen. Das zeigt so ein bisschen auch diesen Wahnsinn, dass so ein Freundschaftsspiel einfach monatelang ihn beschäftigt.
Wir kommen ja noch zu den Halbfinals, die dann noch verloren wurden gegen Barcelona, gegen Atletico, aber halt auch diese Obsession, sich dann auch den Gegner auszurichten, die wird ihm ja schon bis heute zum Verhängnis. Weil wenn man jetzt guckt, wie Man City gegen Lyon ausgeschieden ist, und wie sich danach dann wirklich halt auch Spieler von Man City hinstellen, die ja wirklich alle auch sehr, sehr wohlwollende Pep-Jugger sind, aber durch die Blume sagen, hey Bushy, da hast du echt einen Schmarrn aufgestellt. Warum machst du das denn? Also lass uns doch bitte so spielen, wie wir es können. Dann schlagen wir Lyon auch.
Wir dachten, wir üben die Dreierkette im Training für das Halbfinale gegen Bayern, hat jemand zu The Athletic gesagt von City.
Ja, ja, aber also es war völlig aus der für das Finale, ja. Wir hatten dann im Halbfinale gegeneinander gespielt. Nee, aber es war so unnötig. Pep Guardiola ist sich bis heute halt einfach, ja, nicht zu schade, sondern er kommt nicht aus sich raus, aus seiner Haut, einfach auch mal an einem gewissen Punkt zu sagen, wisst ihr was, ich hab euch jetzt eigentlich alles gesagt und es ist auch scheißegal, wer der nächste Gegner ist, geht's einfach raus und haut die weg. Ja, weil ihr könnt es. Nee, er ist immer einer, der sagt, ja, wenn ich das sehe, er sieht das halt auch, er sieht dann so ein Tape von Olympique Lyon und sagt dann, ah, scheiße, die kommen da immer in den Raum hinter den Außenverteidigern und wir haben gerade so Hackstöcke als Innenverteidiger. Boah, da weiß ich nicht, ob das gut ist. Ich glaub, wir müssen jetzt Dreierkette spielen. Und ich muss glaube ich Kevin de Bruyne irgendwo anders hinstellen, weil der ist so gut, der kann das dann auch. Und das geht dann schon irgendwie auf. Und dann reift das so in ihm und dann stellt er das um und dann funktioniert's nicht. Und dann fragt er sich, wie kann das nicht funktionieren? Ich hab das doch alles gesehen. Und das ist doch alles super. Und die können das doch. Warum machen die das nicht? Ja, klar, aber es ist natürlich...
Es gehört ja zu seiner Brillanz aber dazu. Also es macht ihn ja so als Trainer so stark genau das, was ihn in so einem Moment dann schwach macht. Weil ich hab vorhin dieses 7-1 gegen AS Rom zum Beispiel angesprochen. Das war irre, weil er hat da sich was ganz Besonderes überlegt. Und zwar hat Arjen Robben in dem Spiel, wenn Bayern den Ball hatte, ist Robben nicht mit über die Mittellinie gegangen, sondern ist ganz rechts außen an der Außenlinie geblieben und hat da einfach immer gewartet an der Mittellinie. Gegenspieler bei Rom war damals Ashley Cole, glaube ich. Und Bayern hat sich dann immer irgendwo kleinräumig in der Mitte festgespielt. Und hat immer auf den Moment gewartet, wo Cole eingerückt ist, um zu helfen. Und immer in dem Moment ging der Ball raus. Und Robin ist dann mit voller Granateanlauf von der Mittellinie einfach mit Riesenplatz vor ihm aufs Tor zugelaufen. Es stand nach 32 Minuten, glaube ich, 4 zu 0. Cole wurde zur Halbzeit ausgewechselt. Und es ist einfach komplett aufgegangen. Also er muss im Vorfeld halt irgendwas beobachtet haben, dass Cole die Tendenz hat, immer einzurücken, wenn da irgendwo jemand durchbricht. Und deshalb hat der Robin einfach immer völlig absurd. Der stand teilweise außerhalb des Bildschirms, aber immer noch in der eigenen Hälfte, einfach nur um diesen Raum dann am Ende vor sich zu haben. Das heißt, diese Genialität geht ja auch oft genug auf. Und deshalb ist so ein bisschen die Frage, kriegt man das Gute ohne das Schlechte sozusagen in dem Moment? Oder muss man es irgendwie in Kauf nehmen, wenn man einen Trainer wie ihn hat, dass eben beide Seiten auch ein Stück weiter zugehören?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist auch so ein bisschen eine Frage der Retrospective oder der Perspektive, die man auf diese Frage hat. Ich glaube, in der Retrospective muss man über Pep Guardiola sagen, bei dem, was er an Spielern und Vereinen hatte, jetzt bei Bayern und bei Manchester City, ist das, was international dabei herausgesprungen ist, viel zu wenig. Und in der Perspektive konnte man aber bei einzelnen Spielen, und vielleicht kommen wir jetzt zu dem, was wir schon von einer halben Stunde angekündigt haben, nämlich dass wir mal auf die Halbfinalspiele gucken, konnte man da aber auch immer wieder andere Gründe für sehen, die auch nicht immer in seinem Verantwortungsbereich liegen. Also wenn wir eben zum Beispiel über die Saison 2014, 2015 sprechen, wo man eben gegen Barca das Auswärtsspiel mit 0 zu 3 verliert, da spielen dann eben Verletzungen eine große Rolle. Und ein bisschen auch so ein gewisser Lionel Messi, der da kurz vor Schluss noch zwei Tore macht. Und dann will Bayern unbedingt auf Auswärtstor spielen. Ich glaube, Bastian Schweinsteiger spielt ein Fehlpass oder rutscht aus. In der Rückwärtsbewegung bin ich mir gerade nicht mehr ganz sicher. Und Neymar macht da mit dem 3-0 in der 94. Minute ein bisschen den Deckel drauf, auch schon fürs Rückspiel. Also an diesen einzelnen Spielen konnte man auch immer andere Argumentationslinien fahren, finde ich, was Pep Guardiola angeht.
Auf jeden Fall gerade in dem 14-15, das war einfach so verletzungsdurchzogen dieses Jahr. Also Bayern spielt in Barcelona mit einer Dreierkette Rafinha Benatia Boateng. Und Benat spielt im Mittelfeld, also im Fünfer Mittelfeld. Und dann spielen aber im Fünfer Mittelfeld Lahm, Schweinsteiger Alonso und Thiago. Also ich sehe da keinen Flügelspieler. Und vorne spielen Lewandowski und Müller. Also die Namen Robben und Ribéry sucht man vergeblich. Und trotzdem ist Bayern in dem Spiel nicht viel schlechter als Barcelona. Also dieses 3-0 ist am Ende ein Ergebnis, das viel zu hoch ist in diesem Spiel. Und im Rückspiel wirft Bayern nochmal alles in die Waagschale, kommt zwar nie dem Wunder näher als zwei Treffer, aber gewinnt dann doch 3-2 gegen eine in dem Jahr eigentlich auch überragende Barca-Mannschaft mit Neymar, Messi und Suarez vorne. Und zeigt dann doch nochmal, dass man mit größter Anstrengung auch hätte Barcelona in die Schranken weisen können. Aber das war, glaube ich, in dem Jahr aufgrund der vielen Verletzungen einfach nicht möglich. Und dann hast du halt in einem Spiel auch mal nicht das Spielglück und kassierst eben einen Doppelpack von Messi und dann in der 94. noch das dritte Tor und dann ist das halt durch.
Ich erinnere mich, dass vor dem Hinspiel eine ernsthafte Diskussion war, ob Mitchell Weiser auf dem rechten offensiven Flügel startet, damit man überhaupt jemanden hat, der irgendwie im 1 zu 1 am Gegner vorbeikommt. Ich glaube, das unterstreicht die Verletzungsmiserie da absolut. Aber ich habe mich damals wahnsinnig darüber aufgeregt, wie man dieses aus einem 0 zu 1, was dann spät fiel, dann am Ende noch ein 0 zu 3 hat werden lassen. Und dadurch quasi auch die Champions-League-Saison zu Ende. Und das ist dann auch wieder ein bisschen Genie und Wahnsinn. Guardiola ist immer die Frage, wie viel Anteil Guardiola, wie viel Anteil die Mannschaft hat. Aber eigentlich war die Mannschaft mit Alonso, mit Schweinsteiger, mit Lahm, so weit, dass man in dem Moment merkt, wir gehen hier lieber mit einem 1 zu 0 raus, als am Ende irgendwie noch auf das Auswärtstor zu spielen. Und dann kriegst du zwei Konter und dann steht es 3-0 und du bist damit raus. Das war wirklich, das war unnötig. Aber die Verletzungsmisere, wie gesagt, ist hinreichend beschrieben.
Ja, und ich glaube, wir kommen hier dann auch nämlich so ein bisschen einer Sache auf die Spur, die eben stellvertretend für die Zeit von Pep Guardiola, für die Perspektive auf Pep Guardiola ist. Nämlich weil ich glaube, also wenn man sich diese Einzelspiele anguckt, und über Atletico können wir ja dann gleich sprechen, ich würde aber noch gerne kurz bei der Saison 2014, 2015 bleiben. In der Einzelspielbetrachtung ist das immer alles nicht ganz so heiß gekocht, wie es das Ergebnis suggeriert. Und man würde erwarten, dass zumindest, wenn die erste Emotion auch in der Fußballberichterstattung, und spielt nochmal eine Rolle, gerade bei internationalen Wettbewerben, das kann man, also das muss man einfach ein bisschen mit einpreisen, auch in der Berichterstattung, wenn diese Emotionen ein bisschen abgeklungen sind, dass man das einordnen, dass man das auch erklären kann. Und da gab es eben sehr gute Erklärungen. Habt ihr ja gerade super rausgearbeitet. Also Thiago auf dem rechten Flügel statt Robben ist anders. Und die Dreierreihe, die berühmte, hast du ja gerade schon genannt, Flo. Ich glaube aber, dass es ein Missverhältnis gab. Und zwar ein Missverhältnis aus nationaler Dominanz, bis der Titel gewonnen wurde. Und dann eben derzeit nach dem gewonnenen Titel national. Und eben diesem Ausscheiden. Und dass quasi dieses Missverhältnis dazu geführt hat, dass auch solche Spiele, die für sich genommen alle erklärbar waren und die alle dann auch alle drei Halbfinale niederlagen, haben natürlich wehgetan dem FC Bayern. Das ist ja völlig klar. Aber da waren jetzt, also das eine kann man als Verkaufsbezeichnung, aber da hat die Mannschaft eine entscheidende Rolle gespielt. Und es waren eben zwei Standardtore. Das wird auch wirklich oft vergessen. Das andere haben wir gerade besprochen. Und beim dritten war es so, Atletico. Da hat glaube ich Diego Simeone danach auch gesagt, also ich habe noch nie eine Mannschaft so gut gegen uns spielen sehen. Krass, dass wir hier weitergekommen sind. Und diese Betrachtung auf diese Spiele gab es aber so, in meiner Erinnerung, in der großen Wahrnehmung, in der Bewertung der Saisons von Pep Guardiola nicht, weil man eben auch diese nationale Dominanz gesehen hat, eben bis der Titel gewonnen wurde. Also 2014-15 war es ja wieder so. Hinrunde ohne Niederlage, in der Rückrunde 5 Niederlagen, Tabellenplatz 3 in der Rückrundetabelle. Ist wurscht, wenn du am Ende Meister wirst. Aber ich glaube daher kommt quasi diese, ja, eben auch diese fehlende Einordnung der Details, die eigentlich zu diesen Halbfinale Niederlagen geführt haben. Das ist so meine These ein bisschen dazu.
Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall valide. Also die Betrachtung kann man auf jeden Fall so anstellen. Aber am Ende fehlte glaube ich halt dann auch einfach der nationale Druck irgendwie so. Oder halt das, ja, also ich glaube...
Jetzt sind die anderen schuld. Nee, aber...
Nein, aber der Flo hat ja Recht. Die Weiterentwicklung... Die Weiterentwicklung kam ja nur aus Guardiola selbst. Weil Guardiola das wollte. Weil er irgendwie noch was gesehen hat. Die kam ja nicht dadurch, dass irgendwer Bayern herausgefordert hat, so wie das jetzt ein paar Jahre vorher mit Dortmund war, wo man sich wirklich an diesem Spiel dann richtig ausrichten musste. Sondern die Weiterentwicklung kam eigentlich nur aus dem Kopf Guardiolas, weil er irgendwie immer noch was Neues und immer noch was anderes entwickeln musste. Der Druck aus der Liga, klar, der fehlte.
Ich glaube, Bayern-Spieler haben zu dem Zeitpunkt oder in dieser Zeit hinter vorgehaltener Hand auch gesagt, Training ist bei uns irgendwie herausfordernder als das Spiel am Wochenende. Wir haben irgendwie drei wichtige Spiele im Jahr. Das ist das Heimspiel gegen Dortmund, das wir nicht verlieren dürfen, und die zwei Champions-League-Halbfinals. Alles andere läuft schon irgendwie so. Also tatsächlich, wirklich. Weil die zu dem Zeitpunkt einfach so gute Mittel hatten, den Gegner zu bespielen. Und es war einfach klar, dass sie jedes Spiel irgendwie, wenn es jetzt nicht gerade schief läuft, einfach sehr hoch gewinnen auf nationaler Ebene.
Und da passiert jetzt was auf nationaler Ebene, was für den größeren Kontext auch noch wichtig ist. In der Saison 2014, 2015 bewegen wir uns in der schlimmen BVB-Saison, die es in diesem Jahrzehnt gab, die letztlich auch zum Ende von Jürgen Klopp beim BVB als Trainer führen wird. Also zur Saison 2013, 2014, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, hatte man noch mit Mkhitaryan und Aubameyang sehr, sehr gute Verpflichtungen gemacht. Auch Sokratis hat ja damals noch eine gute Rolle gespielt. Zur Saison 2014, 2015 wechselt dann Robert Lewandowski ablösefrei nach einigem Hin und Her zum FC Bayern, wird ersetzt durch Giro Immobile, der unbenommen sehr große Talente hat, die man ja jetzt aktuell in der abgelaufenen Saison sehen konnte. Aber damals nicht immer gesehen hat. Und Dortmund spielt eine Hinrunde zum absoluten Vergessen. Das heißt, dieser Zweikampf an der Spitze zwischen Bayern und Dortmund, den gibt es nicht mehr. Sie sind punktgleich mit dem Letzten. Sie sind aufgrund eines mehr geschossenen Tores, sie haben 18 Tore in der Hinrunde erzielt, sind sie 17. geworden. Also so genau müssen wir das schon sein, Flo. Aber so läuft Dortmund in die Winterpause ein. Also auf Tabellenplatz 17, in der Rückrunde kommt man dann, also in der Rückrunden-Tabelle, auf Tabellenplatz 5. Insgesamt kommt man so gerade noch in die Europa League. Und das Zustandekommen dieses 17. Tabellenplatzes war absurd. Da waren Spiele dabei, die darf Dortmund nicht verlieren und die verliert Dortmund auch nicht, wenn man sie noch mal dreimal spielen lässt. Da waren ganz, ganz viele Einzereignisse mit dabei, die dazu geführt haben. Dortmund war viel, viel besser als sein Tabellenplatz, das ausgesagt hat zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Man hatte unglaublich viel Pech. Aber es hat eben dazu geführt, dass der direkte Konkurrent und auch der einzige Konkurrent, der finanziell halbwegs mithalten konnte mit dem Bayern, der war für diese Saison sehr früh außer Reichweite. Und am Ende laufen dann Wolfsburg und Gladbach hinter Bayern ein in der Endabrechnung der Tabelle. Dann Leverkusen und für die Europa League qualifizieren sich dann Augsburg, Schalke und eben dann gerade noch der BVB hinten raus. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, das ist eine ganz wichtige Saison, wenn man eben die Frage stellt, warum konnte die einzige Mannschaft, die das wirtschaftlich, der einzige Verein, der das wirtschaftlich vielleicht hätte, irgendwie noch wuppen können, auch mit einer klugen Transferstrategie, die man ja auch hatte, warum konnte der den Bayern dann auch in der Folge nichts gegenhalten? Und da ist, glaube ich, einfach diese Saison ist entscheidend. Jürgen Klopp weg am Ende der Saison, Thomas Tuchel wird kommen. Und es werden ja dann auch Spieler wieder wegwechseln. Das ist ja immer das große Problem von Borussia Dortmund gewesen. Ich hab das Gefühl, da ist es ein Knackpunkt. Ab hier ist dann, jetzt läuft Bayern nicht nur dem Rest der Liga davon, sondern auch Dortmund. Seht ihr genauso, finde ich?
Das ist so.
Ich finde halt bezeichnend, dass Wolfsburg, Wolfsburg wird halt dann zweiter. Und das hängt eigentlich zu großen Teilen mit Kevin de Bruyne einfach nur zusammen, weil die halt einen überragenden Einzelspieler haben. An dieser Wolfsburger Mannschaft ist jetzt nicht allzu viel Besonderes, auch wenn sie es halt einfach auch mal schafft, den FC Bayern 4 zu 1 zu zersiegen. Den Guardiola Bayern zum Auftakt der Rückrunde. Aber die nationalen Verhältnisse sind einfach zementiert in dieser Phase.
Ja, und es ist halt dann richtig bitter für Dortmund, natürlich Lewandowski ablösefrei zu verlieren, wenn man da wenigstens die große Herausforderung für Mannschaften wie Dortmund, die halt schon hohe wirtschaftliche Möglichkeiten haben, aber natürlich trotzdem noch so sind, dass sie immer wieder Spieler verlieren. Die Kunst ist ja dann, hohe Transfereinnahmen zu generieren und dann gute Leute nachwachsen zu lassen. Ja, ich meine, da hat Werder Bremen über zehn Jahre lang oder noch länger eine Kunst draus gemacht. Und das kommt halt beides zusammen. Einerseits verlieren sie Spieler wie Lewandowski ablösefrei. Andererseits sitzen auch nicht unbedingt jeder Neuzugang fest. Und dann bricht es eben aber auch sofort weg. Also der Margin of Error, der ist einfach wahnsinnig klein geworden, wenn du eine Mannschaft wie Bayern in dieser Phase vorne hast, die ja ganz wenig liegen lässt und über weite Strecken wirklich fast perfekt in Fußball spielt.
Und es ist ja noch etwas passiert in diesem Jahr 2014. Deutschland ist Weltmeister geworden. Und in der Regel hat eigentlich häufig der FC Bayern Probleme mit den Langzeitfolgen von Turnieren, weil man eben auch immer sehr viele deutsche Nationalspieler oder generell Nationalspieler stellt. Vielleicht spielt das aber da auch noch in Teilen mit rein, dass Dortmund eher das nicht kompensiert bekommt. Und deswegen auch diese fürchterliche, also das trägt vielleicht auch bei zu dieser Hinrunde. Und ich glaube auch generell zur Wahrnehmung des deutschen Fußballs. Also man hat eben diesen Weltmeistertitel geholt, mit zum Teil vier Innenverteidigungen in der letzten Kette. Die Büffelabwehr war das doch. Scott Rambustavi hat gespielt, hat sich dann verletzt. So wurde Lahm wieder dann zum Rechtsverteidiger. Man hat sich irgendwie gegen Algerien im Eistonnenspiel, wie ich es jetzt mal nenne, durchgespielt. Mit der im Nachhinein lustigen Freistoßvariante, wo sich Thomas Müller fallen lässt beim Freistoß und dann durchläuft. Und es geht aber ganz fürchterlich schief. Dann kommt dieses Viertelfinale gegen Frankreich. Mats Hummels macht das 1 zu 0. Frankreich ist aber wirklich auf Augenhöhe. Das drückt das Ergebnis auch aus. Manuel Neuer mit einer wichtigen Parade ganz kurz vor Schluss. Dann eben dieses 7 zu 1, wo wir, was ja häufiger in diesem Jahrzehnt passiert, interessanterweise so epochale Ergebnisse haben, die auch jeweils für beide Mannschaften so eine Weichenstellung bedeuten. Also Deutschland wusste nicht, wie ihm geschieht bei diesem 7 zu 1 und hat es gleichzeitig aber geschafft, diesen hohen Sieg im Gastgeberland der Weltmeisterschaft auch so zu gestalten, dass man auch mit einem hohen Ansehen aus diesem Sieg herausgegangen ist. Also man hat sich da nicht überheblich verhalten. Da gab es durchaus andere nationalen Mannschaften. Also Looking at die 82er WM-Truppe von Deutschland nun mal als ein Beispiel. Oder auch Looking an Andreas Möller, wie er sich nach dem Elfmeter 96 in England hinstellt, also ohne das jetzt über Spitzen zu wollen. Aber da hat es Deutschland irgendwie geschafft ganzheitlich, sportlich und auch in der Art und Weise, wie man aufgetreten ist, hat man sich da sehr positiv positioniert und auch so positiv, dass man dann über Dinge wie eben nichtgegebene Elfmeter oder rote Karten gegen Neuer im WM-Finale gegen Argentinien oder eine Riesenchance von Higuain, da guckt man einfach drüber hinweg und im Nachhinein ist dann dieser 2014er-Titel scheinbar logisch und das Ende einer Entwicklung. Und das Interessante ist, finde ich, dass es für Dortmund tatsächlich das Ende einer Entwicklung ist, auch wenn die natürlich ein weniger Spieler stellen in dieser Finalmannschaft und sich im Nachhinein aber herausstellt, bei dem Bayern ist das eigentlich nicht so. Für einzelne Spieler ja, aber Bayern hat es schon geschafft, schleichend diesen Umbruch, die Weiterentwicklung des Kaders einzuleiten, was eben jetzt dann dazu führen wird, dass kein anderer mehr Deutscher Meister werden wird in diesem Jahrzehnt.
Ja, du siehst halt dann relativ schnell, Schweinsteiger wird aussortiert, oder sortiert sich selber aus, oder Schweinsteigers Körper sortiert sich aus. Und es gibt dann schon so, ja, so leichte Ansatzpunkte. Ich fand Pep Guardiola war nie besonders gut darin, eine Vision dafür zu haben, welche neuen Spieler seiner Mannschaft oder seinem Spiel gut tun würden. Da hat er sich bei Barcelona nicht besonders hervorgetan, in Sachen Transferpolitik, und bei Bayern dann irgendwie auch nicht. Also diese Hispanisierung der Mannschaft, dass so kreativ er in seinen ganzen Spieldingen war, und so weitläufig und weltmännisch er war, so engstirnig fand ich das. Einfach dieses, ja, da hole ich mir halt meine Spanier, weil die kenne ich noch am besten. Also das passt für mich irgendwie auch gar nicht so richtig zusammen. Aber was ich ganz interessant finde im Gesamtkontext, jetzt was du gesagt hast mit 2014, Hansi Flick war damals ja dann schon Co-Trainer der deutschen Nationalmannschaft. Tuchel kommt dann auf in Deutschland. Und so langsam reifen diese Trainerfrüchte. Und die kommunieren dann natürlich jetzt auch in der Anschauung oder in diesem Phänomen, dass du jetzt drei deutsche Trainer im Champions-League-Halbfinale hattest. Wo viele aus Europa drauf geschaut haben und gesagt haben, wie konnte das denn jetzt passieren? Was machen die in Deutschland da? Was machen die anders? Ach, Fußballlehrerausbildung. Ich hätte es so passend gefunden, wenn Guardiola noch im Halbfinale gewesen wäre, weil du hättest dann mit Flick, Tuchel und Nagelsmann Trainer gehabt, die alle Einflüsse von Guardiola in sich vereinen. Und wenn man dann nochmal jetzt die Bogen wieder zu Bayern spannt, mit Louis van Gaal und dessen Einfluss für die deutsche Nationalmannschaft und damit dessen Einfluss für den deutschen Fußball um 2010 herum, das darf man nicht verkennen. Und Pep Guardiola, eben um die 2014 Jahre herum, hatte auch einen sehr, sehr hohen Einfluss. Also A, Anteil an der Entwicklung der Spieler, die dann eben auch ein Gros der Weltmeistermannschaft zu 14 gestellt haben. Aber eben auch einen prägenden Einfluss auf andere Trainer, einen prägenden Einfluss auf die Bundesliga und generell einen prägenden Einfluss auf den deutschen Fußball. Und das gab es aber dann mit dem Aus von Pep Guardiola dann irgendwie nicht mehr. Also so diesen Bayern-getriebenen Impact für den deutschen Fußball, den Bayern-Trainer-getriebenen Impact für den deutschen Fußball, der verliert sich dann so in den folgenden Jahren.
Einer Aspekt möchte ich noch im Bezug auf die WM 2.14 ansprechen, weil es auch mit Bayern und Dortmund zu tun hat. Auch Löw wird ja häufig vorgeworfen, dass er manchmal zu verkopft agiert und sich dann über Dinge Gedanken macht, die vielleicht nicht so relevant sind. Aber er hat eine sehr richtige Entscheidung aus Meisig getroffen. Und das war dieses Problem zu adressieren, dass es zwischen Bayern und Dortmund Spielern in dieser Mannschaft gab. Er hat ja damals Kevin Großkreutz und Bastian Schweinsteiger legendärerweise da gemeinsam einquartiert in Brasilien. Und ich glaube schon, dass das Kalkül dahinter war. Wenn sich diese beiden Antipoden Großkreutz und Schweinsteiger verstehen, dann gibt es auch in der restlichen Gruppe keinerlei Alibi mehr, dass man irgendwie sich behakt oder irgendwie mit Animositäten begegnet. Und ich glaube, dass es ihm da gelungen ist, da dann richtig Kraft rauszuziehen. Auch wenn jetzt der Dortmunder Block am Ende gar nicht mehr so stark war im Kader, so wie es noch vorher war, als dann auch noch Reus mit dabei war und so weiter. Trotzdem glaube ich ganz wichtig und deshalb definitiv ein Endpunkt einer Entwicklung zwischen 2010 und 2014, die ganz klar von Bayern und Dortmund geprägt wurden. Lass uns ganz kurz, Athletico wollten wir noch kurz ansprechen, damit wir das noch abgehakt haben. Ist wiederum ein anderes Halbfinale als die beiden davor, also dann 2.16 dann das Halbfinale. Das ist eigentlich der Moment, wo Bayern eigentlich voll da ist. Da gibt es dann keine Verletzungsmisere mehr und so weiter. Bayern spielt gegen Athletico wirklich einen richtig, richtig guten Fußball. Über zwei Spiele gesehen 53 zu 18 Torschüsse. Im Rückspiel ein Elfmeter noch verschossen. Zwar auch selbst ein Elfmeter von Gris-Mont gehalten von Neuer. Aber trotzdem eigentlich ein Spiel, was du einfach klarer gewinnen musst und dann eben auch ins Finale einziehst. Das war so der rätselhafteste Moment dieser Guardiola-Ära. Weil alle anderen Halbfinals kann man irgendwie eine Geschichte drum stricken, kann man sich auch irgendwie erklären. Atletico kann ich nicht erklären. Also das wäre eigentlich der Moment gewesen, wo diese Guardiola-Zeit beim FC Bayern durchaus auch die Krönung noch hätte finden können. Und ich muss auch sagen, wir haben das vorhin ja auch schon kurz angedeutet, diese Kritik, die auch immer lauter wurde an Guardiola, wo sich auch teilweise über seine Sprachbarrieren und ich merke am liebsten 1000 Dantes und so weiter, sich sehr viel lustig gemacht wurde. Die Häme, die danach so über Guardiola und auch über Bayern niederprasselte, fand ich schon krass, weil gerade jetzt auch so retrospektiv betrachtet, auch als Journalist hätte ich ja Interesse daran, dass so ein Typ wie Guardiola einfach in der Bundesliga arbeitet und noch an diesem starken Fußball vorbeizuschauen. Das fand ich bemerkenswert zumindest.
Es gibt noch einen Aspekt aus dem Athletikospiel, dem man ihm halt schon zum Nachteil reichen kann. Er spielt in Madrid mit Müller und Ribéry auf der Bank. Er lässt halt beide draußen. Das kann man argumentativ auch sehr gut begründen. Aber wenn du am Ende halt verlierst, 1-0 auswärts, und du hast halt die zwei großen Identifikationsfiguren oder zwei von drei mit Lahm zu dem Zeitpunkt für diesen Verein auf der Bank gelassen, dann hast du einen Fehler gemacht als Trainer. Den können sie dann im Rückspiel nicht revidieren. Er hat Douglas Costa in dem Spiel vertraut, der eine abartige Hinrunde gespielt hatte, wenn ich mich erinnere. Douglas Costa hat ein halbes Jahr für Bayern gespielt.
Und hat sehr häufig aufs Tor geschossen.
In der Hinrunde hat er noch irgendwelche Außenristflanken gebracht. Aber heute auch Übersteiger probiert. Oder diesen Über-Kopf-Zier. Wo ihn dann Robin danach gesagt hat, das machen wir nicht, auch wenn wir 3-0 führen. Das macht man hier in Deutschland nicht. Ich würde aber ganz gerne auf einen Punkt eingehen. Ich würde nämlich genau die Gegenthese vertreten. Steffen, du hast gesagt, als Journalist muss man doch ein Interesse haben, dass dieser Trainer wohl gelitten ist und in der Liga bleibt. Und ich würde sagen... Da würde mich deine Meinung interessieren, Flo, da bin ich ja auch so ein bisschen Außenseiter. Aber ich glaube, gerade als Journalist hat dir Pep Guardiola ganz wenig gegeben. Gerade weil er eben immer zu jedem Spieler gesagt hat, der ist super, super und er hätte gerne 1000 Dantes, war es ja ganz schwierig, über den FC Bayern zu berichten. Und ich glaube, das spielt dann nämlich schon auch eine Rolle, dass journalistisch gesehen Pep Guardiola sehr wenig Fleisch gegeben hat für Berichterstattung.
Das ist sicherlich, aber prinzipiell bist du als Journalist nicht dafür verantwortlich, irgendjemandem irgendwas.
Zu geben. Außer die Wahrheit und außer die Berichterstattung. Ich habe mich nur über diese Häme gewundert. Selbst wenn ich von dem keine spannenden Aussagen bekomme, oder der mich nicht nah dran lässt, muss ich doch zumindest sehen, dass sich fußballerisch was tut. Das ist doch spannend, was da passiert. Das ist nur der Punkt, den ich machen wollte. Kritisieren kann man immer, aber es ging ja weit darüber hinaus.
Ja, aber da trafen zwei sehr, sehr große Phänomene aufeinander. Oder beziehungsweise Pep Guardiola hat in der Zeit entlarvt, dass der deutsche Fußball-Journalismus sich sehr wenig mit Fußball beschäftigt hat. Das hat sich in den letzten Jahren ein bisschen geändert. Es hat sich aber vor allem auch durch den Rasenfunk anmerkt. Es gibt einfach mehr Formate, und es gibt auch nicht von Journalisten gemachte Formate, die sich wieder mehr mit dem Spielfußball auseinandersetzen. In der Zeit von Pep Guardiola war, man hat schon zur Kenntnis genommen, dass Bayern guten Fußball spielt. Es gab auch Ansätze, das zu erklären. Das hat auch Leute wirklich interessiert und sich reingezogen. Aber die Berichterstattung verlief dann doch häufig sehr nah an der Oberfläche. Wenn dann aber ein Trainer da sitzt, der sich ein bisschen hinter seiner Sprachbarriere versteckt und sich leider auf folgenden Jahren, Jahr zwei, drei, in seinem Deutsch nicht weiterentwickelt hat, was ich ihm jetzt gar nicht vorwerfen möchte, aber er hat sich da drin halt auch so ein bisschen eingerichtet. Er hat es jetzt nicht als wertig erkannt, sich da mehr zu erklären, was dann wiederum darin lag, dass er auch gemerkt hat, dass die Leute gar nicht so interessiert darin sind, sich mit ihm über Taktik zu unterhalten. Also er hat aber auch nicht versucht, die Presse zu missionieren und hat dann irgendwann was dann so ein abgekühltes Verhältnis zueinander. Er hat von den Journalisten nichts erwartet und die Journalisten haben von ihm nichts erwartet. Man hätte aber auch, wenn es ihm wichtig gewesen wäre, sich zu erklären, hätte man kleinere Runden machen können. Man hätte auch sagen können, red Englisch mit uns. Das wäre dann wiederum für die TV-Journalisten nicht gegangen. Dann hätte man wieder unterschiedliche Runden machen müssen. Also es hätte schon Mittel und Wege gegeben, aber es hätte alles irgendwie Widerstände hervorgerufen. Und deswegen hat man das dann irgendwann gelassen. Und wo ich euch zustimme oder wo ich zumindest dir zustimme am Ende, war dann schon auch bei dem einen oder anderen gewisse Häme rauszulesen, dass halt dieser Typ, der einem da Woche für Woche nicht viel gegeben hat auf so einer Pressekonferenz, der sich nicht wirklich erklärt hat, der von Anfang an halt auch so dieses ich gebe keine Interviews at one on one, mach ich nicht. Weil aus irgendwelchen heeren Zielen, aber dann hat er halt irgendwie sich mit dem Audi-Magazin hingesetzt und hat da irgendwie ein one on one, fünf Seiten Interview mit dem Audi-Chef irgendwie veröffentlicht. Und da konnte glaube ich, da war der ein oder andere Journalist dann doch irgendwo Mensch und hat dann ein bisschen einen kleinen Fingerhut voll Hämel dann noch über Pep Guardiola ausgekippt, als er dann auch im dritten Anlauf es nicht geschafft hat, die Bayern ins Champions League Finale zu führen. Und der ein oder andere war dann irgendwann glaube ich auch froh, dass dieser dann doch ein bisschen anstrengende Spanier dann nach drei Jahren dann mal weg war aus München und es dann wieder jemand Neuen gab, den man bearbeiten konnte.
Dann lasst uns mal über diesen Neuen und das, was jetzt dann eben kam, sprechen. Um kurz noch den Kontext einzuordnen. Thomas Tuchel war in der Saison 5 und 16 Trainer von Dortmund, ist sehr nahe an den Bayern drangeblieben. Die Hinrunde war fabelhaft von Borussia Dortmund. Bayern hatte eine Niederlage in den 17 Spielen. Auch Dortmund hatte nur eine Niederlage. Nur wegen eines unentschieden Meeres wird Bayern Herbstmeister. In der Rückrunde war es dann deutlicher. Bayern konnte dann Meister werden. Aber jetzt passiert etwas beim größten Rivalen von Bayern. Es wird gesagt, dass auf keinen Fall Mkhitaryan, Hummels und Günduan gehen. Und es gehen zur Saison 2016, 2017 Mkhitaryan, Hummels und Günduan mittlerer von den drei. Also Hummels auch zum FC Bayern, zum Konkurrenten. Und jetzt kann im Grunde trainieren, wer will bei Bayern. Sie werden immer Meister werden, obwohl es ganz oft hakt. Unter anderem ja jetzt eben mit dem Nachfolger von Pep Guardiola, nämlich mit Carlo Ancelotti, der angeblich die Fessin von Guardiola losgelöst hätte. Das war die Berichterstattung in den ersten Spielen von Ancelotti. Und irgendwann kratzte man sich aber so am Kopf, warum da so wenig zusammengeht.
Ja, also wenn wir vorhin gesagt haben bei van Gaal, dass es überraschend war, dass man nach einem Experiment-Trainer den zweiten schwierigen Typen geholt hat, war das jetzt in die andere Richtung, würde ich sagen. Man hat nachdem Guardiola den Verein über drei Jahre echt herausgefordert hat. Und ich glaube auch gerade in der Abwesenheit von Hoeneß, sich auch im Verein einfach was verändert hat. Es gab das Zerwürfnis mit Müller Wohlfahrt, es gab den Abgang von Schweinsteiger, es gab dann auch den Abgang von Bad Stuber. Es war so ein bisschen diese heile Welt, wir liegen uns alle in den Armen und es ist hier eine Einheit. Was auch die Heinkirchzeit extrem geprägt hat, das war so ein bisschen weg. Für mich war Ancelotti, der irgendwie gemütlich ist, mit dem man gut zusammenarbeiten kann, wo es einen persönlichen Draht zu Rummenigge gab und so weiter, war für mich eher so ein bisschen diese Sicherheitslösung, die man dann nach drei Jahren high speed und sophisticated, Stress im System, die man da drin hatte. Ich glaube, Ancelotti war einfach so eine Lösung, wo man gesagt hat, der macht das jetzt, der wird das ordentlich machen, der hat Erfahrung im Umgang mit Stars. Aber damit verband man jetzt keinen großen Anspruch, sich jetzt in irgendeine Richtung weiterzuentwickeln. Und das zeigte sich, glaube ich, auch relativ schnell. Es ist natürlich auch undankbar, muss man schon auch sagen, nach Heinkiss und Guardiola als Trainer zu kommen. Das ist natürlich auch heftig, vor allen Dingen dann, wenn weite Teile der Mannschaft eben auch noch die gleichen sind. Es gab natürlich den ein oder anderen Neuzugang, aber es waren viele, die jetzt mit sehr hoch, mit starken Trainern, die einer Mannschaft viel gegeben haben, zusammengearbeitet haben. Und Ancelotti hatte ja dann auch schnell den Ruf. Und ich glaube, das kann man auch, wenn man auch mal vor Ort ab und zu war, das kann Flo sicherlich bestätigen. Das Training hat sich verändert, da war weniger Zug drin, das war weniger variantenreich. Es ist ja teilweise sogar so, wenn man sich diese Rondos angeschaut hat in der Zeit von Guardiola, also diese Übungen, zum Beispiel 5 gegen 2, oder in verschiedenen Variationen kann man die ja spielen. Was dafür ein Tempo drin war und wie dann bei Ancelotti viel weniger da einfach funktioniert hat, wie viele Bälle da weggesprungen sind, das ist jetzt nur ein Anekdotisch, aber es trotzdem unterstreicht es ja irgendwie, dass da auf allen Ebenen Tempo rausgenommen wurde. Und das sah man aus meiner Sicht dann auch schnell, als dann auch die Automatismen aus der Guardiola-Zeit weg waren, auch relativ schnell auf dem Platz.
Ja, aber der Anspruch der Bayern war ja schon, mit Ancelotti dann die Champions League zu gewinnen. Also das war ja schon so dieses... Wir haben jetzt noch relativ viele vom Triple-Team, die wissen, wie es geht. Die haben jetzt beim PEP nochmal wirklich das Fußballspielen neu gelernt. Und jetzt holen wir da diesen Handaufleger, der ja mit Real Madrid dann nach 100 Jahren mal wieder die Champions League gewonnen hatte 2014, der uns ja auch 4-0 geschlagen hat in München. Klammer auch, Sergio Ramos Kopfballtore klammer zu. Und mit ein bisschen Handauflegen und ein bisschen federlich gut zureden, gewinnen die jetzt auf jeden Fall die Champions League war so ein bisschen die Ansicht.
Der italienische Jupp.
Der italienische Jupp, der aber halt auch, und das war so ein bisschen die Schwierigkeit, halt auch sein ganzes italienisches Team, seinen ganzen italienischen Stuff und halt durchaus auch sehr illustre Gestalten damit an die Säbener Straße angeschleppt hat, die dann am Ende auch teilweise nicht so ganz, also einen anderen Ansatz verfolgt haben und nicht so eine ganz, so eine Professionalität, sag ich jetzt mal, an den Tag.
Der rauchende Co-Trainer zum Beispiel.
Der rauchende Fitness-Coach. Fitness-Coach mit Fluppe im Mund. So, und ich hab mir zu dem Zeitpunkt damals die Ancelotti Biografie reingezogen. Und diese Biografie war quasi eine einzige Rechtfertigung, so hab ich das zumindest heute in Erinnerung, wie er quasi nach dem Real Madrid Champions-League-Sieg, wie er dann danach, in der Saison danach, musste er dem Florentino Perez bei Real die ganze Zeit erklären, nein, wir trainieren nicht zu lasch. Nein, wir trainieren nicht zu lasch. Ich kann die nicht so hart trainieren lassen. Nein, wir trainieren nicht zu lasch.
Deswegen hieß sie ja auch Quiet Leadership.
Genau. Und dann fängt er bei Bayern an und irgendwann sagt jeder, boah, das mit dem Training, das sah unter Guardiola irgendwie anders aus. Was machen die denn da? Ich habe mir jetzt gerade auch nochmal die Ergebnisse aus der Saison angeschaut. Und das ist schon sehr, sehr, wenn man das in der ganzen, diese Ergebnisliste sieht. Die gewinnen acht Spiele zum Anfang der Saison, inklusive der Supercup gegen Dortmund, in Dortmund 2-0. Alles super. Starten mit einem lockerflockigen, weißt du es?
Ja, ja, das war gegen Werder 6-0. Das war ja das losgelöste Fessenspiel. Ich glaube, da fiel schon dieses Zitat.
Ja, also die starten mit einem 6-0 gegen Werder in die Saison, gewinnen acht Spiele am Stück, acht Pflichtspiele und spielen dann in der Champions League am zweiten Spieltag gegen Atletico Madrid, bei Atletico Madrid, da wo Pep Guardiola ja versagt hat auf gut Deutsch, wie man es ihm ausgelegt hat, und verlieren 1-0. Und plötzlich stellt sich alles wieder so in Frage und dann gibt es einen Doppelpack an weiteren Spielen, die Bayern nicht gewinnt. 1-1 zu Hause gegen Köln, 2-2 gegen Frankfurt und man hieft sich dann über einen Champions League-Sieg gegen Eindhoven wieder in die Spur.
Also acht Siege, dann Spiele nicht gewonnen. So, jetzt geht es weiter. Man gewinnt gegen Eindhoven, man gewinnt gegen Gladbach, man gewinnt gegen Augsburg, drei Heimspiele hintereinander. Man gewinnt in Augsburg, das eine Augsburg-Heimspiel war ein DFB-Pokal. Man gewinnt auch in Eindhoven in der Champions League. Und jetzt kommt wieder ein Paket von drei Spielen, die Bayern hintereinander weg nicht gewinnt. Sie spielen daheim nur 1-1 gegen Hoffenheim, sie verlieren in Dortmund 1-0 und sie spielen in der Champions League auswärts bei dem Weltklub FK Rostov 2-3. Sie verlieren in Rostov am Don. Das zieht sich dann so durch die ganze Saison, weil dann irgendwann kriegen sie wieder in die Kurve, dann gewinnen sie wieder acht Spiele in Folge, starten auch gut in die Rückrunde und haben ein sehr gutes Frühjahr unter Ancelotti und dann, als die Saison auf die Zielgerade zugeht, passt plötzlich gar nichts mehr zusammen und sie gewinnen von sechs Spielen nur eins. Also du hast dann am 4.4. auswärts in Hoffenheim verlieren sie 1-0, spielen dann zu Hause, gewinnen sie 4-1 gegen Dortmund und dann Champions League 1-2 gegen Real Madrid, 0-0 gegen Leverkusen Liga, 2-4 nach Verlängerung gegen Real Madrid, 2-2 gegen Mainz in der Liga und 2-3 im DFB-Pokal-Halbfinale zu Hause gegen Dortmund. Du hast also quasi eine Saison, in der sehr, sehr viel glatt läuft, in der sehr viele gute Ergebnisse erzählt werden, aber drei Phasen innerhalb einer Saison, wo plötzlich in drei Spielen oder sogar noch mehr Spielen hintereinander plötzlich nichts mehr zusammenläuft. Und da merkt man so ein bisschen diese Fragilität und auch das Entfragestellen des Ganzen, dass eine Niederlage oder ein Negativ-Ergebnis schnell dazu führt, unter Ancelotti, dass sie sich sehr unsicher sind und nicht so richtig wissen, wo sie eigentlich stehen, nicht so richtig wissen, wie sie jetzt eigentlich wieder in die Erfolgsspur zurückfinden.
Und gleichzeitig hast du, also Dortmund haben wir schon genannt, die haben ganz große Abgänge verzeichnet zur Saison 16-17. Es kam dann immerhin Mario Götze zurück und ein gewisser Usman Dembélé. Also beim 3-2 von Dortmund in München beim DFB-Pokal-Halbfinale, das war ein Dembélé-Spiel. Das zeigt quasi, dass Dortmund es in dieser Phase wieder geschafft hat, mit zumindest einzelnen guten Transfers. Also man hat auch andere Schürle gehört, no offense, aber hatte halt nicht die große sportliche Auswirkung. Aber auch Marc Bartra zum Beispiel hat man zu dieser Saison hingehört. Raphael Guerrero übrigens auch. Also Dortmund hat es wieder geschafft, die Abgänge gut zu kompensieren. Wird Tabellen dritter und warum Tabellen dritter? Und da möchte ich jetzt nämlich darauf hinaus, weil das ist jetzt auch nochmal wichtig für die Gesamtkonstellation der Liga, weil Rabah Leipzig jetzt in der Liga angekommen ist und weil Rabah Leipzig ganz lange Zeit den Bayern auf den Fersen bleibt. Also man kommt nur deshalb als Herbstmeister an, weil Rabah zum einen, die bleiben bis zum 14. Spieltag ungeschlagen, verlieren dann gegen den 1. FC Ingolstadt, der, nee, den FC Ingolstadt, der Tabellen 18. war zu diesem Zeitpunkt mit 0 zu 1. Wisst ihr noch, wer damals Trainer von Ingolstadt war? Ich muss es auch nachgucken. Also Hasenhüttl war Leipzig-Trainer. Nee, nee, nicht ganz. Es war leider ein 15-30-Spiel. Ansonsten hätte man sagen können, es war die Walpurgis-Nacht von Ingolstadt. Mike Walpurgis war damals Trainer. Und Ingolstadt hat sich ja so ein bisschen etabliert, gemeinsam mit Augsburg als Raberschreck. Also gegen die hat Rasenball häufig verloren. Und dann eben ein 0 zu 3 am letzten Spieltag der Hinrunde. Das war auch die Forstberg-Rote Karte faul an Philipp Lahm. Da hat er allerdings auch Leipzig eine große Chance, bevor Bayern dann das mit 3 zu 0 gewonnen hat. Aber das hat sich jetzt verändert. Es ist eine weitere Mannschaft in der Liga angekommen, die zumindest in dieser ersten Saison, und wir wissen jetzt auch in der Rückschau, das wird jetzt auch so bleiben, sich sofort oben etabliert. Und wegen der anderen Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten, wegen des anderen Geschäftsmodells, dass man eben zum Beispiel auf ganz wundersame Art und Weise aus Salzburg ganz oft tolle Spieler bekommt nach Leipzig, Leipzig wird nicht mehr weggehen. Und das verändert sich jetzt im deutschen Fußball. Und das ist wichtig für alle anderen Vereine. Jetzt mal jenseits von allen fankulturellen und sonstigen Themen, ich positioniere mich ja mit dem Raba da auch relativ deutlich. Wir sind eben einfach werbefrei im Rasenfunk, und deswegen wird es für mich immer Raba bleiben. Aber wichtig ist, es kommt eine dritte Mannschaft, als Konkurrent von Bayern in die Liga, bei der man jetzt im Nachhinein sagen kann, sie hat die Mittel, aufgrund ihrer Strukturen, da auch dauerhaft als Rivale zu bleiben. Und das nimmt allen anderen Punkte weg. Also in dieser Saison 2016, 2017, kommt Hoffenheim in die Champions-League-Qualifikation. Da werden wir auch noch über gewisse Trainer-Persönlichkeiten sprechen, die dann auch nochmal wichtig werden. Köln, Hertha und Freiburg kommen in die Europa League. Und zwar mit 49, 49 und 48 Punkten. Das sind schon deutlich weniger als es in mancher Saison vorher war. Nicht in jeder Saison, so will ich es nicht sagen. Aber das heißt, es gibt jetzt quasi einen größeren Gap hinter den oberen drei. In dem Fall waren es sogar die oberen vier in dieser einen Saison noch. Und dahinter rückt es zusammen. Und dahinter setzt aber auch ein Hauen und Stechen ein, um irgendwie in die Europa League-Ränge zu kommen. Was eben in der Saison Köln, Hertha und Freiburg als Aufsteiger schaffen. Köln, die erinnern sich sowieso alle dran, wie sie da gelandet sind, muss ich nicht nochmal sagen. Und das ist wichtig, weil in der Saison zum Beispiel Gladbach, Schalke, Leverkusen, Wolfsburg, die spielen alle nicht international. Wolfsburg sogar Relegation. Während in uns Mario Gomez gegen Eintracht Braunschweig müsste das gewesen sein, wenn ich es noch richtig auf dem Schirm habe. Und das ist, glaube ich, eben wichtig, wenn man die Frage stellt, warum... Also wir reden, wir werden jetzt immer wieder auch kritisieren bei den Bayern, haben wir ja schon bei Ancelotti schon angefangen. Trotzdem werden die in der Saison mit 15 Punkten Vorsprung werden die Meister. Und das liegt eben daran, dass Bayern sowieso schon aus seinen hervorragenden Mitteln und die Champions-League-Einnahmen werden immer hoch bleiben. Und Merchandise ja sowieso, Ligakröses. Auf denen wird man immer aufbauen können. Und gleichzeitig gibt es zwar einen zweiten Konkurrenten, das ist aber für den Restkontext, glaube ich, der Liga, eher eine schlechte Nachricht, weil sie nicht dieser Konkurrent sind, sondern jetzt wird es noch enger. Es wird noch schwieriger, in die Champions League zu kommen, wo du eben das große Geld verdienst. Und dass in dieser Saison mit Leipzig und Hoffenheim zwei Mannschaften neben Dortmund und Bayern in der Champions League bzw. Champions League Qualifikation spielen, die ganz anders aufgestellt von ihrem Finanzierungsmodell her als klassische Vereine wie eben Schalke, wie eben Leverkusen, ein ganz schlechtes Beispiel, Gladbach. Aber zum Beispiel, das ist, glaube ich, wichtig. Ich glaube, das gehört zu dieser Saison 16, 17 unbedingt mit dazu.
Es beginnt auf jeden Fall eine Phase, wo Bayern zum ersten Mal jetzt nach Jahren eigentlich anfängt, so ein bisschen was anzubieten. Ich finde, es greift immer ein bisschen zu kurz, wenn man nur auf die Abschlusstabelle guckt und sich dann anguckt irgendwie, ja, wieder über 80 Punkte usw. und da kommt man ja nicht hin. Das spiegelt nicht unbedingt so die Spielweise in der Saison 16, 17, 17, 18, 18, 19 und auch dann Teile 19, 20. Da beginnt eine andere Phase auch für den FC Bayern, der jetzt aus meiner Sicht nicht mehr so dominant, überragend, konstant agiert wie in den Jahren zuvor und so langsam ein bisschen anfängt, was anzubieten, was später ja auch darin mündet, dass Bayern zweimal zum Beispiel auch nicht Herbstmeister wird, sondern jemand anders. Da sieht man schon, dass es da Phasen gab, wo man durchaus hätte reinstechen können. Trotzdem ist der Kader auch in dieser Phase einfach trotz der sozusagen spielerischen Negativentwicklung, die unter Ancelotti anfängt, immer noch, nicht immer noch, sondern vielleicht sogar besser besetzt als in vielen Jahren zuvor. Weil auch das gehört ein bisschen zu der Geschichte dazu, dass mit der Ankunft von Michael Reschke in München die Kaderplanung insgesamt etwas durchdachter wird, auch etwas breiter aufgestellt ist. Man geht an der einen oder anderen Stelle, ist man auch mal bereit, einen Konflikt einzugehen und holt eben dann auch mal zwei offensive Außenspieler wie Douglas Costa und Coman dazu und gesellt die zu Robben und Ribéry dazu und schafft dadurch eben auch Möglichkeiten, dem einen oder anderen mal eine Pause zu gönnen. Der Kader auch in diesen Ancelotti-Jahren ist schon sehr, sehr, sehr stark. Und ich glaube, dass das auch die Begründung am Ende dann für den Vorsprung in der Liga ist und jetzt weniger eine spielerische, eine taktische Überlegenheit wie in den Jahren zuvor.
Ja, das ist ganz interessant zu sehen, wer in den Jahren ab 2015 so alles zum FC Bayern wechselt oder hochgezogen, na gut, hochgezogen wird eigentlich kaum jemand aus der eigenen Jugend, der dann jetzt dann in der aktuellen Zeit eine große Rolle spielt. Also Joshua Kimmich kommt zur Saison 2015, 2016. Mats Humas, Renato Sanczes, okay, da mach ich jetzt mal kurz eine Klammer über die Saison 2016, 2017, aber dann zur Saison 2017, 2018. Kommt eben Sajnabri über Werder von Arsenal. Niklas Süle kommt aus Hoffenheim, Kingsley Coman, Coretin Tolisso. Gut, letztes Mal, weiß man jetzt noch nicht genau, welche Rolle er spielen wird, aber die anderen genannten, da hört man schon, was quasi die Dimension ist der Spieler. Sajnabri wurde ja dann direkt nochmal weiter verliehen nach Hoffenheim, was auch, glaube ich, in der Retrospective ein ähnlich guter Move war, wie damals Alaba nach Hoffenheim auszuleihen oder Philipp Lahm damals zum VfB Stuttgart, denn Sajnabri hat da eine tolle Saison gespielt.
Eine Einschränkung noch, Coman war schon zwei Jahre vorher da, der wird dann da nur fest verpflichtet. Aber das ist die Weichenstellung.
Ja, die ganze Zeit habe ich mir gedacht, ich dachte, irgendwie, der kommt früher. Ja, vielen Dank. Ja, das hätte ich jetzt grad latt falsch hier von transfermarkt.de abgelesen. Genau, der Transfer wurde da erst klar gemacht. Genau, er kam nämlich mit Koster, so wie du es gesagt hast, Steffen. Genau, aber das ist, das ist schon, glaube ich, ein wichtiger Punkt, dass da quasi viel von dem, was man jetzt dann heute beim FC Bayern sieht, in der Stammelf und die jetzt dann auch das zweite Trippel geholt hat, unter welchen Umständen auch immer, diese Spieler landen jetzt so langsam peu à peu beim FC Bayern. Während es halt zum Beispiel bei Borussia Dortmund so ist, dass man in der folgenden Saison, nämlich 2017, 2018, wieder wichtige Abgänge hat. Also die Vorsaison, McItalyan, Hummels, Gündogan, jetzt Ousmane Dembélé für den Fabelpreis. Wir erinnern uns, das ist das Neymar PSG Jahr, wo eben die im Top-Segment die Preise explodieren. Und Aubameyang wechselt im Winter zu Arsenal. Das sind einfach ganz große Abgänge. Man versucht, die aufzufangen mit Jamolenko, Manuel Canci, der kommt auch im Winter, Maximilian Philipp, Ömer Toprak, Moderhut und, interessant, Jadon Sancho kommt in dieser Saison. Und wir erinnern uns alle an Mishy Batshuayi, der dann als Aubameyang-Ersatz im Winter kam. Also Dortmund hat quasi andere Voraussetzungen. Bayern baut immer auf seinem Fundament auf und sorgt sich eher darum, eine Tiefe im Kader zur Position 1 zu schaffen. Also da sind selten Transfers mit dabei, wo man sagt, die müssen jetzt sofort in die Stammelf. Also die Transfers würden das von sich immer sagen, aber bis auf Hummels ist da jetzt keiner dabei, wo ich sagen würde, okay, der muss sofort spielen. Aber man kann eben eine Tiefe schaffen und eben auch auf jüngere Spieler setzen, wie eben Süle, wie eben Coman und die eben gerade schon genannten. Und Dortmund setzt zwar auch auf junge Spieler, aber unter ganz anderen Vorzeichen. Dortmund muss die ganze Zeit Spiele ersetzen und sieht sich dann gleichzeitig auch angegriffen von Leipzig.
Der BVB, der wird auf dem Transfermarkt immer so ein bisschen fremdbestimmt bleiben. Und Bayern ist auf dem Transfermarkt halt kolossal selbstbestimmt. Also Bayern legt selber fest, ist das jetzt ein Geld-Ausgeben-Jahr oder ist es jetzt nur ein, lass uns mal ein, zwei Positionen ergänzen und dann schauen wir mal, ja. Und wenn man sich wirklich die Transfers über die Laufe der Jahre anschaut, passiert immer genau das, eigentlich fast im stringenten Wechsel. Also vor der Anxolotti-Saison holen sie Hummels und Sanches, um einfach mal zu sehen, reicht das als Ergänzungen zu diesem unter Pep Guardiola eigentlich schon ausgeformten Kader und kommen wir damit hin oder nicht. Sie merken dann, hm, reicht nicht und meine Mannschaft wird auch immer älter irgendwie und jetzt müssen wir mal langsam was machen. Und dann kommt zu Saison 2017, 2018 wieder so ein Geldausgeben-Jahr, wo sie dann Tolisso holen, wo sie in Coman fest investieren, wo sie Süle holen und wo sie auch Gnabry schon verpflichten und James Rodriguez von Real Madrid aus leihen, der sündhaft teuer ist, schon allein als Leihspieler und für das, was sie für ihn an Gehalt bezahlen. Und der auch eine Investition ist, nur für zwei Jahre. Und das ist schon einfach ein Unterschied, wie Tag und Nacht, dass Bayern einfach auf dem Transfermarkt frei agieren kann und Dortmund eben immer so ein bisschen zum Handeln gezwungen ist. Also Dortmund muss immer was Schlaues machen, sonst könnte es nach hinten losgehen. Und Bayern kann eigentlich immer so ein bisschen sich das alles angucken und dann überlegen, oh, wen nehmen wir jetzt eigentlich? Wen holen wir jetzt? Was kostet der? Okay, mach mal. Und hat dann immer noch den Vorteil, dass sie eigentlich auf dem nationalen Markt quasi jeden Spieler an besprechen können und 99 Prozent, nicht 99, aber 90 Prozent der Spieler sagen würden, okay, ich setze mich dann mal in die Schubkarre und fahre selber zu euch nach München. Wenn du anrufst, als Karl als Rummenigge einen Spieler im Rohr hast, dann sind die im großen Wahrscheinlichkeitsbereich erstmal Feuer und Flamme und sagen, okay, das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen.
Gleichzeitig ist die Saison 2016, 2017 auch die mit dem Anschlag auf den Bus des BVBs und den Verwerfungen, zu denen das dann führen wird. Also man spielt ja dann das Heimspiel gegen Monaco am Tag darauf. Aber Unstimmigkeiten, die es offenbar zwischen Thomas Tuchel und Aki Watzke und anderen Verantwortlichen auch zum Teil vielleicht Spielern gegeben hat, die scheinen mir so ein bisschen zu kulminieren dann an der Frage, wie das gehandhabt wurde, wie uneinig man sich auch über die Art und Weise ist, dass da dann direkt gespielt wurde. Und dieses fürchterliche Sonderereignis gehört auch zur BVB-Saison in diesem Jahr dazu. Auch wenn die Ergebnisse danach alle noch passen. Also auswärts in Monaco verliert man das Spiel, aber ansonsten bleibt man ungeschlagen. Gewinnt ja auch das DFB-Pokalfinale gegen Eintracht Frankfurt. Aber da passiert eben bei dem bisher wichtigsten Rivalen noch mehr als nur Spielertransfers in dieser Saison.
Das wollte ich damit noch sagen. Vor allem auch langfristig. Dieser Effekt dieses Anschlags, der wird ganz oft, finde ich, viel zu klein geredet oder auch viel zu sehr in den Hintergrund gedrängt. Dann auch im Kontext der folgenden Ergebnisse so, ja, passt ja eigentlich alles. Und das war es eben nicht. Dortmunder, auch Watzke, hat jetzt im Nachhinein gesagt, dieses Thema hat uns mit Sicherheit anderthalb Jahre mal grundlegend beschäftigt. Und Auswirkungen davon sind bis heute zu spüren. Auf jeden Einzelnen, der Teil dieser lebensbedrohenden und wirklich schrecklichen Erfahrungen war. In diesem Kontext muss man die Leistungen der Dortmunder dann auch wirklich einschätzen und eigentlich auch noch mal herausstellen, wie stark das war, was der BVB in den folgenden Jahren geleistet hat. Und wie stark es auch ist, wie sie sich jetzt in diesen Transferzwängen stellen und halt auch umgestellt haben und entdeckt haben. Wenn wir es schaffen, jemanden zu kriegen, der jung ist und talentiert ist und der uns vielleicht 10, 20 Millionen kostet. Und wenn wir es schaffen, den gut auszubilden und den dann ein Jahr später oder zwei Jahre oder drei Jahre später für über 100 Millionen zu verkaufen, dann haben wir schon bei einem singulären Spieler schon einen riesen Job gemacht. Und sie schaffen es jetzt mutmaßlich, das über mehrere Jahre hinweg einfach mit immer neuen Spielern zu kultivieren. Also angefangen bei Dembele oder angefangen bei Aubameyang eigentlich schon. Es waren jetzt noch keine 100 Millionen, aber große Ablöse auch. Aubameyang, Dembele und jetzt ist es ja erwartbar. Ja, das ist mit Sancho und mit Haaland in genau dieselbe Holland, wie mir ein norwegophiler Kollege gesagt hat, sein ENO als NA in dieselbe Richtung geht. Aber das sind einfach so grundlegend andere Voraussetzungen als beim FC Bayern. Einfach auch allein das ein großes Indienst dafür, warum der FC Bayern jetzt die Meisterschale einfach auf Abo gelegt hat.
Es sind andere Voraussetzungen, klar. Es ist aber natürlich schon so, dass Dortmund jetzt auch kein Ausbildungsverein ist. Das klang jetzt gerade so ein bisschen so. Es ist ja schon auch so, dass Dortmund Jahr für Jahr momentan 100 Millionen Euro für neue Spieler ausgibt. Natürlich vom Saldo her nicht, weil sie natürlich auch viel einnehmen. Aber da sind schon richtig starke Möglichkeiten da, um Julian Brandt zu holen, Toggen Hazard zu holen, Mats Hummels zurückzuholen, Haaland zu holen, der irgendwie auch von halb Europa gejagt wird. Dortmund spielt da schon auch noch mal ein paar Ligen nach wie vor über den meisten anderen Bundesligisten sowieso, aber inzwischen auch eben auch finanziell echt auf einem sehr hohen Niveau mit. Dass sie immer wieder die Herausforderungen haben, sich irgendwie neu zu erfinden, ist klar. Aber es ist jetzt auch kein Spielgeld, mit dem die da agieren.
Das stimmt. Und definitiv spielt quasi Dortmund als einziger finanziell in einer Liga mit Bayern, wenn man jetzt mal kurz Leipzig rausrechnet, wobei man die wahrscheinlich eigentlich gar nicht mehr rausrechnen darf. Aber es ist schon ein Vauban-Spiel, was da Borussia Dortmund betreibt. Wenn man sich anguckt, also diese riesigen Umsatzerlöse, die man hatte, also gerade zur Saison 2017, 2018 hin, mit eben den Abgängen von Dembele und Aubameyang, die schlagen sich ja bei den Umsatzerlösen dann sehr deutlich aus. Also da macht Dortmund einen Sprung. Man startet 2015 mit 276 Millionen Euro Umsatzerlösen und drei Jahre später, 2018, hat man 536 Millionen Euro Umsatzerlöse. Also das hat sich fast verdoppelt. Da kommt auch noch ein neuer TV-Vertrag mit rein, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Aber das Interessante ist, wenn man zum Beispiel dann die Gesamtverbindlichkeiten sich anguckt bei Dortmund, dann sind die auch gestiegen. Die haben sich nicht verdoppelt, aber immerhin fast. Von 100 Millionen Euro im Jahr 2015 auf 142 Millionen Euro im Jahr 2018. Das heißt, das Geld, was Borussia Dortmund einnimmt, das wandert direkt wieder weiter. Das ist ein erhitzter Kreislauf. Da bildet sich kein Kapitalstock auf, also im Kleinen schon, wenn man sich das Eigenkapital anguckt, aber nicht nennenswert dahingehend, dass das ein Fundament wäre und dass das quasi auch aufgefangen werden könnte, wenn man mal in einer Transferperiode es nicht schafft, Jadon Sancho zu holen. Oder Christian Pulisic, der dann ja auch eine sehr wichtige Rolle spielt, auch transfertechnisch für Borussia Dortmund. Und man geht eben dann später deutlich ins Risiko mit eben dann, also jetzt machen wir schon einen großen Sprung, aber eben mit Julian Brandt, Torgann, Hassan, Nico Schulz und Mats Hummels. Und dieses Risiko zahlt sich aber auf der Erlösseite, wenn man ehrlich ist, nicht aus. Also mehr wird Borussia Dortmund nicht erlösen als im Geschäftsjahr 2018. Danach wird das wieder runtergehen. Und Borussia Dortmund ist ja auch von Corona sehr deutlich getroffen worden, werden wir beim FC Bayern auch sehen. Aber beim FC Bayern, wenn man da Verluste machen sollte, ist jetzt nicht mal klar, aber da gibt es ja auch noch mögliche Transferabgänge und hohe TV-Gelder aus der Champions League und so weiter und so fort. Dann werden die halt vom Eigenkapital was wegknabbern. Bei Borussia Dortmund kommt man da schneller in Cashflow-Zwänge, glaube ich, von außen betrachtet nach dem, was ich bei den Zahlen sehe.
Das glaube ich nämlich auch. Also in der Krise geht in erster Linie immer dann noch mal die Schere zwischen Arm und Reich noch mal weiter auseinander. Weil die Krise betrifft alle, aber die Starken haben andere Voraussetzungen als die Schwachen. Und deswegen denke ich, dass Bayern auch im Bundesligakontext jetzt nicht der Verlierer der Corona-Krise sein wird. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Und wenn man noch mal auf die Transfer-Ausgaben schaut, es gibt da auch bei Transfermarkt eben eine super Tabelle, die Einnahmen und Ausgaben einfach aufzeigt, auch in länger Frist, in längerjährigem Kontext. Wenn man mal den Zeitraum von 2009, 2010, womit wir jetzt ja auch diese Sendung angefangen haben, bis heute nimmt, hat Bayern, was denkt ihr, wie viel ausgegeben für Transfers? Also Ausgaben, wirklich nur im Ausgabenbereich, wirklich für Transfers.
800 Millionen oder irgendwie so, oder?
Exakt, 806 Millionen und Dortmund ist nicht weit weg mit 713 Millionen. Also das ist das, was Steffen gesagt hat, Dortmund bezahlt nicht mit Papiergeld. Aber, und jetzt sind wir eben beim Saldo, der Saldo beim FC Bayern oder das Saldo, ist der Saldo oder das Saldo? Der Saldo, weiß ich.
Genau, der ist ohnehin der Saldo, ja, der Saldo bei Bayern.
Der Saldo bei Bayern ist minus 427 Millionen und bei Dortmund ist es plus 65 Millionen. Das heißt, da sieht man, der FC Bayern hat da eine halbe Milliarde Euro sozusagen, nicht versenkt, aber halt mehr investieren können, als das jetzt Dortmund irgendwie am Ende des Tages der Mannschaft dazu kommen lassen. Und das ist, glaube ich, der große Unterschied.
Genau, weil man eben auch aus anderen Bereichen, nicht nur TV-Geld, Champions League ist da wichtig, sondern zum Beispiel auch Merchandising einfach Jahr für Jahr zuführen kann. Genau, zuführen kann. Und da ist die Lücke nicht unerheblich. Dortmund ist da ja schon auf Rang 2 in der Liga. Und beide wachsen da jetzt auch nicht mehr so wirklich. Aber die Lücke war zum Beispiel in den Jahren 2014, 2015, 2016 ab. Dann war die Lücke zwischen Bayern und Dortmund einfach nur, was die Einnahmen durch Merchandising angeht, größer als 100 Millionen Euro. Im Jahr 2016 sogar 191 Millionen Euro. Hat der FC Bayern einfach mehr eingenommen als Borussia Dortmund in einem Bereich, der jetzt per se gar nichts mit dem Spiel auf dem Feld zu tun hat. Stimmt natürlich so nicht ganz, aber ihr wisst ja, was ich damit sagen möchte. Einfach nur mit einer Sache, die nebenher läuft zum eigentlichen Kerngeschäft. Wir spielen Fußball und wollen Titel erringen. Holt Bayern in der Saison 2016, die Zahl habe ich jetzt von Swiss Ramble, sehr gutes Block, was wirtschaftliche Kennzahlen angeht, im Fußball fast 200 Millionen Euro mehr eingenommen. Und die kann man dann eben einfach investieren. Und dann eben diese halbe Milliarde, das ist ja nicht so, dass der FC Bayern deswegen Verbindlichkeiten aufgebaut hätte in dieser Höhe. Darauf ist man ja zu Recht vielleicht auch stolz. Aber das zeigt eben, wie ungleich sogar zwischen der potenziellen Nummer eins oder der eigentlich normalen Nummer eins und dem Herausforderer, dem einen von vielleicht zwei Herausforderern, wie groß da schon die Schere auseinandergeht.
Es kommt ein Aspekt aus meiner Sicht hinzu. Sicherlich ist es noch mal weiter auseinandergegangen. Aber in Wahrheit ist es ja so, dass auch schon Ende der 90er und Anfang der 2000er war es auch schon so, dass der FC Bayern viel größere Möglichkeiten hatte, als alle anderen und immer schon einen breiteren Kader hatte. Und immer schon der Verein war, der irgendwie sechs Nationalspieler auf der Bank hatte und so weiter. Erinnere ich mich jetzt noch irgendwie wie im Olympiastadion, da irgendwie Mario Basler, Thomas Strunz und sonst wer unter der Decke saßen und dann bei Sat.1 range sagt wurde, schauen Sie mal, wer noch alles draußen sitzt. Der entscheidende Unterschied aber aus meiner Sicht, außer dass sich das Niveau noch mal weiterentwickelt hat, ist aber, dass früher das Agreement sozusagen war, ja Bayern hat einen breiteren Kader, aber es ist gleichzeitig auch so ziemlich die einzige Mannschaft in Deutschland, die bis weit ins Frühjahr hinein irgendwie auf drei Hochzeiten unterwegs ist. Und so hat es ja dann auch irgendwie Sinn gemacht, weil am Ende spielen ja nur elf, also die bringen ja sozusagen 18 Spieler im Moment nicht, sondern nur auf lange Sicht auf eine Saison betrachtet. Inzwischen ist es ja aber so, dass selbst der letzte Europa League-Teilnehmer von uns eine ähnliche Belastung hat wie der FC Bayern, weil die sich dadurch irgendwelche katastrophalen Qualifikationsturniere spielen müssen, eine Gruppenphase spielen müssen, sogar noch eine beschissenere Terminlage haben, weil sie am Donnerstagabend irgendwo in Bulgarien oder in Rumänien spielen und dann am Wochenende spielen. Und mit dieser Entwicklung hat das aus meiner Sicht nicht Schritt gehalten. Wir sehen ja auch jedes Mal, wenn so eine Mannschaft überraschend in die Europa League kommt, wie viele Probleme sie im Nachhinein dann in der Bundesliga hat. Weil das ist einfach ein ganz anderer Schnack, ob du in der Lage bist, dich eine Woche lang auf den Gegner vorzubereiten oder ob du zweieinhalb Tage Zeit hast. Und wenn du dann eben nicht die Möglichkeiten hast, so wie Bayern, einen breiten Kader mitzubringen, der irgendwie auf hohem Niveau auch Rotationen ermöglicht, etc., dann schlägt sich das, glaube ich, umso mehr nieder. Und das ist mir bisher so in der Diskussion zu sehr untergegangen. Also die Belastung für alle Vereine hat zugenommen, ohne dass dadurch sozusagen der finanzielle Gap kleiner geworden ist und dann erst sogar noch eher größer geworden. Und wenn wir vorhin gesagt haben, die letzten Meisterschaften von Dortmund sind aus meiner Sicht nicht ohne Zufall in Jahre gefallen, wo sie zumindest in der Rückrunde keinerlei Doppelbelastung mehr hatten.
Und im Grunde sind wir ja da schon bei dem Segment. Also wir können jetzt auch noch drüber reden, was dann nach Angelotti kam. Jupp Heynckes kam nochmal kurz zurück und Jupp Heynckes hat halt gemacht, was halt Jupp Heynckes dann immer macht, also zuletzt immer gemacht hat bei den Bayern. Er hatte dann Erfolg. Niko Kovac kam dann. Und jetzt bewegen wir uns ja dann schon so sehr Richtung jüngere Vergangenheit, dass das auch jeder Hörerin und jedem Hörer vor Augen sein wird, was dann passiert ist. Vor allem, weil wir dann auch bis zu einem zweiten Trippel kommen, was ja früher wie so ein ganz ferner Wunsch stand. Der FC Bayern ist ihm so lange hinterher gerannt. Jeder Trainer wurde ständig nach einem Trippel gefragt, obwohl dafür alles zusammenkommen muss. Okay, und in dieser Saison ist jetzt alles zusammengekommen. Das können wir ja auch gleich im Detail reingehen.
Das war ja nicht nur das Trippel. Also überhaupt einen Champions-League-Sieg oder an eine Champions-League-Titel zu denken, das war ja vor 2001 schon nur allerhöchster Anstrengungen. Und wenn es sich einigermaßen ausgeht, zu denken daran, im internationalen Kontext der finanziellen Kräftenverhältnisse, dann in den 2000er-Jahren war das ja sozusagen undenkbar, weil man dachte, die anderen Ligen, gerade die Spanier und die Engländer, haben die Deutschen einfach auf Jahre hinaus. Und ich weiß noch, wie ich zu meiner damaligen Freundin, heutigen Frau 2010 gesagt habe, ich würde da ganz gerne nach Madrid zu diesem Spiel fahren, zu diesem Champions-League-Finale, mit dem wir ja auch eingangs angefangen haben, weil das passiert nicht so häufig. Das passiert vielleicht alle zehn Jahre mal, dass da ein deutscher Club, also der FC Bayern, im Champions-League-Finale ist. Und vier Jahre später hat sie mich so ein bisschen, oder drei Jahre später so ein bisschen doof angeguckt und hat gesagt, ja genau, und jetzt waren es dreimal in vier Jahren. Aber also an die prinzipiellen Verhältnissen, was die Premier League einnimmt und was Barcelona und Real Madrid einnimmt, hat sich ja eigentlich nicht verändert, aber dass Bayern dann zweimal in sieben Jahren das Trippel gewinnt. Und irgendwie in einem Zyklus von zehn Jahren, achtmal im Halbfinale steht der Champions League viermal im Finale und das Ding zweimal gewinnt. Wenn man das jemandem 2009 gesagt hätte, ich glaube, der hätte einen für ziemlich bescheuert erklärt, glaube ich.
Das spricht aber auch noch im November 2019 sagen können. Da hätte ich dich schon verrückt erklärt, aber gut.
Aber das ist ja die interessante Frage. Wenn du eben sagst, international haben die Bayern sich etabliert und sie sind auch nicht die kleine Nummer international, auch finanziell, wie sie immer tun. Da sind sie immer in den Top 5 in der Deloitte Football Money League. Ja, Manchester City, PSG, die haben Scheichtümer, Staaten, die dahinter stehen. Das hatte man früher auch. Die Zeit, die du angesprochen hast, 2001 bis 2010, da war ja unter anderem Roman Abramovic so ein bisschen der Anti-Held zum FC Bayern, bei der er da Hunderte Millionen investiert hat und der FC Bayern da auf der Schiene war zumindest öffentlich, bis man dann eben in der Saison mit Toni Klose und Ribery umgeschwenkt ist. Da war man ja noch auf dem Nervier, wir versuchen das nachhaltig zu machen und wir versuchen das anders zu erledigen. Das ist ja jetzt eingetreten. Also der FC Bayern spielt, egal wie viel Glück, Pech, jetzt dann bei den einzelnen Finalspielen und so weiter mit dabei waren, aber der FC Bayern spielt permanent in der europäischen Spitzenklasse mit, obwohl ja die finanziellen Mittel bei den anderen immer noch größer sind. Also Bayern wird keine 222 Millionen Euro für einen Nehmer ausgeben und muss das auch nicht. Und die Frage, die sich mir so ein bisschen stellt, ist, woher kommt dieser Erfolg? Kann man den erklären, ohne zu sagen, der FC Bayern nutzt dafür seine nationale Dominanz radikal aus, weil die besten deutschen Spieler sich beim FC Bayern vereinen und weil man es geschafft hat, so ein gewisses Marktsegment an Spielern für sich zu reklamieren. Und das sind vor allem Spieler, die in Deutschland einen sehr großen Sprung machen. Bevor sie ins Ausland wechseln gehen, entweder ins Ausland oder zum FC Bayern.
Ich glaube aber schon, dass es auch einen großen Aspekt ist, ist einfach diese Erfolgssicherung. Und da hat Rummenigge natürlich lange Jahre als Vorsitzender der ECA auch gute Lobbyarbeit geleistet, sprich vier feste Startplätze in der Champions League. Also Bayern hat sich ja quasi, das Achtelfinale der Champions League ist ja per se eigentlich gebucht für Bayern allein durch den Umstand, dass sie auf jeden Fall 1. 2. oder 4. der Bundesliga werden und damit an der Champions League teilnehmen dürfen. Und dadurch, dass sie durch die bisher errungenen Erfolge ja auch in der Club-Weltrangliste so weit vorne sind oder in den UEFA-Koeffizienten, dass sie auf jeden Fall in Losthof 2 landen werden. Die UEFA hat zwar umgestellt und setzt jetzt nur noch die Landesmeister als Gruppenköpfe, was ich gut finde, weil das so ein bisschen für Ausgleich sorgt. Aber es muss schon mit dem Teufel zugehen, dass Bayern in einer Champions League-Gruppe landet, wo zwei starke Gegner sind. Und damit hast du denen, natürlich ist ja nicht garantiert, aber schon eine relativ sichere, gute Aussicht, in der K.o.-Runde der Champions League zu landen. Und ab da ist es Tagesform. Und ab da hat Bayern natürlich durch den Kader und so immer das Format dazu bestehen. Bayern hat ja auch letztes Jahr gegen Liverpool, in Liverpool, nicht so schlecht ausgesehen. Aber Bayern ist dann halt im Achtelfinal in Liverpool gescheitert. Ja, also ich kann mich erinnern, dieses 0-0 hatte schon einen gewissen Appeal auf Fans und auch auf Medien, die gesagt haben, so hätte Bayern auch gewinnen können.
Ja, weil man halt dachte, dass Liverpool...
In der ersten Halbzeit...
Ja, Erwartungshaltung. Also da dachte man halt, Liverpool rollt drüber über die Bayern. Und erstaunlicherweise ging das im Hinspielen noch nicht. Und das hat dann schon gereicht zu Begeisterungsstürmen.
Ich glaube, am Ende ist es jetzt so, durch diese Corona-Krise und die damit verbundenen Verbindlichkeiten, die gewisse Vereine aufbauen, ich glaube, die europäische Spitze wird breiter. Das hat man eben auch jetzt gemerkt durch Phänomene wie Leipzig und Lyon, die bis ins Halbfinale vorgedrungen sind. Und ich glaube, dieser Trippeltitel der Bayern ist jetzt nicht der Anfang einer Bayern beherrscht Europa. Aber ein gutes Enddienst dafür, dass wir vielleicht in den nächsten Jahren fünf, sechs, sieben, acht Mannschaften jedes Jahr haben könnten, die die Champions League gewinnen können, was wiederum für den Wettbewerb bestimmt nicht schlecht ist.
Aber dafür sind die nationalen Wettbewerbe alle kaputt. Also ja, es kann sein, dass die Champions League spannender wird, auch ab der K.o.-Phase, wenn man ehrlich ist. Dafür sind die Ligen mit Ausnahme der Premier League alle langweiliger geworden.
Ja, aber das ist ja letztlich dann auch immer diese... Wenn du das einfach nur wirtschaftlich anschaust und sagst, Geld schießt Tore, wenn du einfach mal von dieser Prämisse ausgehst, und natürlich ist es nicht in jedem Spiel so, nicht in jeder Saison so, aber Geld schießt Tore, weil du kaufst dir damit die besten Spieler.
Punkt.
Und dadurch ist diese Champions League in Verbindung mit den nationalen Ligen natürlich ein die nationalen Ligen total abschneidender Wettbewerb, weil da halt immer dieselben landen jetzt, gerade in den vier großen Ligen, und die dann dort halt das große Geld rausziehen. Geld, das sie dann dafür einsetzen, um die nationale Konkurrenz immer mehr zu beherrschen. Und wenn du dann im nationalen Kontext keinen Ausgleich schaffst und es nicht schaffst, einen Wettbewerb zu veranstalten, der zumindest eine relativ gleiche Voraussetzung, finanzielle Voraussetzung bietet, wie jetzt zum Beispiel die Premier League, wobei ich das auch in Klammern setze, aber da kommt halt Leeds und steigt auf und kriegt halt dann mutmaßlich 100 Millionen. Es ist ja immer das 100-Millionen-Pfund-Spiel, dieses K.o.-Spiel um den Aufstieg in die Premier League. Aber sagt es mal Paderborn oder sagt es mal VfB Stuttgart, wenn die sich mit Leeds vergleichen müssen. Also das ist ja ein Witz. Das ist halt so ein bisschen das große Minus dieser Champions League. Die langfristigen finanziellen Auswirkungen im nationalen Kontext, im Kontext der nationalen Wettbewerbe.
Jedes Mal, wenn jemand sagt, Geld schießt Tore, weint irgendwo ein Manchester United-Fan.
Oder Otto Rehagel, weil er es ja damals genau umgedreht gemeint hat. Er meinte ja, ich glaube, es ging um Rudi Völler, der hatte ein Angebot zu wechseln. Und Otto Rehagel meinte damals, naja, ich kann mir natürlich jetzt Geld holen für Rudi Völler, aber das Geld wird mir ja keine Tore schießen. Also er meinte es eigentlich genau andersrum, als man es immer verwendet.
Ja, bei mir ist es auch ein bisschen zu viel Mathematik jetzt. Fußball ist keine Mathematik, endlich. Es ist ja völlig klar, dass Bayern da ein Wahnsinnsfundament hat und so weiter. Das ist alles gut, aber am Ende hängt es trotzdem daran, ob man irgendwie kluge Entscheidungen trifft oder nicht. Und ich finde, wenn man sich die letzten 3, 4 Jahre des FC Bayern anschaut, dann beweist das das ja auch. Also es hat sich ja jetzt finanziell in dieser Saison jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel verändert im Vergleich zu den Vorjahren. Und unter Ancelotti und unter Kovac, da fehlte eine klare Spielphilosophie. Es fehlten auch klare Strukturen im Verein. Ich meine, da haben wir jetzt alles gar nicht angesprochen. Als Sammer dann ging jahrelang diese Position nicht vernünftig besetzt gewesen. Brazzo auch in seiner Anfangszeit wirklich eine schwierige Rolle gehabt, Transfers in Sand gesetzt und so weiter. Und das sieht man dann eben schon auch im Resultat. Wir haben es ja sogar gesehen, bis zum November 2019, wo es Kovacay bis zum Ende nicht geschafft hat, sich jetzt mal für eine Variante zu entscheiden, weil dieses Spiel in Liverpool so gut lief, lag unter anderem daran, dass er zum ersten Mal als Bayern-Trainer mal den Fußball hat spielen lassen, für den er bekannt geworden ist. Nämlich ein relativ defensives, kompaktes Spiel. Und er hat monatelang oder die anderthalb Jahre nicht geschafft, diese Balance zu finden zwischen dem Fußball, den er kann und den er auch gelehrt hat und diesem Selbstverständnis von Bayern und dieser Zeit davor. Was ich damit nur sagen will, ist, es ist am Ende ja nicht... Ich finde, man kann nicht nur jetzt Finanzzahlen nebeneinander legen und dann sagen, deshalb hat das funktioniert und deshalb hat das nicht funktioniert, sondern es geht ja irgendwie immer auch darum, was macht man da raus? Und was Flick jetzt zum Beispiel gelungen ist, nachdem er das übernommen hat, diese Mannschaft zu formen, einen Spielstil zu entwickeln, der zur Mannschaft passt, diese Gier in der Mannschaft wieder zu wecken, dass man, obwohl man schon alles einmal gewonnen hat, oder viele aus der Mannschaft eben auch dieses Trippel schon gewonnen haben, trotzdem nochmal mit dieser Intensität in dieses Champions-League-Turnier reinzugehen, das sind einfach wahnsinnig viele Stellschrauben, die am Ende darüber entscheiden, ob du sehr erfolgreich bist oder ob du erfolgreich bist. Meinetwegen ist das sozusagen die Basis beim FC Bayern. Aber deswegen sollte man, finde ich, nicht unterschätzen, was da eigentlich auch alles zusammenspielt und was am Ende zwischen, was den Unterschied ausmacht zwischen Erfolg und Misserfolg. Und gerade jetzt in dieser Saison, wenn sich die Bayern auch nicht so früh von Kovac getrennt hätten, glaube ich schon, dass wir zum ersten Mal einen deutschen Meister gesehen hätten seit Jahren, der nicht FC Bayern heißt.
Ja, also das ist ja klar, dass auch sportliches, also dein sportliches Handeln kann nicht komplett Banane sein, dann wirst du keinen Erfolg haben, selbst wenn du der Reichste bist. Aber auf der anderen Seite wird man halt auch für Fehler weniger anfällig. Und auch für Unwägbarkeiten, die es in einem Geschäft wie Fußball oder wie Leistungssport einfach gibt. Also eben der berühmte Lucas Hernandez, der für eine Wahnsinnssumme kommt, bei dem man es sich aber leisten kann, dass er gar nicht spielen muss. Oder eben man könnte auch Niko Kovac, das ist ihm jetzt ein bisschen zu hart formuliert, aber ihn könnte man ja auch als Fehler bezeichnen. Also natürlich nicht den Mensch. Aber insgesamt hat da viel einfach nicht zusammengegriffen zwischen ihm und der Mannschaft. Und trotzdem kommt er eher auch als Dubelsieger 2018, 2019 aus der Saison raus. Natürlich ist das nicht losgelöst von finanziellen Entscheidungen, aber das liegt eben auch an der Qualität in der Mannschaft. Und die wurde ja dann finanziert über eine finanzielle Dominanz. Und da hat sich, weil du vorhin gesagt hast, ein Punkt noch, dann darfst du gerne reingerätschen, weil du vorhin gesagt hast, finanziell hat sich da nicht mehr viel getan bei Bayern. Das stimmt nicht ganz. Von der Saison 2017, 2018 hin zur Saison 2018, 2019 hat man seinen Gesamtumsatz nochmal um 93 Millionen Euro gesteigert. Von 650 auf 750 Millionen Euro. Ohne sich jetzt an der Zahl aufzuhängen, da gibt es nochmal Sondereffekte, die da mit reinspielen und mit rausspielen. Aber insgesamt hat einfach der FC Bayern in diesem 10-Jahres-Zeitraum 2009, 2010 bis 2018, 2019 seinen Gesamtumsatz verdoppelt, und zwar mehr als verdoppelt, um 400 Millionen Euro. Und klar ist das langweilig, auch immer mit diesem Geldargument zu kommen. Und das stimmt auch nicht immer, weil da schießt natürlich Geld wirklich keine Tore. Du kannst nicht sagen, du hast einen großen Umsatz, und deswegen gewinnst du die Meisterschaft. Aber du wirst eben viel, viel weniger anfällig für Fehler, weil die Grundqualität dir einfach stimmt.
Na klar, aber trotzdem gewinnt am Ende der FC Bayern Champions-League-Sieger mit einer Basis von Spielern, die seit Jahren in dem Verein sind, die teilweise Alaba, Müller selbst ausgebildet sind, die wie Joshua Kimmich aus der 2. Liga verpflichtet wurden, wie ein Alfonso Davis, der irgendwo in Kanada gefunden wurde, wie Serge Napri, den sicherlich auch der eine oder andere Bundesliga-Verein hätte bei Arsenal loseisen können. Es war jetzt nicht so, dass Napri zu dieser Zeit schon ein Weltstar war. Oder auch einen Kingsley Coman von der Bank bei Juventus zu verpflichten. Ich will ja nur sagen, ich blende die finanziellen Rahmenbedingungen überhaupt nicht aus, aber es ist aus meiner Sicht ein Aspekt von mehreren, meinetwegen ein starker Aspekt, aber dazu gehört eben genauso kluge Personalentscheidungen, kluge Transferentscheidungen, eine kluge Trainerwahl, eine starke Taktik. All das gehört für mich zusammen. Und ich finde diese Tendenz, so Leistungen zu entwerten, indem man sagt, ja gut, die hatten halt mehr Geld, das greift mir einfach ein Stück weit zu kurz.
Ich finde, es ist einfach.
Wir sagen nur, die Voraussetzungen sind halt gut.
Ich finde halt, mir fällt es halt schwer, als journalistischer Betrachter des Ganzen, dafür mehr als nur eine punktuelle Begeisterung zu entwickeln. Also, Anerkennung auf jeden Fall. Respekt natürlich. Und das, was jetzt, wenn wir jetzt über die aktuelle Saison vielleicht noch sprechen, das aktuelle Trippel, da gibt es auch wirklich Dinge, für die ich mich auch begeistern kann. Was da in der Mannschaft auch sportlich passiert ist. Das gucke ich mir an und sage, super Geschichte, tolle Geschichte. Das will ich ja vom Sport haben. Letztlich geht es darum, Geschichten zu produzieren. Solche Geschichten schreibt nur der Fußballscherz bald wieder im Shop unter kiosk.rasen.de. Aber wenn ich mir dann eben den größeren Kontext angucke, dann fehlt mir da die Begeisterung, weil es vorhersehbar geworden ist, aufgrund der wirtschaftlichen Disbalance, nicht nur im nationalen Fußball, sondern ja auch im europäischen Fußball. Also eben der Unterschied zwischen Einnahmen in der Champions League und zur Europa League ist viel zu hoch. Und verfestigt quasi das System. Und da fehlt mir dann tatsächlich einfach auch der Reiz. Und was soll denn mit dieser Liga, mit diesem Wettbewerb passieren, so toll die Leistung des FC Bayern natürlich war. Das haben wir jetzt ja auch, finde ich, ganz gut eingeordnet bekommen. Schon über die aktuelle Saison würde ich gerne gleich noch kurz sprechen. So toll diese Leistung war, viermal ins Champions League-Finale zu kommen, neun Meisterschaften zu holen, sechs DFB-Pokalsiege. So schlimm ist das doch gleichzeitig aus einer Sicht aller anderen. Und die kann ich nicht komplett ausblenden, weil ich auch selbst feststelle und auch übrigens beim FC Bayern auch feststelle, als ob denen die achte Meisterschaft, die sie in Werder mit diesem 1 zu 0 gewonnen haben, als ob das jetzt noch irgendwo Jubelstürme ausgelöst hat. Völlig routiniert posten die dann, okay, hier kannst du jetzt den Fan-Merch kaufen und so weiter. Hey, wir haben uns irgendwas mit einer 8 ausgedacht. Ja, aber das ist doch nicht gut. Also das ist doch dann eigentlich, also ich sag's jetzt ein bisschen überspitzt, aber das ist doch kein Sport mehr, wenn immer derselbe gewinnt.
Ja, zumindest nicht, wenn immer derselbe die besseren Voraussetzungen hat. Also es ist halt, ich glaube, die Bundesliga, und muss sich sehr genau überlegen, wie sie künftig mit den finanziellen Hebeln, die sie selber hat, mit den Mitteln, die sie selber den Verein angedeihen lässt, umgeht. Und einfach dieser Verteidigungsschlüssel, der ist für mich einfach noch mal einer gröberen Überprüfung wert. Solidaritätsprinzip kann man bestimmt in einer wirtschaftlich geprägten Welt nicht immer propagieren, aber man kann es vielleicht trotzdem versuchen, das einfach durchzusetzen. Und warum muss die Grenze, oder warum muss die Schere zwischen Platz 1 und Platz 18 in der Bundesliga, was die Prämien angeht, was die TV-Gelder angeht, so weit auseinandergehen? Warum kann das nicht ein bisschen enger sein? Und warum kann man nicht damit den kleineren Teams ein bisschen mehr abgeben? Die großen Vereine haben ja immer noch ihre eigenen wirtschaftlichen Voraussetzungen und ihre eigenen wirtschaftlichen Quellen, die sie jetzt nicht auf Prämienbasis irgendwie einnehmen oder auf TV-Geldbasis eingeben. Also sie haben immer noch einen großen Wettbewerbsvorteil gegenüber den kleineren. Aber man kann halt zumindest den, der jetzt wirklich die gesamte Liga betrifft, und die Liga hat ja ein Interesse, spannend zu sein, den kann man doch einfach ein bisschen mehr nivellieren und ein bisschen mehr anpassen, um dafür ein bisschen mehr Ausgleich zu sorgen. Und ich glaube, das ist wichtig, weil sonst reden wir in zehn Jahren von 18 Meistertiteln von Bayern in 20 Jahren, und das schaut sich doch dann wirklich keiner mehr an. Oder? Ich weiß es nicht.
Was die Liga angeht, da stimme ich euch ja völlig zu. Also ich halte diese Dominanz von Bayern, wie gesagt, die aus meiner Sicht nicht nur rein finanziell zu begründen ist, aber natürlich auch finanziell zu begründen ist. Das ist eine existenzielle Krise, würde ich es nicht nennen, aber eine existenzielle Frage für die Bundesliga. Definitiv. Das scheint ja auch als angekommen zu sein. Also Seifert macht ja jetzt irgendwie so eine Kommission zur Zukunft des Fußballs. Ich bin gespannt, was da rauskommt. Der hat ja vor kurzem auch mal sowas in Richtung Gehalts- obergrenzen und so weiter gesagt. Wir werden die Diskussion wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht mehr führen können. Das lohnt sich sicherlich in ein anderes Rasenfunk, noch mal mit anderen Gästen auch. Aber die Frage ist ja, was will man? Es schauen gerade alle nach England und alle jubeln und sagen auch hier Leeds aufgestiegen und das ist doch toll. Und Liverpool, der wahre Fußball. Was ist denn der Hintergrund der Renaissance, der Premier League und vor allen Dingen auch der Spannung dort? Das ist doch nicht, dass die Fernsehgelder anders verteilen, sondern es ist doch eine Reihe von Investoren, die in diese Liga gekommen sind und die deshalb dafür sorgen, dass da einfach auch im letzten Drittel der Liga deutlich mehr ausgegeben wird als bei uns in der Mitte. Und die Frage ist ja, ob man das will. Deswegen finde ich halt immer so, die Anklage ist ganz leicht. Die Lösung finde ich wahnsinnig schwer. Weil ich habe auch kein Interesse an chinesischen Investoren oder an sonstigen Investoren in der Liga. Aber es ist für mich schwer zu greifen und jetzt zu sagen, man macht den FC Bayern künstlich schlechter, kann aus meiner Sicht auch nicht die Lösung sein.
Nein, aber künstlich schlechter ist es ja auch nicht. Aber wenn man halt als CFL hergeht und sagt, pass mal auf, wir würden jetzt gerne jedem dasselbe geben, TV-Gelder, dann kommen natürlich die Bayern und die Dortmunder und schreien als erstes, ja, dann gehen wir aber in die Superliga. Machen die am Ende aber nicht. Also, sie würden sich natürlich mit Händen und Füßen dagegen wehren und sagen auch, klar, uns gucken die Leute ja wenigstens. Ich meine, Hoffenheim gegen Paderborn, Freitagabend, sorry, aber das zieht natürlich nicht die TV-Gelder so an, also den Leuten, dass Pay-TV-Geld irgendwie da reingepfliest, sondern das sind natürlich zum Großteil Bayern und Dortmund. Das ist ja auch ganz klar. Und halt noch ein paar andere Traditionsvereine, die noch viel mehr ein Recht hätten zu sagen, bitte mehr TV-Geld für uns, weil uns gucken die Leute ja wenigstens.
Ja, ich meine, das ist halt so eine große...
Aber wenn man das alles nivellieren würde und sagen würde, ihr kriegt jetzt alles dasselbe, dann würden halt ein paar schreien, dann würde es halt drei Wochen echt hoch hergehen und jeder würde ein Interview geben und würde Lobbyismus betreiben, aber dann wird es halt einfach so gemacht und gut. Und natürlich liegt das nicht an den TV-Geldern, wie die Premiere aussieht, absolut valide Punkte, Steffen, aber es würde halt nicht schaden. Es würde nicht schaden. Man muss halt ein Interesse haben, dass die Grenze zwischen Arm und Reich nicht noch weiter auseinandergeht. Das Interesse muss die DFL haben, weil es sonst den Wettbewerb kaputt macht.
Ich meine, es ist ja auch nicht so in der Premier League, dass das jetzt nur das Geld aus den TV-Erträgen wäre, sondern da kommen ja auch sportliche Komponenten mit dazu. Allein die Trainer Jürgen Klopp und Pep Guardiola haben etwas verändert in Liga-weit. Da muss man sich nicht nur die Tabellen angucken, sondern man kann sich auch die Berichterstattung angucken. Die Art und Weise, wie Manchester United früher seine Meisterschaften geholt hat, das war jetzt auch nicht immer mit der Zunge schneizen. Genauso wie es jetzt auch nicht so wäre, dass wenn wir allen Bundesligisten einfach mal 100 Millionen Euro über die Theke rüber schieben, würde es ja auch nicht per se den Wettbewerb besser machen. Das ist ja im Grunde dein Argument von vorn, Steffen. Du kannst quasi die wirtschaftlichen Zahlen nicht mit sportlicher Leistungsfähigkeit und mit sportlicher Kompetenz gleichsetzen. Du kannst aber die Margin of Error eben ein bisschen abfedern für die Vereine. Und wenn du jetzt aber allen Vereinen gleich viel geben würdest, würden sich erstmal einfach nur die Preise verändern und sonst wahrscheinlich sich eher weniger verändern, weil ja auch das Wirtschaftssystem Fußball darauf basiert, dass du das, was du einnimmst, im Grunde gleich wieder ausgibst. Es ist ja nicht nachhaltig angelegt. Egal, was die DFL einem zeigen will und ja, Eigenkapitalquote hochgegangen und so weiter. Haben wir jetzt ja aber in Corona gesehen, wie es da um den Cashflow in den Vereinen bestellt ist. Also dieses Argument möchte ich einfach nicht mehr hören. Aber letztlich kann man doch mal die Frage stellen, und die wird mir nicht diskutiert, und die wird, meiner Meinung nach auch nicht in dieser Kommission Zukunft Profi-Fußball gestellt werden. Denn warum hören wir nichts von dieser Kommission? Warum gibt es sie noch nicht? Warum ist die DFL da schon wieder so langsam? Das hat Gründe. Es wird nicht die große Reform geben. Aber im Grunde müsste man die Frage stellen, wir erkennen jetzt alle an, Fußball ist ein Produkt. Dieses Produkt soll unterhalten. Was am Fußball unterhält? Ist es nur Leistung? Aktuell wird ja sehr nach Leistung auch, Leistung wird in Geld aufgewogen, zu großen Teilen. Oder kommen da auch noch andere Faktoren mit rein? Kommen da noch Faktoren rein? Wie wichtig ist die Attraktivität des Spiels? Wie wichtig ist sie? Nicht nur jetzt in einer philosophischen Frage, sondern lasst uns doch mal diskutieren, wie wichtig ist es denn für die Fans? Also ist es wirklich so wichtig, wie man vielleicht manchmal glauben möchte, ob die Spiele gut oder schlecht sind? Oder ist vielleicht eine andere Komponente, nämlich welche Tradition ein Verein hat? Ohne das, vielleicht hat das, welche Bedeutung hat das? Das kann man doch sehen. Wir wissen doch, wie die Leute das Produkt Fußball konsumieren. Da müssen wir uns ja nicht dümmer stellen als wir sind. Wir haben TV-Quoten, wir haben Merchandising-Einnahmen, wir haben Mitgliederzahlen, wir haben Zahlen an Auswärtsfans. Wir können doch sehen, was da die Effekte sind. Und selbst wenn das dann zum Teil Effekte sind, wo man sagt, das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen ungerecht, weil wie sollen denn dann neue Vereine in die Liga reinkommen? Oder können wir jetzt wirklich Hoffenheim vorwerfen, dass es nicht die Historie hat, wie eben Borussia Mönchengladbach? Diese Diskussion kann man führen. Aber mir fehlt einfach so die grundsätzliche Frage, was ist es denn, was das Produkt Fußball als Unterhaltungsobjekt für eine große Masse an Menschen gut macht? Diese Diskussion wird komischerweise nicht geführt. Da wird auch nicht drüber geredet, welche Rolle spielt Atmosphäre in den Stadien? Welche Rolle spielt die Art, die Qualität auch der Übertragungen? Hört euch mal an, wie das Sounddesign bei einem Premier League Spiel ist und hört euch das Sounddesign aus der Bundesliga an. Da hat sich seit 10 Jahren meiner Meinung nach nichts getan. Bei der Premier League hörst du jeden Ballkontakt im Mittelfeld. Du hörst jedes Aufraunen unterm Dach der Zuschauer beim falsch ausgeführten Einwurf. In der Bundesliga ist das so ein Soundbrei. Und du hörst mal gerade so einen Pfostenschuss unten raus. Ich komme jetzt ein bisschen ins Detail rein. Aber das ist doch eigentlich die Frage. Was soll denn das Produkt Fußball bitte sein, dass sich die Leute auch noch in 20 Jahren für nationalen Fußball interessieren? Wie wollen wir es denn gestalten? Diese Grundsatzfrage, wo man auch mal einfach offen diskutieren muss und vielleicht auch wirklich mal auch Zahlen heranziehen muss, die jetzt eben nicht finanzielle Kennzahlen sind, sind so einfach Popularität, Nutzungsverhalten von Fans. Die Diskussion wird nicht geführt und ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass die in dieser Kommission geführt werden wird. Zumindest nach allem, was ich bisher so höre.
Ja, wollen wir noch mal ein bisschen über Trippel reden?
Ja, reden wir noch mal ein bisschen über das Trippel.
Ich weiß, wenn ich das jetzt sage, das ist immer der Punkt. Das ist immer der Punkt, wo ich dann bei Twitter und so immer ziemlich viel Gegenwind bekomme. Ich möchte es zumindest einmal loswerden. Ich weiß auch vielleicht, ihr könnt mir auch sagen, wenn das Schwachsinn ist, aber mir fehlt alles, was du gesagt hast, Max, und auch Flo, ist alles richtig, ist alles irgendwie eine richtige Problembeschreibung und so weiter. Es fehlt mir aber trotzdem, und das möchte ich schon sagen, dass der FC Bayern in zehn Jahren acht Mal Meister wird. Ich glaube, kann man sagen, ist der Normalfall, wenn man sich die finanziellen Voraussetzungen momentan so anschaut, wie sie sind, dass der FC Bayern in zehn Jahren zehn Mal Meister wird, ist aus meiner Sicht nicht der Normalfall. Weil das, wenn du mal ein Jahr drin hast, wo das nicht läuft, haben wir ja auch gerade schon darüber gesprochen, gab ja genügend Angriffungspunkte. Mir fehlt schon, trotz dieses Ungleichgewichts, mir fehlt in der Liga trotzdem irgendwo eine Mannschaft, die den Anspruch hat zu sagen, wir bauen jetzt ein Team, was in der Lage ist, diesem Verein richtig weh zu tun. Wir haben vorhin angefangen mit der Anfangszeit 2010 bis 2012. Aus meiner Sicht ist das genau das, was Klopp gemacht hat. Er hat es vielleicht nach außen nicht so dargestellt, sondern seine Underdog-Geschichte erzählt. Aber natürlich ist auch der Fußball, den er da entwickelt hat, perfekt gewesen, um Bayern richtig weh zu tun. Jetzt mache ich einen noch gewagteren Cross-Sport-Vergleich. Es läuft gerade die Tour de France. In den letzten Jahren wurde die Tour de France jedes Jahr vom Team Sky gewonnen. Jedes Jahr. Letztes Jahr sogar erster und zweiter Platz. Die Dominatoren überhaupt. Kein anderes Team hat eine Chance und so weiter. Vor drei oder vier Jahren hat ein holländisches Team, das heißt Jumbo Wismar, angefangen, sich daran auszurichten und gesagt, wir bauen jetzt sukzessive über drei, vier Jahre ein Team auf, ein System auf, eine Struktur auf, was in der Lage ist, diese unfassbare Dominanz, die die gleichen zur gleichen Diskussion geführt hat, die wir jetzt in der Bundesliga führen, nämlich ist das alles langweilig, gewinnt immer der Gleiche und so weiter, um das irgendwie aufzubrechen. Die sind jetzt in diesem Jahr zum ersten Mal so weit, dass sie es wahrscheinlich schaffen werden. Durch einen Langzeitplan und mit einem klaren Ziel, wir wollen die da oben wegstoßen. Und so bauen wir jetzt sukzessive auf, wenn wir nicht die finanziellen Möglichkeiten haben, das sukzessive auf. Mir fehlt irgendwo eine Figur im deutschen Fußball, die diesen Anspruch hat. Und mir geht es nicht darum, das öffentlich auszusprechen, sondern mir geht es darum, das jeden Tag zu leben. Ich nehme zu viele Leute wahr, die eigentlich so dann mit dem Status quo irgendwo auch vielleicht dann ganz zufrieden sind. Und wenn wir, wir wollen auch nicht zu hoch pokern, weil dann müssen wir uns daran messen lassen und so weiter. Das ist alles irgendwie nachvollziehbar. Mir fehlt diese Figur, so wie es Klopp eben vor zehn Jahren gemacht hat, die sagt, wir wollen die da oben wegdrücken. Und so, da bauen wir jetzt einen Fußball, da bauen wir jetzt eine Mannschaft, da bauen wir einen Trainerstab und so weiter, dass das langfristig schafft. Liege ich damit so falsch oder?
Nee, von mir kriegst du volle Zustimmung. Und gerade bei Dortmund fand ich es halt, also die haben dieses Jahr wirklich Voraussetzungen, die sind einfach vier Wochen weiter vom Kopf. Und vier Wochen, es ist Wahnsinn. Also die sind halt seit vier Wochen in der neuen Saison. Während Bayern jetzt gerade letzte Woche dieses Champions-League-Finale gespielt hat, gefühlt und jetzt erst mal Urlaub hat. Und wenn du denen mit 18. September Bundesliga-Auftrag kommst, sagen die, ja, von mir aus, können wir machen, aber schauen wir mal, wie es dann so läuft. Und die Dortmunder könnten das jetzt schon irgendwie, ich denke, die Planungen gehen auch darauf hin. Aber was mich halt gestört hat, war, dass in einer Woche aus Dortmund kam dieses, wir geben jetzt kein Saisonziel öffentlich aus, weil das, warum auch immer, habe ich nicht verstanden. Und die nächste Meldung war dann, ja, wir ändern übrigens Rückennummern bei uns im Kader. Und zwar der kriegt jetzt diese Rückennummer und der kriegt die Rückennummer und der kriegt die Rückennummer und so. Das wirkt halt einfach ganz seltsam. Nach dem Motto, denen sind aktuell die Rückennummern wichtiger, als ob die jetzt dieses Jahr Meister werden oder nicht, so gefühlt. Wo ich dir schon auch recht gebe, ist, dass halt diese Vereine weg sind, oder alle Vereine weg sind von der Zielsetzung. Ziel, das absolute, übergeordnete Ziel ist der Titel. Hin zu einer Zielsetzung, die heißt, wir müssen wirtschaftlich gesunden, wir müssen wirtschaftlich uns stabil halten, wir müssen wirtschaftlich schauen, dass wir gute Zahlen schreiben. Und am Ende des Tages ist Rabah damit einverstanden, wenn da der Rubel stimmt und der Revenue für dieses Produkt da ist, das sie vertreten. Bei Dortmund ist man einverstanden, wenn das finanziell alles sich in geregelten Bahnen bewegt und ob man dann zweiter wurde oder dritter oder vielleicht sogar mal erster. Also diese These stelle ich in den Raum. Das ist dann am Ende nicht mehr alles entscheidend. Diese Mentalität zu haben wäre wünschenswert, aber ich glaube, die Leute sehen halt auch den realistischen Rahmen und wiederum die realistischen Voraussetzungen und einfach die viel, viel besseren Grundvoraussetzungen des FC Bayern, sodass man sich eben nicht einfach hinstellen kann mit den aktuellen Gegebenheiten und schon gar nicht nach dieser Corona-Krise und dieser Weltwirtschaftskrise, die wir schlittern oder die schon da ist, sich da einfach bold hinzustellen und zu sagen, ja, machen wir jetzt so. Wir greifen die Bayern an. Wir sind jetzt die Bayern-Jäger Nummer eins, weil dann fällt man, glaube ich, auch relativ schnell damit auf die Fresse.
Ja, da stecken ja so zwei Sachen drin. Also zum einen die Frage, die ich einfach offen in den Raum stelle, was ist Julian Nagelsmann wichtiger, eine Meisterschaft mit Leipzig oder irgendwann Trainer bei den Bayern zu sein? Also ist nicht vielleicht auch der FC Bayern als Zielclub für Trainer inzwischen ein Problem für die Liga? Und das andere ist aber das, was du zuletzt gesagt hast, wenn du solche großen Ankündigungen machst, dann wird dir das vielleicht auch logischerweise aber auch immer vorgehalten. Und dann aber auch, da steckt dann auch wieder oft Häme drin, wenn es schiefgeht. Da kann man sich angucken, was zum Beispiel im Umgang mit Werder Bremen passiert ist, die mit großen Zielen gestartet sind und ganz fürchterlich auf den Mund gefallen sind. Du kannst dir angucken, was mit Borussia Dortmund passiert ist, die vor dem Auswärtsspiel bei Bayern sagen, soll jetzt mal richtig hier mit Männerfußball, man war auch eine dämliche Aussage und so weiter. Aber ich finde, ich glaube, das spielt halt auch damit rein, dass diese Geschichten nicht produziert werden, dass eigentlich kaum einer, doof gesagt, die Eier hat, sich einfach hinzustellen, jetzt mache ich im Grunde dasselbe wie Männerfußball, das Selbstbewusstsein hat sich hinzustellen, Entschuldigung, und zu sagen, wir sind jetzt die, wir wollen jetzt da sein. Die berühmte Aussage von Schalke 04, Clemens Tönnies, wenn Bayern mal Strauch hat, müssen wir da sein, Horst Held hat es auch gesagt, wo man sich dann immer herrlich drüber lustig macht, aber eigentlich wollen wir ja diese Geschichten und müsste man da nicht auch einen anderen Umgang mit solchen Aussagen bekommen und eben sagen, ja super, da ist jemand, der sich dagegen stellt und er kämpft mit ungleichen Waffen einen schwierigen Kampf und ist vielleicht eher so wie Luke Skywalker mit einem Todesstern. Und wenn es dann doch mal klappt, dann jubeln alle, aber in neun von zehn Fällen trifft er halt den Entlüftungsschaft, nicht?
Aber dann sag es meinetwegen nicht öffentlich. Mach es so wie Klopp damals und sag, wir sind hier der Underdog und erzählen auch am 33. Spieltag, dass wir hier gar nicht hergehören, aber intern hat er ja anders geredet. Also intern hat er doch seine Mannschaft komplett, das hast du doch in jedem Spiel gegen Bayern gemerkt, da ist doch keine Mannschaft aufgetreten, die jetzt irgendwie gesagt wurde, wenn wir hier mit 0-0 rauskommen, sind wir zufrieden. Sondern die waren so heiß darauf, diesen Fußball kaputt zu machen, den Bayerns in der Zeit gespielt hat. Und den eigenen Stil durchzudrücken. Deswegen geht es mir noch nicht mal um die öffentlichen Kampfansagen, sondern es geht einfach nur um den Anspruch. So diesen Anspruch intern zu haben, wir orientieren uns an den Besten und wir schaffen es zumindest vielleicht mal alle 3-4 Jahre, mal ein Team zu formen. Und es ist ja auch, Bayerns Spiel ist nach wie vor angreifbar. Also es ist nach wie vor so, das haben wir ja auch jetzt in der Schlussphase der Champions League teilweise gesehen. Es ist nach wie vor so, dass du mit einem, wenn du vorne einen bulligen Stürmer hast, der mit dem Rücken zum Tor agieren kann, den du sofort steil anspielen kannst, der in der Lage ist, den Ball zu verarbeiten und du hast dann flinke Außen oder flinke Achter, die dann in der Lage sind, ein Konterspiel aufzuziehen. Das ist immer noch das gleiche Spiel, was damals schon Chelsea als Robin dann noch gespielt hat. Das ist über 10 Jahre her. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer der Trainer war. Aber da haben die uns schon mit auseinandergenommen. Und so hat Dortmund uns ja auch ähnlich gemacht. Und ich würde behaupten, dass es immer noch, wenn man eine Mannschaft so formt, dass sie wirklich auf Bayerns Schwächen passt, dass man in der Lage ist, die auch ins Wanken zu bringen.
Unter diesem Aspekt ist es tragisch, dass Sevilla die Europa League gewonnen hat und wir nicht das Spiel Inter gegen Bayern uns mal angucken können. Mit Romelu Lukaku und Konter Fußball. Ja, stimmt natürlich alles.
Aber diese Schwächen sind ja auch am Anfang der Saison sehr gut zu Tage getreten. Da war so ein 1-5 in Frankfurt.
Ah, die goldene Überleitung. Jetzt sind wir in der Saison. Also die Saison 2018, 2019, da sind wir jetzt ein bisschen drüber gewischt. Aber Bayern ist da unter Niko Kovac Meister geworden. Mit zwei Punkten Vorsprung vor Borussia Dortmund. Ganz, ganz große Aufregung an der Meisterschaft. Erst am letzten Spieltag zu Hause gegen Frankfurt mit einem 5 zu 1. Und man hat dann auch noch den DFB-Pokal gewonnen. Und jetzt kommen wir in eine Saison 2019, 2020, die eben kulminiert in der Hinrunde in einem 1 zu 5 in Frankfurt vom ehemaligen Frankfurter Trainer Niko Kovac. Was war da los, Flo?
Also zu allererst fliegt Jerome Boateng in der zehnten Minute vom Platz. Also dieses Spiel ist geprägt von einer Unterzahl-Situation von Bayern, die Bayern nicht kompensiert bekommt, weil der Trainer nicht reagiert, nicht richtig reagiert und weil Bayern zu der Phase extrem anfällig ist gegen schnelle Gegenspieler und weil, meiner Meinung nach, auch die Mannschaft gegen den Trainer spielt. Man merkt, zwischen Mannschaft und Trainer stimmt das nicht. Es kam eine Woche vorher oder in der Woche davor zu diesem berühmten Kovac-Satz, als er darauf angesprochen wurde, ob man nicht so spielen wolle wie Liverpool, ob einem da nicht das Herz aufgehe, wenn man eine Mannschaft so spielen sehe und er sagt, ja, aber du kannst nicht 200 auf der Autobahn fahren, wenn das Auto nur 100 schafft. Und ich glaube, das haben alle Spieler gehört und sich alle gedacht, sag mal, spinnt der jetzt eigentlich? Und in dieser Gemengelage sind die in dieses Spiel gegangen und dann kannst du in Frankfurt auch mal fünf Stück kassieren, aber die Art und Weise war natürlich unfassbar. Und da kumulierte dann alles, was nicht richtig läuft, auf dem Platz, neben dem Platz, mit fehlendem Spielglück, mit roter Karte und Bayern kriegt da so dermaßen die Hucke voll. Ich habe mir die Aufstellung nochmal angeschaut. Es war ja nicht so, dass da ganz andere Spieler auf dem Platz gestanden werden, als die, die den Champions-League-Titel geholt haben am Ende der Saison. Nein, es standen neun Spieler auf dem Platz, die auch im Finale gegen PSG auf dem Platz standen. Neun. Die einzigen Änderungen waren, glaube ich, Coman und Goretzka, die gespielt haben jetzt im Champions-League-Finale statt Coutinho und Pavard. Und das ist jetzt auch kein, wo ich sage, die zwei haben es dann auf jeden Fall rausgerissen. Klar, Coman hat das Tor gemacht, aber ja. Also, das war schon die Spitze des Eisbergs. Und dann letztlich auch der letzte Offenbarungseid, dass jedem klar wurde, mit Niko Kovac kann es beim FC Bayern nicht weitergehen als Trainer. Und wie sich dann in den nächsten Wochen unter Flick entwickelt hat, dieser anderes Spielstil, dieses Pressing und Gegenpressing, Chaos generieren, Chaos auch in das Gegnershälfte hervorrufen und trotzdem hinten eine Absicherung zu haben und trotzdem hinten eine gute Restverteidigung zu haben, das hat sich halt relativ schnell alles in eine extrem gute Richtung entwickelt, auch für die Spieler, die dann sofort gemerkt haben, so funktioniert es ja wirklich gut und so können wir das auch so spielen, wie wir wollen und so müssen wir nicht immer 70 Meter mit dem Ball Richtung gegnerisches Tor zurechtlaufen, sondern wir sind einfach viel näher am gegnerischen Tor dran. Große Rolle hat bestimmt auch Alphonso Davies gespielt, der mit seiner Schnelligkeit einfach auch viel zugeführt hat, den übrigens Kovac schon eingesetzt hat. Davies kam ja nicht erst mit Flick in die Mannschaft, sondern er hat ja auch in Frankfurt gespielt und davor schon in Bochum. Aber er war dann plötzlich fester Bestandteil dieser Mannschaft. So nahm das dann so seinen Lauf.
Man muss noch mal sagen, dass das 1 zu 5 gegen Frankfurt, das war ja der Endpunkt einer Entwicklung. Also es gab diesen 7 zu 2 Erfolg gegen Tottenham, wo irgendwie alle dachten, okay, geht es jetzt doch noch in Richtung Happy End und danach lief ja gar nichts mehr. Niederlage gegen Hoffenheim in der Bundesliga, 2-2 gegen Augsburg, ein grausames 3 zu 2 bei Olympiakos, dann auch ein grausames 2 zu 1 gegen Bochum im Pokal, was wirklich peinlich teilweise war, wie Bayern da gespielt hat. Und das 5 zu 1 war dann irgendwie so die Spitze des Eisberges, während man vorher irgendwie noch hinbekommen hat, zumindest Ergebnisse rauszuholen, war jetzt dann für jeden offensichtlich, dass das nicht mehr funktioniert. Und man muss schon sagen, Respekt an die Verantwortlichen beim FC Bayern, dann auch so konsequent die Reißleine zu ziehen, weil eine Woche später stand das Spiel gegen Borussia Dortmund an. Also nicht unbedingt der perfekte Moment für einen Trainerwechsel. Im Nachhinein war er es dann doch, weil das Spiel geht 4-0 aus und wie die Restsaison weitergeht, wissen wir auch. Aber dass der FC Bayern da Anfang November dann so konsequent sagt, geht hier nicht weiter, glaube, muss man auch sagen, viel mehr Zeit hätte man da auch nicht verstreichen lassen dürfen, sonst wäre die Saison sicherlich anders ausgegangen.
Ja, es gab noch ein knappes 2 zu 1 gegen Union. Zu Hause, aber in der Tat, ich habe irgendwo den Tweet gelesen, leider ist mir der Autor vergessen gegangen. Aber am nächsten am Trippel verhindern, war der VfL Bochum gegen den FC Bayern. Das fand ich recht treffend. Ja, aber wie ordnen wir jetzt dann, bevor wir gleich über Hansi Flick sprechen, die Zeit von Niko Kovac ein? Ich finde, ich tue mich da schwer in einer Bewertung, weil natürlich, man sagen kann, es ist nicht gut gegangen. Ich habe aber auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, von Anfang an hatte Niko Kovac keine Chance. Und in Teilen ist er dafür verantwortlich, und in Teilen aber nicht. Ich glaube, dass er zum einen auf eine Mannschaft getroffen ist, mit sehr, sehr starken Köpfen, die sehr genau registrieren, ob jemand sie taktisch weiterbringt oder nicht. Ich finde, das kann man in der Retrospektive ganz gut in dem sehen, was sie über Hansi Flick dann gesagt haben. Also, jeder hat jetzt einen klaren Auftrag und so weiter. Und zum anderen aber ist ja Niko Kovac geholt worden und man hat sich von Anfang angefragt, wie soll denn die Art und Weise, wie er bisher Fußball hat spielen lassen, zum FC Bayern passen? Und er hätte sich natürlich verändern können. Er hat auch versucht, sich zu verändern. Aber es hat nicht geklappt. Vorne und hinten eigentlich nicht, auch wenn nicht alle Spiele verloren wurden. Also ich will es jetzt nicht überdramatisieren, aber das stimmt ja mit dieser Entwicklung, deren Höhepunkt dann das 1 zu 5 war. Ist nicht der eigentliche Fehler schon passiert, einen Trainer zu holen, der sicher kein schlechter Trainer ist, aber der hat eigentlich keine Chance hatte, bei dieser Mannschaft, bei dieser Art Fußball, die der FC Bayern spielen, will ja auch?
Ich glaube, das Problem war einfach, dass Niko Kovac es nicht geschafft hat, als Trainer mit der Mannschaft zusammen eine Spielidee zu entwickeln, die beide tragen, also die Trainer wie Mannschaft mittragen. Sondern er hatte seine Vorstellungen. Er hat diese Vorstellungen meiner Meinung nach sehr autoritär vorgetragen. Und er hat da dann wichtige Stimmen gegen sich gehabt. Und einige Stimmen gegen sich gehabt. Und das hat ihm einfach nie zum Vorteil gereicht. Im Gegenteil, das wurde ihm zum Verhängnis. Und dann halt so Spieler wie Hummels gegen sich zu haben, Spieler gegen sich zu haben, die dann auch noch dem Boulevard zugetan sind, die kann man dann aussortieren und nach China schicken, geht schon. Aber dann auch den Thomas Müller zu demontieren, das ist alles nicht so schlau. Dann hat er sich einfach nicht schlau angestellt. Er wollte seinen Weg gehen, er wollte seinen Weg durchdrücken, er wollte seine Mannschaft überzeugen, aber er hat es einfach nicht geschafft. Und da war dann der FC Bayern dann auch einfach unter den Voraussetzungen, die sicherlich nicht gut waren für ihn. Aber er hätte es einfach schaffen müssen, sie zu überzeugen, er hat es nicht geschafft. Und das ist ihm dann anzukreiden.
Was ich den Verantwortlichen ankreiden würde, ist, dass sie... Also ich habe den FC Bayern generell rund um diese Verpflichtung von Kovac irgendwie als taumelnd wahrgenommen. Ich glaube, in dieser Zeit fällt ja auch diese Pressekonferenz da, diese Meinungsfreiheitspressekonferenz und so weiter. Also dieser Verein hat insgesamt einfach keinen guten Eindruck abgegeben und wusste, glaube ich, auch nicht so richtig, wo er hin will. Und die Wahrheit wäre ja gewesen, zu sagen, wir wissen gerade auch nicht so richtig. Wir wollen jetzt aber irgendwie vor allen Dingen dieses mir sein mir-Gefühl wieder stärken und wir wollen, dass sich alle wohlfühlen. So hat sich Hoeneß ja zumindest öffentlich dann auch geäußert, wo er gesagt hat, Robben und Ribery, die müsse man immer spielen lassen und so weiter. Die können man nicht auf die Bank setzen. Das Wichtigste ist, dass die sich wohlfühlen. Und so habe ich auch diese Kovac-Verpflichtung verstanden. Der hat irgendwie steil gerucht, der so irgendwie, wenn die alternativen Tuchel und Nagelsmann oder so gewesen wären, die sind dann vielleicht zu kompliziert. Aber was sie gemacht haben, ist dann halt öffentlich zu sagen, ja, Kovac ist der beste Trainer, der verfügbar ist. Der war ganz klar unsere Variante Nummer eins. Und ich meine, das stimmt ja auch nicht. Also es wissen ja auch alle, wie lange man mit Tuchel irgendwie hin und her überlegt hat und sich dann nicht durchregen konnte. Oder dann vielleicht auch zu spät war, als er sich dann schon für PSG entschieden hat. Und das passte irgendwie für mich nicht zusammen. Und wenn man von Anfang an eine Geschichte gestrickt hätte, wo man eben sagt, so wir konzentrieren uns jetzt stärker wieder auf die Werte hier im Verein und keine Ahnung, dann hat das vielleicht einen anderen Start gehabt. Aber so ihn auch von Anfang an zu überhöhen, als der jetzt die Mannschaft großartig weiterentwickelt, diese Erwartung hatte ich offen gesagt nie. Und was Flo richtig gesagt hat, die Mannschaft ging sie... Wenn man sieht, wie emotional Thomas Müller jetzt nach dem Champions-League-Finale war, wo er auch nochmal gesagt hat, wie er quasi aussortiert war im letzten Herbst und irgendwie das Gefühl hatte, auch er gehört nicht mehr dazu, sowohl bei der Nationalmannschaft, aber auch von Kovac infrage gestellt wurde, dann zeigt das, glaube ich, wie tief diese Phase oder wie sehr auch die Verunsicherung in der Mannschaft in dieser Phase einfach da war.
Man darf ja nicht vergessen, beim FC Bayern gab es ja auch wirklich nicht nur jetzt Umbrüche in der Mannschaft, ihrer Robberie, sondern ja auch im Vorstand. Und die jetzt ja auch von langer Hand in den letzten zwei Jahren dann erstmal umgesetzt werden mussten. Also man hat Hasan Salihamidžić in eine Rolle gehievt, die vielleicht inhaltlich ganz gut ausfüllt, aber in der Außendarstellung doch erhebliche Probleme hatte. Oder hat. Und es musste plötzlich jetzt eine Nachfolgeregelung für Hönes und für Rummenigge gefunden werden. Und in dieser Gemengelage ist natürlich sehr viel Aufruhr in so einem Club, die sich natürlich dann auch, gerade bei diesen Köpfen Rummenigge und Hönes, natürlich bis in den sportlichen Bereich auswirken. Und unter diesem Hintergrund ist, glaube ich, diese Episode Kovac auch zu sehen. Oder die Ära Kovacs zu, Ära, also die Amtszeit Kovacs zu sehen. Dass er auch da gegen Widerstände zu kämpfen hatte, die er gar nicht beeinflussen konnte. Und umso erstaunlicher ist es, wie sich das alles wirklich innerhalb von wenigen Monaten so in Wohlgefallen aufgelöst hat. So, aber vielleicht auch die Verpflichtung von Hansi Flick.
Da wäre ich an Kovacs Stelle schon hellhörig geworden. Also zumindest war das mein Gedanke damals schon, als er dann dazu kam, dass ich dachte, okay, da wird nach einer Back-up-Lösung schon gearbeitet.
Das haben wir alle geschrieben. Wir haben alle geschrieben, dass es gut ist, dass der Flick da reinkommt, weil der kann mit den Nationalspielern, der kann eine Brücke schlagen zum DFB, der kann da auch noch ein bisschen was inhaltlich reinbringen. Und sollte das mit Kovac nicht funktionieren, haben Sie ja gleich einen, der das Ding übernehmen kann.
Aber hat denn wirklich jemand geglaubt, dass Hansi Flick das als Cheftrainer dann länger macht? Also ich hatte einfach auch nicht die Wahrnehmung des sehr erfolgreichen Manns in der ersten Reihe von Hans-Dieter Flick. Das kann jetzt auch mein Fehler sein, aber würde ich jetzt halt aus seiner Biografie herleiten. Er ist ja nicht als der Mann bekannt geworden. Immer wenn er in der ersten Reihe stand, bei Hoffenheim oder beim DFB, wo es jetzt auch nicht die erste Reihe im Sinne von tägliche Pressekonferenzen erste Reihe war, hat er sich zurückgezogen. Ich dachte auch, es ist quasi ein Kommunikator. Ich habe ihn aber nicht als Backup gesehen. Als Interimslösung natürlich logisch. Man braucht irgendwie jemanden, der einem Zeit verschafft. Aber mir war das nicht klar, dass Hans-Dieter Flick diese Qualitäten als Mann der ersten Reihe hat.
Das war mir auch nicht klar.
Ja, aber welchen Trainer kriegst du sonst, der sowas kann? Also, ich meine, sonst hast du ja immer irgendwelche Zuarbeiter, wo du jetzt wirklich nicht sagen kannst, dass die das Zeug dann wirklich im Rampenlicht zu stehen. Oder oft hast du das halt. Oder halt diese ganz alten Lösungen, wie Peter Herrmann und Hermann Gerland, wo du jetzt auch wusstest, auf kurz oder lang, das wird dann nicht irgendwie eine Interimslösung sein und schon gar keine langfristige Lösung. Bei Flick hattest du schon, denke ich, das Potenzial, dass das funktionieren könnte. Oder dass das zumindest eine zusätzliche Überlegung sein könnte. So ist es ja letztlich dann auch gekommen.
Es ist ja auch keine Garantie, dass es funktioniert. Als Sanyol Co-Trainer bei Ancelotti wurde, hatte ich den gleichen Hintergedanken. Das ist dann natürlich jetzt so irgendwie nicht aufgegangen. Aber zumindest hatte ich das Gefühl, man kommt nicht mehr in die Bredouille, Jupp Heynckes oder Ottmar Hitzfeld oder sonst wen anzurufen. Sondern man hat zumindest dann erst mal irgendwie Ruhe. Und so ist ja auch die Saison gestartet. Als Kovac weg war, haben wir ja auch alle über Erik Ten Hag oder über andere Lösungen gesprochen, die dann vielleicht im Januar oder im Sommer kommen. Aber zumindest hattest du erst mal Ruhe. Und was ich ihm schon zugetraut habe, war eben, dass er die Mannschaft beruhigt, dass er auch wieder einfach eine Arbeitsatmosphäre schafft, wo sich die Mannschaft wohlfühlt und dann eben auch erfolgreich sein kann. Dass er sich jetzt auch als taktisch, ja, wir haben viel über Guardiola und über Heynckes gesprochen, was Flick jetzt gerade in der letzten Saisonphase auch taktisch der Mannschaft da eingeflößt hat. Das ist in diesem Jahrzehnt sicherlich die dritte große taktische und spielerische Offenbarung gewesen. Nach Heynckes und nach Guardiola.
Und da war er ja auch unglücklich.
Was auch ganz wichtig war, ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber was, glaube ich, Bayern auch total wichtig war, war einfach, dass Flick Brücken schlagen sollte, auch zum Jugendbereich. Und das hat er halt dieses Jahr halt auch sehr gut gemacht.
Und er ist die Aufgabe vielleicht nicht auch angegangen wie ein klassischer Interimstrenner. Oder zumindest wie jemand, der eben mutig alle hinter einem neuen Plan vereint. Also das erste Spiel gegen Pireos, da hat er ja, glaube ich, nur eine Trainingseinheit. Das kann man jetzt nicht so richtig mit reinrechnen. Aber dann war ja direkt dann am 9. November das Heimspiel gegen Borussia Dortmund. Und das hat man jetzt nicht nur 4-0 gewonnen. Da waren auch Einzelereignisse mit dabei. Irgendwie ein Fehler von Sagadu war es, glaube ich. Oder Kanji, bin mir gerade nicht mehr sicher, vom 2 zu 0. Aber das Interessante war ja, Bayern ist da komplett anders aufgetreten. Bayern hat da schon ein Pressing umgesetzt, bei dem alle Spieler vorrücken. Also es wird quasi vorne die Spitze. Robert Lewandowski läuft an und alle schieben nach. Also ein sehr riskantes Pressing. Und auch eines, was funktionieren muss. Das hätte auch sehr leicht, gerade von einem gut aufgelegten Jadon Sancho, zum Beispiel aufgedeckt werden können. Aber ich fand, das war kein klassisches, wie ein Interimstrainer eine Mannschaft beruhigt verwalten, sondern das war eher ein offensives, okay, gut, jetzt habe ich das Steuer in der Hand. Übrigens, das wäre die Richtung, in die ich gerne fahren würde. Und dann hat das aus verschiedenen Gründen, sicherlich hat dabei auch eine Rolle gespielt, dass das gleich so großen Erfolg hatte mit diesem Spiel. Deswegen hat man sich da auch nicht so ganz aus der Ruhe bringen lassen, als es gegen Leverkusen und Gladbach eher unglücklich dann zweimal nicht gut gegangen ist in der Folge. Aber das hat dann, glaube ich, alle hinter diesem Plan vereint. Und dann hat das eine Dynamik entwickelt.
Es war aber am Anfang schon wohldosiert. Also es war noch nicht dieses, Bayern hat nicht gegen Dortmund so gespielt, wie sie jetzt gegen Barcelona gespielt haben.
Das stimmt.
Oder wie sie gegen PSG gespielt haben. Sondern es war noch, es war einfach ein aggressiveres nach vorne verteidigen, aber schon, und halt auch nicht in die, in die, in die Defensive Grundordnung zu krass zurückzufallen und sich zurückzuziehen. Aber es war noch nicht das, wie es am Ende war. Aber Flick hat halt relativ schnell einfach seine Gedanken damit eingebracht und hat sie den Spielern vorgestellt und die sind ihm sofort hinterhergelaufen. Und dann, du hast es gerade angesprochen, sie verlieren hintereinander weg gegen, gegen Leverkusen und Gladbach. Oder andersrum. Aber, aber es macht niemanden nervös. Zu dem Zeitpunkt. Also, so ein bisschen ja. Aber keiner denkt zu dem Zeitpunkt daran zu sagen, oh Hoppela, vielleicht ist es mit Flick doch nicht das Richtige. Vor allem intern. Sondern sie merken, das hätte jetzt auch anders ausgehen können in Gladbach. Und die Grundidee ist gut. Und die Grundidee passt gut zusammen. Und die Grundidee passt auch zu den Spielern. Und die Spieler tragen das. Und die Spieler waren dann eben auch die, die dann den Kahn aus dem Dreck gezogen haben. Und bis zum Winter dann nochmal eine Schippe drauf gelegt haben, sodass es sich zumindest erträglich gestaltet hat, der Rückstand auf den Herbstmeister aus Sachsen. Und dann trat die Situation an einem Trainingslager in Doha, wo sie dann wirklich progressiv Ziele formuliert haben. Und auch wirklich gesagt haben, wir können dieses Trippel schaffen, wenn alle an einem Strang ziehen, wenn wir unsere Spielweise weiter verbessern, wenn wir das machen, was der Trainer umsetzt. Und da ist wirklich dann so eine eingeschworene Gemeinschaft entstanden. Zwischen Trainer, der natürlich auch die entsprechende Empathie mitgebracht hat, und Spielern, die sich vom Trainer wertgeschätzt fühlen und die sich verstanden fühlen und die das auf dem Spielfeld dann auch umsetzen dürfen, was sie sich vielleicht selber auch vorstellen.
Ich fand es noch beeindruckender, wie sie dann aus der Corona-Pause kamen, weil das Spiel verbesserte sich in der Tat sukzessive, aber gerade so im Frühjahr war das Spiel auch gut. Und wie gesagt, was Flick geschafft hat neben diesem Gegenpressing, vor allen Dingen auch, dass die Abstände endlich wieder stimmten, also dass du wirklich das Gefühl hast, da bewegen sich auch Mannschaftsteile synchron zueinander und nicht irgendwie ständig aus der Balance zu kommen. Aber es waren noch so Wackler drin, gerade so im Frühjahr. Und dann kam diese Corona-Pause und da habe ich mich schon gefragt, wie kommen die da jetzt wieder raus? Weil das war ja für Bayern eigentlich so ein bisschen zur Unzeit dann auch, weil sie einen richtig guten Lauf hatten. Und irgendwie müssen sie es ja auch geschafft haben, da aus dem Homeoffice oder aus dem digitalen Training oder was auch immer. Die kamen ja raus aus dieser Pause wie so Berserker. Also es war ja so richtig, wie so gefräßig. Es war jetzt nicht mehr nur guter Fußball, sondern diese Intensität war ja einfach Wahnsinn. Das war ja so ein bisschen so, wie Dortmund früher gespielt hat. Diese Sprints im Pressing. Also es ist nicht nur als Kollektiv gepresst wurde, sondern auch jeder Einzelne, der irgendwie ballener war, wie verrückt da gerannt ist und den Gegner unter Druck gesetzt hat und fast jeden Gegner wirklich aufgefressen hat dann in dieser Phase. Das fand ich beeindruckend und da würde ich auch gerne, ich weiß nicht Flo, ob du da Infos hast, aber das würde ich gerne in der Nachbetrachtung nochmal verstehen, was mit der Mannschaft in dieser Corona-Pause passiert ist, weil ich stelle mir das wahnsinnig schwer vor. Ich meine, ich habe in meinem Job auch irgendwie versucht, alle im Homeoffice zu organisieren, aber natürlich, man wächst nicht unbedingt zusammen in so einer Phase, sondern es wird eher irgendwie komplizierter und schwieriger, man versucht sich anzupassen, aber es muss irgendwas nochmal Klick gemacht haben in dieser Phase.
Die Bayern haben einfach einen extrem guten Job gemacht, von der Eins im Verein bis runter zum letzten Posten. Da muss ich wirklich auch dem Vorstand mein Kompliment ausdrücken, die sehr schnell, sehr besonnen die Mitarbeiter auch in den Vordergrund gestellt haben, natürlich auch wieder aus einer Position der finanziellen Gesundheit heraus. Die konnten dann natürlich auch eher den Mitarbeitern erstmal Mut zu sprechen und sagen, ihr müsst euch keine Sorgen machen, das geht schon alles und ihr werdet nicht euren Job verlieren. Das hätte jetzt vielleicht ein SC Paderborn jetzt nicht ohne Weiteres aussprechen können. Aber der Verein war sofort gut aufgestellt. Man hat die Spieler unterstützt, auch in ihren Projekten, sei es Wekick Corona, sei es, dass sie auch irgendwie Betreuungen übernommen haben für Spieler und so konnten sich die Bayern-Spieler auch relativ schnell dann auch wieder aufs Normale und aufs Wesentliche konzentrieren, nämlich das Arbeiten. Und auch dort hat das Funktionsteam um Hansi Flick halt wirklich auch aus den Voraussetzungen das Aller-Allerbeste rausgeholt und hat halt dieses Cyber-Training organisiert. Das klingt immer so ein bisschen nach 1998, dieser Cyber-Begriff. Aber die haben halt eben die Gerätschaften, den Leuten halt, also Hansi Flick hat halt so ein Fahrrad halt auch mal selber zu einem Spieler hingefahren und so, so ein Ergometer. Und da haben die halt relativ schnell wieder in die Spur gefunden und relativ schnell die Grundlage gelegt für das weitere. Und was man natürlich auch nicht vergessen darf, ist, Bayern hatte natürlich auch was zu kämpfen. Also Bayern hatte eben dieses Triple vor Augen. Bayern hatte die Bestätigung durch das 3-0-Hinspiel bei Chelsea, dass da wirklich was sein kann, dass da was passieren kann. Und jetzt kommt diese doofe Phase und nein, wir wollen, wenn es weitergeht, wollen wir alles dafür getan haben, dass wir Meister werden, dass wir Pokalsieger werden und dass wir vielleicht am Ende sogar noch die Champions League gewinnen. Das sind jetzt so Sachen wie zum Beispiel, als Spieler von Schalke hast du dir eher schwer getan, nach dieser Pause dann nochmal ohne Zuschauer zurückzukommen und nochmal neun Spiele für was zu spielen. Für was jetzt genau eigentlich? Es standen ja auch wirklich ganz grundsätzliche Dinge in Frage. Wann geht es überhaupt weiter? Hat diese Saison überhaupt nochmal einen Wert? Wird sie abgebrochen? Wird sie nicht abgebrochen? Spiel ich jetzt zwei, drei Mal und dann geht es vielleicht nicht weiter, weil sich irgendjemand infiziert hat und dann plötzlich Spieltage abgesagt werden. Also diese ganzen Fragen standen ja alle in dieser Phase im Raum. Und die Bayern haben es, glaube ich, geschafft, sich relativ schnell einfach darauf zu fokussieren, alles dafür zu tun, bestmöglich vorbereitet zu sein, für den Fall, dass wirklich alles wieder losgeht und für den Fall, dass sie dann wirklich noch eine Chance haben auf das Triple. Und da wirklich von Rummenigge über Kahn, der auch sehr schlaue Sachen gemacht hat, der intern wohl auch sehr gut gewirkt hat, bis eben über Team Flick, bis zu jedem einzelnen Spieler, sind bildlich natürlich der Muckimann Leon Goretzka, der, wie wir leider nur hoffen können, da natürlich jetzt keine unmenschlichen Dinge mit sich und seinem Körper angestellt hat, sondern dass das auch alles mit legalen Mitteln und Dingen vor sich ging. Aber wir gehen mal davon aus, also Kompliment an alle Beteiligten.
Sie sind es im Grunde ein bisschen angegangen, wie eine Saisonvorbereitung war ja im Grunde auch die erste richtige Saisonvorbereitung unter Hansi Flick, wo eben halt auch körperliche Grundlagen gelegt werden für die Intensität, die die Bayern haben. Ich möchte aber dennoch ein bisschen Wasser in die Suppe gießen, denn das stimmt natürlich alles. Jetzt in der Retrospektive alles ganz toll. Trippel, super. Aber zum Beispiel die letzten Spiele vor der Winterpause. Wenn da nicht ein gewischer Joshua Zirkzi gegen Freiburg in der Nachspielzeit zweimal getroffen hätte und dann auch gegen Wolfsburg sehr spät im Spiel, ich glaube 1. April und dann auch nochmal Zirkzi, dann hätte Bayern da schon Punkte liegen lassen, wo man damals dachte, hui, das könnte entscheidend werden. Es waren vier Punkte Rückstand auf Rabaa Leipzig zum Winter. Es hätten mehr sein können. Und auch in der Rückrunde ist es noch so, dass du immer wieder Spiele mit dabei hast, gerade bei hohen Führungen, wo gewackelt wurde. Also ein DFB-Pokal-Achtelfinale zu Hause gegen Hoffenheim, was irgendwie völlig wird mit 4 zu 3 endet. Ein Spiel gegen den SC Paderborn, wo man zu Hause 3 zu 2 spielt und gerade noch das 3 zu 2 irgendwie am Schluss macht. Ein nicht wirklich so ganz überzeugendes 1 zu 0 bei einem Schalke 04, was ja irgendwie mit 13 Prozent Ballbesitz in der eigenen Hälfte war, aber auch 2, 3 Chancen hatte, wo es schiefgehen hätte können. Auch der direkte Start nach der Corona-Pause bei Union Berlin, da hat man sich noch eher schwer getan, kann man natürlich aber auch unter diesem Corona-Effekt abstempeln. Auch gegen Eintracht Frankfurt, das DFB-Pokal-Halbfinale, da wurde es noch mal eng als Martin Hinteregger zum Kopfball-Hochstieg nach Flanke Rode. Und übers Champions-League-Finale, auch wenn wir da natürlich auch von anderen Voraussetzungen sprechen, aber das war ja gegen Lyon und PSG auch, das waren jeweils enge Kisten. Und ich möchte nicht sagen, dass jetzt deswegen Bayern schlecht gearbeitet hätte oder so, aber lassen wir uns nicht in den Komplimenten, die wir da verteilen, vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu sehr von den Ergebnissen leiten, die, wenn man auf jedes einzelne Spiel draufguckt, dann hin und wieder auch einfach durch Faktoren wie individuelle Klasse und Glück zustande gekommen sind. Okay, ich sehe schon in dieser Runde die falsche Frage.
Ja, klar, aber ich meine, das ist doch auch normal. Also ich meine, es ist doch völlig normal, dass auch wenn du guten Fußball spielst und so weiter, dass es immer wieder Momente gibt, wo auch Dinge aus der Kippe stehen. Sprich ja nur für meine These, dass am Ende eben nicht nur alles an meinem Geld liegt. Nein, natürlich, klar. Also insbesondere, ich hab mir im Finale vor allen Dingen Sorgen gemacht. Da hab ich schon so das Gefühl gehabt, das war teilweise schon so ein bisschen auf dem letzten Zahnfleisch. So auch gerade so die letzte, die Schlussphase, da hab ich mir schon Sorgen gemacht, im Lyon-Spiel weniger. Weil klar hat man dann viele Chancen zugelassen, aber man hat ja auch relativ souverän dann geführt. Insofern ja, natürlich, gerade vor der Corona-Pause, hab ich ja vorhin schon gesagt, so der eine oder andere Wackler drin gewesen. Danach hab ich aber wirklich wenig Grund, mich irgendwo zu beschweren oder zu sagen, da gab es irgendwie systematische Probleme. Sicherlich dieses 8 zu 2, was da rausgehoben ist gegen Barcelona, das ist natürlich, also, das wird sicherlich für immer irgendwo mit dieser Saison verbunden bleiben. Ob das jetzt wirklich die wahren Kräfteverhältnisse widerspiegelt oder ob da nicht auch einfach Spielglück in eine bestimmte Richtung läuft, hergeschenkt. Aber das gehört eben dazu. Du kannst auch am 7 zu 1 gegen Brasier gehen, wenn du es nochmal genau auseinander nimmst, Momente finden, wo du sagst, ah, da gab es nochmal hier eine Chance. Und wenn das anders gelaufen wäre, ich glaube, das ist ganz normal. Was mich beeindruckt hat, und das hat mir wirklich richtig gefallen, weil darum geht es mir letztendlich auch, als vor dem Finale Oliver Kahn und auch Flick angesprochen wurden auf die defensiven Probleme, die man gegen Lyon hatte, die Chancen, die man dazu gelassen hatte, wurden sie explizit darauf angesprochen. Und es wurde gesagt, ja, mit Neymar und Mbappé und so weiter, das könne man ja so nicht durchziehen, das würde ja schief gehen. Und da haben beide unabhängig voneinander gesagt, nee, das ist der Spielstil, der uns hierhin geführt hat. Und wir wissen, dass wir durch dieses hohe Pressing auch immer wieder Lücken im Rücken ermöglichen. Aber das ist unsere Spielweise und die werden wir jetzt ganz sicher auch nicht im letzten Spiel ändern. Und dann bin ich auch bereit, solche Großchancen, die zum Beispiel Paris dann ja auch hatte, dann auch hinzunehmen. Wenn eine Mannschaft, wenn ein Klub sagt, das ist unsere Philosophie, so spielen wir Fußball. Und das in aller Konsequenz und wenn das am Ende sozusagen, und wir vertrauen auch darauf, dass das am Ende dazu führt, dass wir gewinnen, dann kann ich auch über das eine oder andere Problem, was daraus entsteht, dann hinwegsehen. Weil das will ich, dass das ein Verein eine Philosophie hat und die durchzieht.
Ja, in Bayern war natürlich jetzt nicht das alles über das Europa dominierende Team, genauso wie Bayern, nicht das Team war, das per se 1 zu 5 in Frankfurt zu verlieren hat. Irgendwo in der Mitte liegt natürlich die Wahrheit. Und ich glaube, man kann das jetzt alles zurück analysieren und sagen, hier hätte und hätte da Divari. Aber die sind jetzt Trippelsieger. Aber spannend wird halt jetzt, wie geht es weiter? Wie geht es jetzt in die neue Saison, die ja gleich mal sportlich mit drei englischen Wochen beginnt für die Bayern mit sechs Spielen bis zum 4. Oktober. Also zwischen 11. September und 4. Oktober sechs Spiele plus inklusive zweier Supercups. Und halt wirklich, wenn man sich dann die Frage stellt, deswegen hat Flick ja schon vorgebaut und hat gesagt, ich brauche vielleicht noch den einen oder anderen Spieler. Wäre vielleicht gar nicht schlecht, weil mein Spielstil ist halt sehr, sehr fordernd. Unser Spielstil ist sehr, sehr aufwendig. Es ist vor allem nicht nur körperlich aufwendig, sondern höchst herausfordernd fürs Mentale, immer wieder drauf zu gehen, immer wieder dem Drang zu widerstehen, sich fallen zu lassen und erst mal Distanz zwischen sich und den Ball zu legen, dass man nicht ausgespielt wird, sondern wirklich aggressiv immer zu bleiben, immer scharf zu bleiben, ist, glaube ich, das richtige Wort. Und klar kann man das in so einem Champions League-End-Turnier, und klar kann man das immer über kurze Perioden, und da hat, glaube ich, auch die Corona-Phase paradoxerweise Bayern geholfen, weil du hattest jetzt immer nur so kurze Perioden, also immer so Zyklen, neun Spiele Bundesliga, vier Spiele Champions League, davor Anfang Hinrunde, bis es halt dann zu Ende war, waren auch nur so zehn Spiele. Aber wenn du jetzt mal so gefühlt eine Strecke von 30 Spielen bis Dezember vor dir hast, aus einer Haltung raus, wir sind jetzt Trippelsieger und du hast viele Spieler dabei, die sich jetzt einfach ihren ultimativen Beweis ihrer Göttlichkeit geholt haben, also ihrer fußballerischen Brillanz. Also alle, die es schon mal waren, die sich jetzt bestätigt haben, für die geht nicht mehr. Und auch Lewandowski ist jetzt für sich am Ziel angekommen. Und das wird jetzt die ganz spannende Frage, wie kann Bayerns Spielstil sich jetzt noch mal weiterentwickeln und wie kann Bayern jetzt diese Hinrunde bestreiten? Vielleicht, wenn es darum geht, eben dosierter spielen zu müssen, nicht ganz so scharf sein zu können, auch mal in einem Spiel. Oder treten dann eben diese Schwächen- und Sollbruchstellen, die hier und da punktuell natürlich schon aufgetreten sind unter Flick, aber dann noch mal deutlich, deutlich, deutlich krasser zu tragen. Und wie wirkt sich das letztlich dann auf die Ergebnisse aus in der ersten Saisonhälfte 2020, 2021?
Und ja, ein bisschen auch die Frage, also man hatte zwar das Gefühl, Bayern hat den Umbruch schon vollzogen. Also die berühmte Frage Nachfolge für Ribéry und Robben, die wir ungefähr drei Spielzeiten lang gestellt haben vor der Saison. Zweimal war die Antwort, ja, sie spielen, sind trotzdem einfach die Entscheidenden. Und dann, und dann war aber, gab es dann tatsächlich die Ablösung. Und beide haben dann auch ihre Karriere beim FC Bayern beendet. Ribéry, Florence, Robben gleich ganz, beziehungsweise so ganz ja auch nicht. Aber das geht es zu sehr ins Detail. Aber auf der anderen Seite könnte ja der eigentliche Umbruch immer noch kommen, auch wenn es sich jetzt nicht mehr auf diese zwei Spieler bezieht. Wenn ich mir die Startausstellung aus dem Champions-League-Finale 2013 angucke, dann gibt es einen Durchschnittsalter von 26,9 Jahren. Die Startausstellung jetzt aus dem Jahr 2019, 2020 hat 27,9 Jahre, weil da eben Spieler wie Thomas Müller 30 Jahre, Robert Lewandowski 32 Jahre, Manuel Neuer 34 Jahre, Jerome Boateng 31 Jahre mit dabei gespielt haben. Also ist das jetzt dann vielleicht die Herausforderung des FC Bayern? Diesen Umbruch, der so ein bisschen stiller verläuft, weil er sich nicht an zwei Personen aufhängt zu meistern?
Klar, zumal es auch nicht nur ein Umbruch ist, der jetzt so Spielertypen betrifft, also Robben und Ribéry, die haben so viel Einfluss gehabt aufs Bayernspiel. Das war klar, wenn die mal weg sind, das reißt eine Lücke. Ich glaube, die größte Herausforderung ist, dass du jetzt eine Generation mit Neuer, mit Müller hast, die ja diesen Verein, diese Mannschaft ja auch einfach geprägt hat. Wir haben vorhin mal darüber gesprochen, wie es war, als dann Schweinsteiger ging, der ja auch einfach rund um die Mannschaft herum, jenseits wirklich vom Fußballerischen, wahnsinnig viel organisiert hat und wahnsinnig viel auch zusammengehalten hat in so einer Mannschaft, was ja auch extrem wichtig ist. Und wer wächst jetzt so da in diese Rolle zum Beispiel rein? Ja, ein Kimmich ist, glaube ich, auf einem guten Weg dahin. Insofern, klar, der Umbruch, das ist ja eh eine müßige Diskussion, weil der Umbruch ist nie zu Ende. Es geht immer irgendwie weiter, es werden immer irgendwie Spieler weggehen und neue Spieler dazukommen. Aber natürlich, wir haben ja dieser Podcast gedreht, das redete sich ja jetzt auch um zehn Jahre FC Bayern. Und wir haben ja gesehen, dass es einige Spieler gibt, die die komplette Periode eben auch mitgemacht haben. Und klar, wenn die mal den Verein verlassen, wird das wieder die nächste Herausforderung sein. Auch in Oliver Kahn, der jetzt ja fast ein bisschen undankbar nach einem halben Jahr schon irgendwie den größtmöglichen Erfolg hat. Auch der will ja den Verein in den nächsten Jahren prägen. Auch das wird spannend. Wie richtet er diesen Verein aus bisher? Ist das sehr vielversprechend, was er sagt und auch wie er analysiert? Aber natürlich, der Umbro ist nie zu Ende, sondern geht immer weiter. Und die Herausforderungen, die kommen jetzt definitiv. Ich halte nichts davon, der Umbro ist abgeschlossen und die nächste Goldene Generation steht schon in Startlöchern. Das erinnert mich immer so ein bisschen an dieses, wenn jetzt die DDR-Spieler noch oben draufkommen, sind wir auch Jahre unschlagbar. Ich glaube, so funktioniert Fußball einfach nicht, sondern du wirst immer wieder herausgefordert, du musst immer wieder richtige und kluge Entscheidungen treffen.
Ja, und das ist tatsächlich eine Frage, die sich die Bayern-Verantwortlichen jetzt stellen und stellen müssen und gezwungen nach dem Titel stellen müssen. Wie lange geht es noch weiter mit Manuel Neuer als tragende Säule? Wie lange geht es weiter mit Thomas Müller? Oder muss ich jetzt vielleicht mir doch Gedanken machen, wann ich denen wie jetzt die Plan stelle in der Offensive Neuer Sätze? Verlänger ich jetzt wirklich mit Alaba? Oder ist es vielleicht gut, wenn auch dieser Zyklus irgendwann endet und ich etwas Neues dort, in Anführungszeichen, ich habe da jemanden für 80 Millionen gekauft, für den ich aktuell keinen Platz in meiner Mannschaft habe? Was ich ganz persönlich am aller spannendsten finde, ist, wie kompensiert Bayern den Abgang von Thiago, der für mich einfach eine absolut prägende Gestalt die letzten Jahre in diesem Bayern-Spiel im Zentrum, nicht nur sprichwörtlich, sondern buchstäblich im Zentrum, Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt, dass das jetzt wirklich im Zentrum dieses Spiels einfach war und auch in dieser Saison jetzt hinten raus gewesen ist. Wie wird das aufgefangen? Es ist sehr spannend. Die punktuellen Verstärkungen, die sie jetzt sich geholt haben für die neue Saison, bei Sané muss man abwarten. Der hat seit anderthalb Jahren nicht mehr auf höchstem Niveau dauerhaft Fußball gespielt seit seiner Verletzung. QSC, Nübel sind Ergänzungen, die erst mal reinwachsen sollen und müssen. Bei Adrian Fein muss man mal sehen, ob der quasi diese Javi Martinez-Nachfolge, also diese Planstelle im Kader einfach gleichwertig ersetzen kann oder nicht. Also, ja, es ist schon spannend irgendwie. Vielleicht holen sie ja noch einen, der dann diese Thiago-Rolle vielleicht... Also, ich fände es ein bisschen fahrlässig, Thiago gehen zu lassen und für ihn keinen Ersatz zu verpflichten.
Und wo steht der deutsche Fußball? Also, wir haben mit Rabaa Leipzig noch einen zweiten Halbfinalisten in der Champions League gehabt. Wobei, irgendwie, ich finde immer noch, dass die Corona-Bedingungen es zu einer so besonderen Champions-League-Saison macht, dass es schwierig ist, Quervergleiche zu ziehen. Also, aber wir halten fest, da war noch jemand im Halbfinale. Aber wir haben ja auch die Entwicklung, dass von Leipzig der, ja, wahrscheinlich beste Spieler oder einer der wichtigsten Spieler definitiv zu Chelsea wechselt. Wir haben die Entwicklung, dass von Leverkusen der wichtigste Spieler. Jetzt gerade, während wir aufzeichnen, dass das Nations League Trainingslager verlassen hat, die Vorbereitung, um die letzten Details mit Chelsea zu klären, was man so lesen kann. Also der verlässt auch die Liga. Im Grunde deutet das nicht schon wieder alles darauf hin, dass sowieso, wenn dann nur Dortmund, Dortmund allerdings auch mit einigem Nachdruck, bei den Spielern, die man verpflichtet hat und halten konnte, Jadon Sancho, dass es wieder der einzige Konkurrent ist.
Also ich finde es halt auch, ich finde es nicht gut, dass dann auch Spieler wie Volland, Koch, Waldschmidt, auch Goetze, höchstwahrscheinlich, die Liga verlassen. Auch Statistik und Marktwertschätzung von Transfermarkt sind ja nur Schätzungen, aber 17 der besten 40 oder höchst eingeschätzten deutschen Spieler werden nächstes Jahr im Ausland spielen. Philipp Max habe ich noch vergessen, der auch geht. Ich glaube, jemanden, der sagt, dass Bayern und Leipzig im Champions League-Halffinale standen, bedeutet etwas Positives für die Liga oder spricht, das ist ein Prädikat für die Liga und deutet darauf hin, dass die Bundesliga im internationalen Kontext in den nächsten Jahren wieder größer, besser performen wird. Das würde ich doch arg bezweifeln. Das könnte man ja genauso argumentieren, dass die Liga in den nächsten Jahren eine größere Rolle in Europa spielen wird, weil Leon und PSG beide im Halbfinale standen. Auf die Idee kommt, glaube ich, aktuell auch keiner. Es war einfach eine sehr spezielle Situation und es ist immer noch ein Turnier. Vor allem Turnieren nur mit einem Spiel hinten raus. Da können immer mal Anomalien eintreten, wie man ja auch auf EM und WM-Ebene oft genug gesehen hat. 2004 hat auch niemand gesagt, dass Griechenland danach irgendwie die nächsten Jahre den Weltfußball mitbestimmen und dominieren würde. Es war halt einfach ein sehr gutes Turnier. Eine Mannschaft, bei der alles zusammengepasst hat. Und that's it.
Steffen, wie ist da deine Anschätzung?
Ich glaube auch, dass die Bundesliga ein Problem hat oder bekommt. Wir haben ja über diese Chancengleichheit oder Gerechtigkeitsproblematik auch schon gesprochen. Oder die fehlende Spannung. Ich glaube, es ist nicht gut, wenn jetzt auch deutsche Topspieler die Liga verlassen. Wenn ich mir jetzt die Konkurrenzsituation angucke, traue ich außer Leipzig und Dortmund niemanden zu, Bayern im nächsten Jahr gefährlich zu werden. Nagelsmann traue ich wahnsinnig viel zu. Mein Flick hat jetzt auch bewiesen, dass er ein starker Trainer ist. Aber vor der Saison hätte ich gesagt, der beste Trainer der Liga ist definitiv nicht in München, sondern in Leipzig.
Nagelsmann hat 80 Punkte auf Bayern abgegeben in der Rückrunde. Das hast du mitbekommen, oder?
Das habe ich mitbekommen, aber ich lasse mich ja, ich gucke ja nicht nur aufs Ergebnis. Es geht ja auch um Entwicklungen, die man anstößt und um den Fußball, den man spielen lässt. Und dass er diese Rückrunde, dass da einiges schiefgelaufen ist, ist völlig klar. Ich hätte auch Leipzig grundsätzlich dieses Jahr schon zugetraut, eventuell Meister zu werden, wenn man es schon früher geschafft hat, Bayern als sie geschwächelt haben, sogar noch ein bisschen stärker auf Distanz zu bringen. Weil auch das muss man ja in so einer Dramaturgie in der Saison verstehen. Ja, wenn erst mal der Rückstand vielleicht mal irgendwo bei 8-10 Punkten ist, dann kommt eine Mannschaft da auch nicht mehr wirklich zurück, weil dann fokussiert sie sich auf andere Dinge etc. Insofern, ich traue Leipzig das schon grundsätzlich zu, Bayern weiter zu ärgern. Es ist aber, wie bei allen anderen auch, ich weiß nicht, ob der Kader breit genug ist, um eben diese Aufmerksamkeit in drei Wettbewerben, oder nehmen wir die zwei Wettbewerbe, Champions League und Bundesliga, wirklich über die volle Distanz so hoch zu halten. Das ist so die große Frage, die ich mir stelle. Ich glaube, dass Nagelsmann jetzt gerade auch noch mal Verstärkungen eingefordert hat, weil er ähnliche Probleme sieht. Daran hängt es am Ende. Und deshalb nochmal, wenn Leipzig vielleicht auch mal nach der Vorrunde oder so rausgeht, glaube ich, im Hinblick auf die Bundesliga wäre das sogar echt ein Vorteil.
Ich bin so ein bisschen indifferent, was jetzt dann das Fazit dieser Sendung sein könnte. Also wir haben ja immer wieder zwischendurch schon heiß und innig diskutiert, wie jetzt diese dominante Phase des FC Bayerns zustande gekommen ist. Du hast ja vorhin völlig zu Recht, Steffen, Lösungsorientierung gefordert, bei dem, was so kritisiert wurde, auch am FC Bayern, am System Weltfußball und nationaler Fußball. Ich bin ein bisschen indifferent. Also es ist, dass wir jetzt nicht hier bei der Lösung rauskommen, das war klar. Es ist keine schwarz-weiß Frage, wo es auch eine klare Antwort gäbe, sondern es gibt immer verschiedene Perspektiven, verschiedene Rollen. Wir haben ja auch andere Perspektiven wie zweite Liga, Amateurfußball und so weiter. Haben wir ja auch ausgespart. Trotzdem fehlt mir so ein bisschen ein Gefühl dafür, für den Ausblick. Ich habe mein persönliches Gefühl, das, was wir jetzt erlebt haben, ist die Vorhut dessen, was wir so lange erleben werden. Entschuldigung, bis es eine Europa League gibt. Also jetzt nicht die Europa League, Europa League, sondern eine Vereinsmeisterschaft, die in einem Super League ausgedrückt ist. Super League, danke schön. Genau. Das ist so ein bisschen mein Gefühl. Und da freue ich mich ehrlich gesagt nicht drauf. Ganz persönlich. Wie geht es euch?
Ich glaube immer noch nicht, dass die letzten zehn Jahre, die wir erlebt haben, unbedingt der Normalfall sein müssen. Ich glaube aber nichtsdestotrotz, weil ich immer noch, ich habe so viele Momente in Erinnerung, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, okay, jetzt kippt es. Okay, jetzt, dieses Jahr ist es so weit. Bayern wird nicht Meister. Ich glaube schon, es ist ja auch kein Zufall, dass Deutschland Weltmeister geworden ist in den letzten zehn Jahren. Dass zwei deutsche Mannschaften in einem Finale standen, dass Bayern sehr häufig im Finale standen. Es sind schon zehn sehr, sehr gute Jahre für den deutschen Fußball insgesamt gewesen und vor allem auch für den FC Bayern gewesen. Und die Generation, die jetzt nach Müller, Alaba, Neuer, Schweinsteiger, Lahm kommt, wird erst mal beweisen müssen, auch beim FC Bayern, ob sie das hinkriegt. Nichtsdestotrotz hat die deutsche Fußballliga natürlich einen klaren Auftrag. Ja, da sitzen sehr hoch intelligente Leute, die es geschafft haben, in den letzten Jahren diese Marke Bundesliga weiterzuentwickeln, die es geschafft haben, Rekordfernseherlöse zu erzielen. Und die nächste große Aufgabe wird eben sein, ein System zu entwickeln, was diese Liga irgendwie wieder spannender macht und es gleichzeitig den Top-Vereinen ermöglicht, auch europäisch konkurrenzfähig zu sein. Das ist eine wahnsinnige Aufgabe, aber warum soll sich, wenn man das einmal als Aufgabe erkannt hat, traue ich einer deutschen Fußballliga auch zu, so etwas anzugehen und zu lösen. Und ich glaube, das ist der Auftrag für die nächsten zehn Jahre, unabhängig davon, ob ich glaube, dass auch die nächsten zehn Jahre der Meister automatisch FC Bayern heißt.
Ich denke, dass Bayern nach wie vor die besten Voraussetzungen hat. National, dass Bayern international auch sehr, sehr gute Voraussetzungen haben, weil andere Großvereine gerade andere Probleme sportlich haben, in Klammern Barcelona, größere Projekte vor der Brust haben, in Klammern Real Madrid, Stadionumbau und prinzipiell diese Krise für mich, das ist meine These, einfach dazu führt, dass die die Schere zwischen Arm und Reich noch weiter auseinandergeht und Bayern da sehr fähige Köpfe hat, die diesen Vorteil nutzen werden. Kurzfristig sehe ich aber allerdings eben wirklich diese spannende Frage, wie kann Bayern jetzt aus dieser Saison in die neue Saison gehen, ohne dazu großen Reibungsverlust zu haben und ohne irgendwie erstmal schlechten Ergebnissen hinterher zu laufen? Auch unter der Ansicht, dass Flick mit dieser Situation jetzt auch erst mal umgehen muss und jetzt eigentlich die große Herausforderung für ihn erst kommt.
Sehr gut. Hat er uns noch ein bisschen Lust dann doch auf die neue Saison gemacht. Ich würde sagen, das ist echt fast der klassischste Rasenfunk aller Rasenfunk-Sendungen bisher geworden. Wir haben jetzt unglaublich lange gesprochen. Ich habe unglaublich viele Dinge von dem Zettel, also dem Zettel, den ihr kennt. Ich habe hier auch noch einen anderen Zettel nicht angesprochen. Also wir haben nicht mal alles angesprochen, was anzusprechen gewesen wäre und haben dennoch so viel Zeit gebraucht. Machen wir an der Stelle einen Deckel drauf und lassen uns einfach überraschen von dem, was so kommt. Ich danke euch beiden sehr herzlich. Es ist nicht selbstverständlich, dass man sich, honorar hin oder her, wie gesagt, das ist eh nur eher symbolisch, so viel Zeit nimmt. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an euch beiden. Zum einen an Steffen Meyer von mirsandroth.de. Add der Bayern-Blog auf Twitter. Bitte dahin alle Beschwerden für das, was er vorhin gesagt hat. Steffen, danke dir.
Ich freu mich schon. Ich freu mich schon.
Und wann gibt es den nächsten Goodsport-Podcast?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Das letzte Mal gab es ja in der Corona-Pause, da haben wir die Zeit gefunden. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, wir warten bis zur nächsten Pandemie, aber ist es nicht abzusehen. Mal schauen.
Also, Hörer wie ich lächzen danach. Der Goodsport-Podcast kann man aber auch sehr gut nachhören, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Gerade die Folgen zur WM 2006 möchte ich euch sehr ans Ohr legen. Und ganz herzlichen Dank an Flo Jan Bogner von Eurosport, der quasi direkt aus seiner Nachtschicht in die Sendung gekommen ist und den wir jetzt wieder direkt in den Beginn seiner neuen Schicht entlassen. Edflo Pomuk auf Twitter. Danke dir, Flo, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast.
Ja, vielen Dank. Und ich war vorhin richtig gerührt, als als Chefin eine Analogie zum Tour de France gezogen hat. Und ja, als Eurosportler, ich trage natürlich nicht nur den Fußball im Herzen, sondern auch andere Sportarten und freue mich jetzt auf eine US Open-Spätschicht und ein bisschen Tour de France nebenbei. Und ja, schaut doch auch mal bei uns rein. Boris Becker ist sehr gut drauf. Er tanzt, er tänzelt durchs Studio. Ich möchte dich da noch mal mitgeben.
Eigentlich war das ja der geheime Subplot dieser ganzen Sendung. Wir wollten euch die Lust am Fußball verdarben, damit ihr jetzt dann andere Sportarten konsumieren könnt. Tut es gerne.
Also es war sehr schön. Vielen Dank, Max. Du warst wie immer ein herausragender Gastgeber, der so eine Sendung auch trägt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Hau an. Doch, muss man mal sagen.
Dann machen wir jetzt aber wirklich Schluss. Ich habe noch Podcast-Empfehlungen. Auch ich hatte ja eine Sommerpause. Ich empfehle euch drei Sendungen. Das Logbuch Netzpolitik zu Hongkong. Sehr gute Sendung, werde ich verlinken. Radio Nucular hat eine Sendung zu Naughty Dog gemacht. Nicht zuletzt wegen The Last of Us 2 unbedingt empfehlenswert. Und ich möchte euch Gold und Blech empfehlen. Ein Podcast von Sascha Strunk und Fabian Hambüchen. Da geht es auch mal um anderen Sport als Fußball. Diese drei Sendungen lege ich euch ans Herz. Ansonsten freue ich mich, wenn ihr den Rasenfunk unterstützt. Ihr könnt ihn auf rasenfunk.de unterstützen. Da gibt es alle Informationen dazu. Und dann geht es jetzt so langsam los wieder mit dem Rasenfunk. Ich freue mich auf die neue Saison. Ich hoffe, ihr auch. Und verfolgt uns am besten überall in Social Media. Da wird noch so einiges kommen. Macht's gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das war das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.